the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
there's blood in the water at the U.S
women's and U.S open championships in St
Louis the sharks of the Chess World are
hungry for winds and ready to Feast
co-leaders Hans Neiman and Sam sebian
were on the hunt but their prey got away
leaving them circling the top of the
open standings things went swimmingly in
the women's event with three apex
predators still undefeated and tied for
first after ripping apart their
competition it's not safe to go in the
water who will fall victim next day
three of pulse pounding chess coming up
next
[Music]
all right
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the 2022 us
chess championships and U.S women's
chess Championships held here at the St
Louis chess club let's go to the studio
and start the action with Yasser and
Anastasia
[Music]
in the United
Saint Louis chess club and the third
round of the USGS championships and the
US Women's chess championships
hello everyone and here we are I'm
Anastasia carlowicz together with
Grandmaster Yasser Sarah one and only
likewise Anastasia one and only a
pleasure to be with you to call all the
action for today's round hello everyone
thank you for joining the show and what
a show we had yesterday as the
Millennials are not only coming they
arrived Thrills and Spills we use that
term a lot but we had a big spill
yesterday as well as 15 year old
Christopher you took down our defending
Champion let's take a look at our
current leaderboards Anastasia all the
action let's check them so we have
leaders we leaders actually in women
section Jennifer you Ellis Lee and Megan
Lee all of them they have two out of 100
and they followed by Irina Crush um
others by the way no one has one and a
half points amazing and in the open
section and in the open section we have
two co-leaders Sam Seville and Hans neem
and both of them they have one and half
points then we have a group really nice
group of people
gangsters actually
Slenderman and Christopher you
um Also let's not forget about elshon
and we have also two players with half a
point absolutely and our format and the
format we have 14 players in this
tournament in each of them and 90
minutes for the first 40 moves Then
followed by 30 videos for the rest of
the game 30 seconds increment from one
it's very important and of course no
draw offers and our schedule Anastasia
where already we have already third
round and it's 7th of October if you
still remember that thanks for the
reminder I need it
yes and then we have two rest days one
is on 10th of October then 16th of
October and in case of playoffs we have
uh we have them on October 20th exactly
and as we see that the Players yesterday
had some trouble getting through the
security everybody's being wanted very I
want to say severely like and when
you've got 28 players in the field you
better arrive early because there's a
quite a lineup there we see Chris bird
with Alexander been doing the honors but
we're very fortunate to have in studio
Christian Christian break down some of
the action yesterday it was tense oh it
was definitely tense and it's great to
be back for a day three calling the
shots here at the U.S Chess Championship
and U.S women's chess championships and
what two great events we've had so far a
lot of uh decisive chess being played
and let's take a look at the percentages
we're going to start with the open
section 4 out of 14 games we've been
spoiled with a lot of rapid and blisters
in recent months but 28.6 in a classical
uh tournament is a pretty decent
performance these guys are definitely
battling it all out and in the ladies
section well the ladies section is
definitely combative as we shall see 8
out of 14 games decisive
57.1 percent this late the ladies are
definitely here to fight and there are
bringing the action in every single game
and every single matchup and let's take
a look at the upsets that we've seen so
far in the U.S chess championships we're
going to start with the open section in
a very recent memory this one the game
between Wesley so and Christopher you
what a game that was a Bounce Back
Revenge victory for the youngest
competitor in the open section only 15
years of age Grandmaster Christopher you
defeated the defending Champion Wesley
so just an amazing game and I'm sure
we'll be talking about that one for a
very long time and in the ladies section
we had a lot of upsets as well one in
particular that
um stood out yesterday was the game
between the 12 year old Alice Lee
against gulrook peginto hirjonova who
was the leader of the ladies team at the
Olympia then there you have it Alice Lee
Alice's Pawn Palace I think is her show
on chesskid.com and she definitely
gained a lot of subscribers as you were
mentioning Yasser after that Victory
right now she's co-leading the event
with this lady Jennifer you who uh well
she striked first and she striked hard
in her game against Anna zatonski that
was a very very nice game with the black
piece is defended well a very tense
middle game and after that managed to
grab a pawn and translate that into an
incredible victory that was definitely a
big one and Jennifer is a lady to follow
in this event but we still have so many
rounds to go in this Championship it's
going to be an amazing tournament and an
amazing third round there we see Megan
Lee one of the co-leaders of the Women's
Championship for the perfect to a zero
and as we get ready for this round three
uh Anastasia for our audience lay the
table tell them what they can expect
with the pairings starting with the
ladies they become very very interesting
parents pay attention to yourself
Marquee matchup right there I'm going
down to look at Megan Lee versus Arena
Crush because Megan had a perfect score
arena with two draws he's gonna want to
uh bounce back battalia versus Alice Lee
Alice Lee pardon me uh that's another
good one and in the open yes let's check
also the open I just wanted to point out
the Sabina place also today
the former U.S women's champion
apologize you're absolutely right but we
have also really great matches in the
open section same Savion will play
against lemon aronian the leader exactly
absolutely you know you go down
Christopher you versus elshon they're
both at 50 but uh clearly uh they're
fighting uh for swinging for the fences
I want to say both of them scored
yesterday so both of them won their
games and it's interesting what will
happen today exactly there again as I
mentioned earlier uh the uh the line
reminds me of the airport congestion
I've been going through the security
checks exactly 20 minutes before the
round I came to the plane when you just
to check what's happening nobody was
there and suddenly you know everybody
came nobody wants to come half an hour
before right true then you got nothing
to do yes and just wait I don't know
maybe the games have started already oh
yeah no although the snacks are pretty
impressive snacks oh good very good very
good all of them are looked really fresh
and uh interesting because we put it
this way
um for today's matchups Christian uh
which games in particular caught your
eye and this parents well in the open
section I do have to go with that big
battle between Sam shankland who is a
theoretical wizard against one of the
co-leaders Hans Neiman and this one is
going to be very interesting because we
know Sam what he does especially in the
early stages of the game he puts a lot
of pressure on his opponent's time and
this is what I'm going to be looking
forward to because we've seen Hans he
gets very close to his last few minutes
he gets in time trouble in this event so
putting early pressure on your
opponent's clock especially when you see
those Tendencies coming from us I think
is going to be crucial this one in
particular I'm having my eyes off nice
and there we see former U.S Champion Sam
Shanklin putting on his game face I want
to say the man with the Velvet Hair at
the bottom of the screen that's our own
Leonard oats Leonard fantastic and I
think I'm spotting Eric Rosen as well
yes he came today yes
Tony was mentioning at the beginning the
only players and the only people allowed
especially in the playing Hall are uh
the cameraman the Arbiters the players
Leonard and very VIP person so Eric
definitely
very high VIP person of course but he
lives really nearby it will be really
unfair not to let to come and take some
shots kid takes beautiful photos
not not only a great streamer but there
you have it look at that camera that
looks like super pro
Chris bird was checking hair of hands
very very carefully now I Leonard had
this wonderful photo of uh the wanding
of a banana because the caption was you
never know you never know wasn't that
banana you got to be uh
everything today yeah so we see also
Wesley so he's in the queue as well
exactly waiting for his
and as we await the players uh to take
their seats and get properly Wanted
let's just remind everybody what these
players will be fighting for over three
weeks prize money is absolutely
fantastic I mean the prize money very
generous and in the ladies
the latest section we have 160 500
price fund total price fund first place
for
30 20 15. every place looks great and
only the ladies are in the contention
for the sixty four thousand dollar Bobby
Fischer bonus prize but that would
require a perfect score highly unlikely
and what's the prize fund for the open
and for the open section we have also
very decent 262
000 price fund with some 60 for the
first place right that's a record price
fund for any U.S Championship 45
000 seconds 35 000 third all the way
down if you're 14 if you walk away with
5500 so everybody's a winner not bad at
all I mean I think the players are
getting spoiled that's so great prices
here and the clocks have started how do
I know that because I see that tatv is
open one E4 in her game with Jennifer
you again one of our Marquee matchups
Knight F3 and will we see an open
Sicilian I'm absolutely sure because
tatv loves
fighting games and what do you have
Christian behind you well I was just
watching the watchful eye of our
executive director Tony Rich in the
playing Hall as well making sure that
everything is running smoothly I haven't
looked at the games yet but I will get
right on that yes right and I take we
have a E7 E6 Tai Manoff oh interesting
Knight F6 attacking Pawn on e4 of course
Knight C3 is kind of like the automatic
and again
um many many years ago D7 D6
establishing what we call the shenanigan
Pawn formation as black that was very
popular until G4 kind of put it out of
commission Knight C6
today is the go-to move after Knight C3
and you can go into a svajnikov if you
would like
in this style
or just a second
this is also called the classical and
there's been some recent games with this
system is black we'll keep an eye on
that one I just go around I want to go
to Alice Lee again I always like to pay
respects to our tournament leader
leaders in the ladies case and we have
Paris orientation I think yes
but maybe it has different name yes so
it's like black tries to develop the
bishop immediately right he doesn't want
to stay with this bishop C exactly well
the whole game is so he moves his Bishop
very early when the bishop ends up being
stuck on C8 it very often happens that
in these types of cases you this bishop
looks awful until you you know put it on
the long diagonal but like you say you
can solve your problems right away as
does Alice by developing the bishop out
and she's
seeking to provoke the move F2 F3 before
dropping back with her Bishop hoping
that after any trades in this case the
pawn on F3 will make the H2 Pawn
strangely enough more vulnerable and now
we've already looked at Jennifer where's
our other Megan where are you right
there Megan Lee versus Irina looks like
Arena might be caught in the line I have
one move
and that's it the system up there but
right she's still under good chick
security Christian back over to you what
have you uh scoped up we're still in the
very early stages and let's take a look
at what's happening in the open section
as I predicted I do believe that Sam is
going to try to put early pressure on
Hans and on his time specifically with
his opening choices and he decided to go
for this nimso bishop to B4 was the
response so not the D5 of course you can
play D5 and accept the car spot
structures most likely but you already
have the Knight on F6 so that allows my
Bishop to already jump to G5 I'm going
to commit to G5 I'm going to set up this
pressure on the h4da diagonal and this
generally is considered to be slightly
better for white so of course Hans
decides to go for the nimzo and we see
this queen to C2 move I believe we've
seen that in a yesterday's game between
if I'm not mistaken ashwita eswaran and
Rochelle Wu but I might be mistaken
about that one E3 has been very popular
at the top level Fabiano is playing it
Wesley has played it countless of times
as well but he decides to go for this
queen to C2 and we already see a very
early on tanking in his time Hans Neiman
that is his thinking pondering his
options he's trying to figure out where
he wants to direct the game towards and
as you can see him he's browsing let's
say through his memory uh right now
thinking about which lines am I most
familiar with and which lines let's say
I will be able to take my opponent early
on out of the opening because he knows
Sam Shanklin is a wizard in the opening
phase we've seen that yesterday against
Darius Verge he played with the black
pieces that groomfield and uh I think
Darius was saying that yeah Sam can
actually play everything he has the
semi-slav course on chessball but he can
play absolutely everything and grunfeld
was one of the options as well I'm
struggling to just play the groove and
remember my lines semislav by itself is
a huge theoretical uh opening if you
want to combine that with the groove
yeah I mean good luck this guy is
spending eight hours a day trying to
remember and repeating his material so
very very impressive in that one we have
a Berlin in the game between Fabiano and
Darius and this one is speeding up a
little bit as we shall see Bishop to B5
Knight to F6 D3 Bishop to C5 so Fabiano
early on he deviates from his SEC
actually I do believe it was yes his
second uh game against his first game
against laneier that was I do believe
with castle if I'm not mistaken take
take bomb 96 take on E5 Knight to B5 and
now A4 we've seen this idea from Fabiano
in round number one now in number three
he decides to go for the more
critical D3 take on C6 Knight to D2 and
now we have this idea with Bishop to B2
early B3 Bishop to B to put a lot of
pressure on E5 and ask your opponent how
are you going to set up your PCS to
defend this weakness on E5 he decides to
put the queen forward with Queen to D6
not the bishop in general we see the
bishop come back to uh D6 follow it up
with C5 Knight to D7 solidify uh the
support over the E5 pawn and then
potentially play even F6 the queen
generally we don't see it on D6 but in
this particular case this uh was
darius's choice now Knight G5 Knight to
G5 is already on the board on the board
oh very nice and we can see these
players have been uh playing extremely
quickly that's an interesting move my
guess is that we're going to see
something along the lines of F6 then you
have to worry about Queen to H5 but I
don't think that's necessarily something
to worry about because you have the move
G6 so F6 to my eyes seems to be the more
Natural Choice
yeah yeah F6 take the bishop Queen takes
and then we're just going to see
the type of position where white tries
to go King to H1 sidestep uh this pin on
the diagonal and then play the move F or
open up the position on the king side
and make use of his extra space in the
center this is what I'm predicting in
this one Sam Savion oh this one sped up
as well C4 Knight to F6 and D4 we've
seen a Levon aronian essay this move E5
actually with a lot of success at the
American Cup against Ray Robson they had
a match and they were actually Levon was
playing with the white pieces as well as
the black pieces he was starting if he
was white with C4 and responding with
this move E5 and he actually defeated
Ray Robson in a critical game in that
one with E5 so he definitely has
knowledge in this particular case as
well but he decided to go Knight to F6
and now D4 E6 Knight to F3 not the nimzo
but we do have Bishop to E7 Queen's
Gambit decline Knight bd7 and C5 Leon
Knight to H5 we know this line in
general this is considered to be quite
equal if black knows exactly what he's
going to do and generally he follows it
up with B6 B4 A5 A3 exchange there get
the bishop to A6 try to exchange the
light Square Bishops it's going to be a
bit passive for black but nevertheless
the material is limited and in general
you are consider to be quite quite good
as black and look at his shirt look at
levon's shirt yes sharks yesterday I
think in the first round he had the
Sharks right yeah or was it the second
round this second yesterday this year
today almost reminds me of the
Indonesian batik which I love I mean
this is very very very stylish he's
making he's sending a message yes he's
sending a message to the rest of the
field try to catch up guys pay attention
it's not easy by the way I paid
attention that Hans Neiman is playing
with this nice jacket from St Louis
chess club with Sweden US championships
Championship yes Championship okay blue
one very beautiful and you can find that
atl.com exactly yeah he's he's our role
model for our our clothes
yeah always thinking about merchandising
and sales you know of course but I have
very nice Red Jacket actually these days
I got it as a present yesterday probably
will wear it one day also let's see
Christian uh it's the Berlin the Berlin
is the bane of one E2 E4 players and I
see that Lanier Dominguez against Ray
Robson we have yet again another Berlin
but this time the Berlin ending I'm
almost after seeing so many of these d3s
it's almost nice to see the Berlin
ending back on the board
until we don't have it in all games it's
nice exactly until we don't have it all
games and I'm not really sure what uh
Ray is thinking actually he's not at the
board he's not really thinking he still
has one hour and 30 minutes on his clock
so
um it was actually linear who was
pondering his options or maybe he was
just getting winded at the beginning and
he was a bit late to the round but of
course black has so many options right
now you can go Bishop D7 and try to get
the King on the queen side King C8 B6
King to B7 that way or you can try to go
King to E8 in this particular case as
well so it all depends where which side
you're going to put the King on if you
put it on EA that's considered to be a
more tame approach
um and if you try to go towards the C8
score after Bishop 37 that opens up the
opportunities for both sides to
complicate matters nevertheless we're
going to see a very long theoretical
battle I have a feeling in this one and
we know Lanier Lanier is also very very
well prepared player
thank you for that in the game between
uh a Wonder Liang and Alex Linderman
it's I you almost want to call it a
Catalan but it really is not uh White
City and shadowing as Bishop with this
bishop already out on F5
the normal Catalan occurs when the pawn
is on E6 so this bishop is at at home
kind of what Alice Lee has done you know
developing a bishop outside of her Pawn
chain and uh well I've played this
position uh with both both colors rather
solid balanced Affair and just looking
at that Wesley so Wesley so with the
bounce back well not so fast he's
playing Queen's Gambit accepted this
move b2b3 of personal favorite of mine
introduced by Kiva Rubinstein well over
70 years ago the idea is as simple as it
looks this bishop on on E3 pardon me
this bishop on C1 is looking for a good
square with a Pawn on E3 locking
as long as black let's say let me just
make a move as long as black refuses to
trade and open up the bishop the bishop
on C1 rather suffers the idea behind B3
is as simple as it looks uh put the
bishop on a very nice long diagonal and
claim that thanks to your right of first
move that you'll have an advantage and
I've done very well with b2b3 but Wesley
will be very aware of it is he's played
against it many times actually as it's
become more and more popular and Wesley
has just drawn so many of these Queens
Gambit Endings by the way yeah
he waits for that and of course the
recapture with the pawn now makes less
sense because with the isolated Pawn how
does B3 fit into your scheme of
development it does not Knight takes D4
on the other hand
prepares for this bishop to come back
and uh well again early days in this
opening let's just go over to the ladies
I wanted to jump into the game between
Megan Lee and Arena Crush because
whoa we've got some action on the board
here okay classical four nights Sicilian
I want to say uh with D7 D6 Bishop G5
ooh Bishop B5 now that is really off the
Beaten Track I mean
there must be a million games with Queen
D2 everybody that seems to play Queen D2
perhaps F2 F4 is also a popular move
Bishop C4 maybe less so but Bishop B5
for me is a rare bird Megan Megan trying
it's an aggressive I'm sorry I I hit the
wrong key there I don't know what I did
but uh
Megan trying to catch her uh opponent
off guard there with Bishop refi Queen
D3 very different very unusual approach
by white
95
and boy I'm going to have to
pull in our big expert Our Big Chief and
ask a Christian
to break down the game between Megan and
Irina because I'm not familiar with
what's going on well the Big Chief was
actually looking at a different game
you guys caught me red-handed yes but
this is a big one guys I'm not gonna lie
this one between Sam Shanklin and Hans
Niemann is in a very well-known
variation actually of the names of the
queen C2 nimzo Sam Shanklin came with a
bomb at move 10 an incredible novelty
and I'm still trying to figure out
exactly the details but this is what I'm
saying so far Bishop 286 everybody knows
at this position Queen 24 is one of the
main lines Queen to C2 is another one of
the mainlands queen to C3 has been
played as well quite a few times 13
times that is Queen to C1 in never
played and he played it now let's try to
understand the differences if you start
with the move Queen to C2 which feels
the most natural you're supporting the
move uh E4 after that E5 put some
pressure on the h4da diagonal now the
main line almost the main line comes
after H6 Bishop to H4 and C5
black is trying to simplify the position
as fast as possible and get his species
involved in the game if you take on C5
I'm going to take back then I'm going to
jump with the Knight to C6 and I'm going
to I this Square D4 I have to do
something fast because if white
stabilizes the position if white manages
to develop his pieces well he's going to
have a better position now one of the
main lines and actually why this move E4
doesn't work as well in this particular
case you would be thinking about yeah
you take take take E5 and now I'm doing
great with white right I established
this connection with an iPhone F6 uh
controlled by the pin on H4 d a diagonal
but the problem is after King takes F1 I
have this move G5 and this actually
gives black quite nice play you cannot
take on G5 because after HD hd5 Bishop
takes G5 Queen takes a D4 uh you have to
release the pin but also you're a piece
down and there's no attack I mean you're
coming my way Black's way now this is
the big difference in my opinion after
this move Queen to C1 check this out
interesting if you do try to go for the
same simplifying variation that we just
looked at H6 Bishop to H4 and C5 now
after E4 take take and G5 Knight takes
G5 finishes the game right this is a big
difference because you take on G5 I take
back with a queen king to H7 I pick up
uh the Knight on F6 and you're just
simply losing as black so this one is
the big one right now in my opinion this
is what Sam Shanklin looked at uh this
morning this is on his computer this was
on his computer this morning now let's
try to understand H6 Bishop H4 C5 E4
there's also this line very intriguing
line by the way King takes F1 and now
Black's best move in the position and in
fact the only move in the position is to
go E5 whoa exactly you take with the
pawn D takes C5 I have this move Queen
to D3 follow it up with Knight takes C4
I'm fine okay so what are you going to
do after E5 if you take with the Knight
then I just go Queen to D6 I don't take
on D4 because after taking on D4 take on
F6 take on F6 Knight to G4 your king is
in shambles right you cannot do that so
I have to keep contact with the Knight
on F6 with this move Queen to D6
this is so hard to understand and to see
from afar right to see this whole
variation from afar after your opponent
just dropped this queen C1 uh it's not
easy right so I'm expecting Hans right
now to be thinking for a very long time
and trying to figure out the differences
and decide what he's going to choose uh
as his defense big moment right now
Queen to C1 a big novelty that
definitely will be analyzed by a lot of
people
um after this move was just dropped in
this key game at the U.S Championship
well uh Hans is definitely thinking I
was thinking
it's unnerving when you're playing a
player like Sam Shanklin who's so
incredibly well prepared what is this
queen novelty by the way you've been
looking at C7 C5 could black play the
move Knight D7 in order to play G5
without worrying about Queen takes Italy
Knight to D7 right yes yes
boom
you're trying to escape yeah I was
trying to escape you're not escaping I'm
coming after you yes no this is cool
that that Queen is on C1 it helps him
over it helps a lot if you try to go G5
once again 19 G5 works why take uh sorry
take with a queen take with the queen
queen to F4 and uh it does seem like I'm
having quite a good position maybe even
Bishop to G2 and play it slowly oh
Bishop E4 check right exactly Bishop G2
exactly but uh even after G5 I can go
Bishop G3 actually Bishop to G3 and then
just play the move H4 I still have a lot
of pressure given by this queen on C1 on
G5 so if you take after H4 unfortunately
I think you're going to get checkmated
this is what happens when you start the
GSA Tower you know you really go deeply
into position you're finding a lot of
interesting ideas yes good tip you know
for those who want to improve and chess
like just study just this game has been
played so many times there's been 550
games no one played Quincy one by top
players I mean I'm looking at the names
here Mama dear of caruana Wesley sohanan
Nakamura kramnik Anan kariakin
only Elite level players and nobody
played Queen to C1 wow so this is a big
find by Sam Shanklin but also the move
Queen C1 very counter-intuitive because
you're sitting there The Rook on C Rook
on A1 is crying what are you doing
you're in my space
that that that's where it was reserved
for me so very a natural move but as
you're showing a lot of tactical
justifications absolutely important
great Kristen for explaining all this
small details
it's amazing what you could learn
watching videos watching it just I have
a feeling that I'm taking someone I'm
having free lessons exactly now Big
Chief turn Okay
versus Arena Crush because I'm still
it's gonna take a while guys all right
let me let me let me check what's
happening in this one
um we couldn't guess like what was
happening some kind of theory after
Bishop Megan Lee versus sure I'll open
up the engine
um
well Irina is doing well it seems like
it's just that simple yeah Knight to E5
Bishop takes E5 was played which is a
novelty right now Queen to E2 was played
previously okay in the game between
hovanizian is iskandarov and a couple of
other strong players but Bishop to E5
was her choice Megan's Choice
nevertheless how are you going to
continue right now
do you go Knight to B3 do you take on D7
first
which one is going to be Knight to B3
seems like the most let's try it let's
just say what if I just continue A6 and
I'm forcing you to take on D7 but on my
terms take on D7 I don't think you want
to take I don't think you want to
exchange the Queens if you exchange then
I take back with the Knight I'm going to
develop the bishop your Knights are not
as well positioned as you would like
them to be also Rook to C8 is going to
come and that's going to pin the Knight
on C3 it's going to be very difficult to
move it and reroute it to a better
position because this C2 Pawn is always
going to be hanging so there are some
problems in Wise position and I think
you were mentioning it uh Yasser as well
do you prefer to have the center yes and
this type this type of Sicilian uh
encounters and definitely it is black
who has the center controls D4 and D5
squares with authority and I have to say
I think Irena not only got out of the
opening uh and equalized but actually
got out of the opening and is putting
pressure and potentially has a slight
advantage and just one other quick
question for you the move Bishop B5 that
even though you cited a game between two
very strong Grandmasters Bishop B5 is
that uh how often has Bishop B5 been
played because I'm not used to that
Queen to d2ha is is the main line
exactly right but Bishop to B5 is
actually the second choice the second
choice yeah second choice in uh this
position but there is a huge discrepancy
Queen to D2 16 000 games Bishop to B5
300. so
that's pretty significant that's that's
huge all right thank you very much for
that uh Christian as I'll just move to
the game between tatev and Jennifer yes
yeah Marquee matchup but Joko piano the
uh uh quiet game the Italian game as
it's been called and it's all the rage
and please don't ask me to break down
the nuances of uh that there are times
that you play A7 A6 I also play this
variation and then when they play A4 you
play A5 this is incredible it's it's
very very strange how these things
develop but the idea of A6 to my main
just to bring the bishop that's as far
as possible yeah and you kind of
sidestep uh b2b4 as well as D3 D4 still
early days here in this game and let's
take a quick look at oh now this is a
game that's going to site rexingfield so
Jennifer shahadi has been teaching Rex
somehow in all of their lessons they had
together the Grand Prix attack stuck yes
like that finally connected with Rex and
he just loves this F4 F5 castles uh
Queen E1 and queen H4 and go Checkmate
uh his opponent so let's just see how it
happened so it's kind of what you might
call
um
a closed Sicilian there's no D2 D4
that's interesting that begum wanted to
include the move Bishop B5
to say that the bishop is worse off on
D7 than on C8 I won't try to explain why
that's the case and F5 wow uh guns
blazing uh right out of the opening the
idea is if you do take not that you
necessarily want to go Knight G5 instant
but there are ideas of castling
where white is ready to coordinate a
very uh powerful attack against the F7
Pawn oh okay we'll keep an eye on that
the shritha versus Naji okay looks
pretty tame uh two Bishops slight
Advantage for shritha I would say in
this position Rouen versus Sophie
now this is for me kind of one of those
uh classical
Sicilians where you got this English
attack brewing with G4 G5 but this open
C file the Knight coming to D7 maybe
quickly to E5 a great Clash from these
openings the open sicilium love it
and Sabina versus Anna to a former U.S
Champions crossing swords here Queen's
Gambit declined with a very early h2h3
essentially what this move uh suggests
to me is that Sabina does not want to
see the Knight capturing the bishop with
E3 Knight but h2h3
yeah that loses some time I think this
is about even and finally Talia versus
Alice Lee when we left it we had seen
the move Bishop E4 and by the way the
players are playing very quickly it says
to me that both players are in their
home prep
as we we're now up to date with the
players interesting idea I think it's
considered to be like a little bit
better for white because of two Bishops
sure I'd say yes this variation but
still people keep playing well one of
the one of the real you know there are
two Bishops and then there are two
Bishops yes this bishop on D2 is not a
two Bishop put that Bishop on F4 or
where it's really exciting it can be uh
so there's it's going to take time for
white to develop the advantage of the
two Bishops normally speaking white will
play a move like King B1 to uh tuck her
King away and there we have her 12
12 years old perfect score looking for
that Bobby Fischer prize of course 64
000 if you can make a perfect score as
did Bobby Fischer back over to you
Christian and uh tell us what
developments are taking place in the
open section well I'm just trying uh not
in the open section oh sorry because you
asked a question about one point you
were asking what the difference is we
start with Bishop to B5 follow it up
with Bishop to C4 or you play Bishop C4
first and leave the bishopon C8 and
there's a couple of reasons why you
would do that now with the bishop on D7
in the position that we currently have
imagine this with the bishop C8 when I
take on E6 I'm not hitting anything I am
hitting the pawn on F7 but I'm not
hitting the bishop and that might be
important now also what is uh Black's
main counter play in this position
probably in the center right you're
going to slow something along the lines
of Knight to E7 and then you want to
play D5 with a [ __ ] Pawn C8 and the
queen active you can support D5 quite
easily right you're going to go Knight
to E7 and then D5 comes immediately so
these are a couple of differences that I
immediately see uh in the position also
if you do take on F5 now one of the main
moves except Castle is Bishop to F4 to
attack the pawn on D6 once again with a
[ __ ] Pawn C8 you wouldn't attack that
on uh on D6 and I would just have time
to do something else play something like
Knight to E7 or something along those
lines so there's a couple of uh my new
details that matter in the position and
actually the bishop on D7 doesn't
actually help black at all because most
likely black is not going to Castle
alongside so these are the couple of
differences that I'm seeing in a
position between Bishop to C8 and Bishop
on D7 thank you for that but especially
that Bishop F4 that really does expose
why the potential of the bishop being on
D7 is kind of one of those in the way
kind of uh moments uh let's just take a
look at the open section I'm seeing
Christopher versus Alshon Alshon has a
sacrificed upon early against this kind
of Catalan C5 Bishop to C6 the idea from
Black's point of view is if he can just
simply recapture this Pawn by playing
Bishop takes C5 Bishop takes C5 oh look
let me make a move on the board uh
Bishop takes C5 for example
Bishop takes C5 a couple of ways for uh
to continue to continue one is just to
say okay go ahead you you captured but
yes I get to capture you back I get a
nice uh Tempo and then we go Queen A4
I've checked
another way for black is if you Castle
is I can start with Bishop to D5 with
the idea that I'm going to uh win the
pawn back on the next turn so the key I
think the critical question is can I get
away with B4 exactly
okay but now you you your eyes should be
immediately uh open yeah you just play
the move before yes really I just played
it okay and you know you immediately
start to think okay how can I use it how
can I exploit that exactly how can I do
that uh or should I just ignore it all
and say go ahead I still want to win the
pawn I want to play oh sorry how could I
exploit the that diagonal well one way
is to say okay uh let me make a bad move
what's a really bad movement
that's a good move
for example right but unfortunately it's
not it's not bad enough because
I need something really bad I guess I
can't exploit the fact that the Rook on
A1 is no but B6 seems to be really
interesting I'm not sure what about B5
after B6 that's Bishop D5 then yes okay
so yeah this time important time for you
right so then I mean try B6 move is
really really logical because this you
want to open the C file yes and use the
fact that this queen is on C4 and
finally uh also a similar idea of
undermining the two pawns uh the pawns
on uh B4 C5 it's just to play A7
A5 attacking the bee Pawn threatening to
capture threatening to capture if you
play B5 just that same irritating uh
move of Bishop D5 is going to cost the
pawn on C5 so we'll keep our eye on that
one let's go over to Lanier versus Ray
Robson this is the Berlin Berlin ending
and this is a very different look that
I'm used to okay so everything's quite
normal Bishop D7 this is one of those
lines where the king slides over to the
B7 Square
with King C8 oftentimes in the Berlin
the king ends up on E8 but here we see
the King on C8
and black is trying to preserve his two
Bishops King G2 there is no Checkmate
coming because after for example a move
like Rook D1 aha I see it
and uh just uh sidestepping that
Checkmate King G2 and I suppose the
players are in still in theory but first
take first takes is I think black is
more or less okay because he always has
this bishop D5 move and I've seen so
many times uh black playing A5 and A4
and thanks to this bishop you know
bearing down on this diagonal it's very
hard for white to claim an advantage
Christian are you seeing positions where
players can claim an advantage and what
about Hans Neiman while Hans Neiman will
get there in just second because he
actually did make a move okay and Sam
immediately responded we'll see that in
just a second it does seem like this
King to G2 is an interesting idea by
Lanier he played it immediately and it
is indeed uh the novelty in this game
Bishop to E3 was played in every single
game in this particular position once
again very very powerful games we see
grishook versus Wesley so leko versus
Adams zverch versus Wesley so as well
Bishop to E3 was played in that one
Bishop takes E3 take on E3 are now H5
this is the typical way these players
are usually approaching this position
now he starts off with the move King to
G2 and I'm kind of trying to understand
what the differences are for example
what if I just simply go H5 how do you
protect the pawn on uh G4 and now we
understand why the king is so important
in the end game to support the expansion
on the king side King to G3 comes very
interesting idea by linear and corked by
a linear and we know once again he's
very well prepared he knows exactly
where to look for ideas in the opening
and I know he
applies the Berlin end game for
countless of hours during our camps as
well he was one of the guys tasked with
this particular opening he's definitely
aware of what needs to be done and where
there are important wrinkles in these
openings are so
this is what I'm seeing an interesting
idea by Lanier Rey is going to be
thinking for a very long time now
I anticipated Hans will be thinking for
a very long time as well trying to
understand what's happening in the
position but he did play the move Bishop
to B7 sidestepping all these ideas that
I showed after age six and uh C5 after
the move E4 and he immediately sidesteps
that with a move a bishop to B7 setting
up additional control over the square E4
it's very very important that E4 is not
going to happen right in the position
and immediately Sam responded with H4
this is big right right H4 are you
kidding me where are you going I haven't
created any hooks I haven't played G6
you're not going to go uh H5 what I'm
seeing in the position is that he
actually wants to go H5 if you allow me
go H6 and soften up the dark squares
around your king now most likely after I
play H5 as white you're going to respond
with the black pieces so let's make a
couple of moves Knight to D7 for example
let's say H5 H6
[Laughter]
yes let's go I'm not sure about uh
four G4 things of this nature yes that
is definitely something that this is
a bit too much right why did I put my
queen on C1 yes I want to give the
bishop but no I I do believe that H5 and
after that probably Bishop H4 and then
G4 G 5 try to take advantage of the hook
the newly created hook on H6 there's a
lot of things that once again Hans needs
to be considering at this point there's
a lot of ways in which black can play
this position he can start off with C5
he can play the move Knight D7 you
probably don't want to start off with H6
that feels a little bit off at least to
my eyes because you're creating that
potential hook for my g-pawn this is a
very interesting game guys and as we can
see Hans is deep in thought trying to
understand hey what have you been
looking at this morning
on your computer Sam yeah I you know
this is what Grandmasters always do they
they uh
contrast and compare on your board if
you could instead of the move Queen C1
um Christian if you could put the move
Queen A4 on the board I seem to recall
that when Gary Kasparov was kind of
making a comeback into chess he was
coming up with these H4 ideas
and uh
actually got some very decent positions
when he when he when he came back yeah
no Queen A4 is one of uh the main lines
right and right the idea is that you
cannot develop your knight you cannot go
Knight D7 you have to keep contact with
the bishopone A6 so right you can start
off with Queen to D7 and in general
after Queen takes D7 this end game has
been worked out and is considered to be
uh equal right Queen takes E7 Knight
takes D7 if you do Retreat to C2 now
sure I don't have the square for my
knight the square D7 but I do have speed
because now finally my Rook is ready to
get involved into the game so I can try
try to open up the position as fast as
possible with the move C5 you can take
on F6 take on F6 and destroy my Pawn
structure on the king side but you still
have a lot of development issues that
you need to solve as white so you're not
in time once again this has been worked
out as well and it does seem like it
leads to an equal equal position
we do have to move H4 in the position
though Queen to C1 Bishop B7 H4 hunts
right now under tremendous pressure and
you know that this is most likely just
the beginning of Sam's analysis right
I'm looking at Bishop takes F3 and I'm
trying to understand what if I just
simply take the pawn right right Queen
takes D4 this is an option yes but
perhaps after H5 right once again I
don't think you can allow H6 H6 your
dark squares are going to be uh very
very weak H6 and now Bishop to E3 Queen
goes somewhere let's say queen to E5 the
problem is now I have ideas of f4 put my
Bishop on the long diagonal as well
there seems to be tremendous
compensation in the position for the
pawn but we saw Hans fronding a little
bit thinking hey what if I just take the
pawn maybe he's considering Bishop takes
F3 and queen takes D4 and just simply
take the bull by the horse
nice thank you uh Christian for that
by the way uh
through all of that elshon did play the
move B7 B6 the move that we were looking
at he is alternative a785 uh he
eventually uh rejected four B6 taking a
look at uh Sam uh Savion versus Levon
aronian uh very very theoretical Affair
I've seen so many games uh from these
positions many of them attempt to just
end up in draws as we see lines like
after Bishop Essex let me just put a
move on the board rookie one H4 is a
move I've seen lots of moves in these
positions just to kind of give a flavor
of what we can expect these types of
things where it's very difficult for
either side to make too much Headway
Rook A7 Rook A8 whenever you drop a
knight on E5 I'm kind of just taking
that and the pawn structure is well
there very similar
Jeffrey versus Wesley again this is this
Queen's Gambit accepted line Wesley is
just been neutralizing some of the the
best players in the world as black with
his Queen's Gambit accepted Alex pardon
me a Wonder Liang versus Alex lunderman
the bishop stepped up to E4 that's a
it's always nice when you can neutralize
the bishop on G2 but with the bishop on
e4 I'm assuming black is going to play
B7 B5 in the very near future and then
next year five later or not and then I
will jump somewhere yeah find a square
as as we would say uh Fabi versus uh
darush after we saw Knight to G5 we were
kind of expecting F7 yes F7 F6 uh go
ahead and take my Bishop well darush
said well let me kind of soften you up
here maybe ideas of A3 and Bishop D4 are
on tap Knight F3
castles
interestingly he didn't he didn't Castle
immediately sorry he didn't Castle
immediately not
wishing to invite a potential H5 but
okay he played A4 and once the Knight
was on F3 only now castled and now
Knight H4
aggressive
Greenwich greenish five problems in the
air but yes as well as Knight F5 and I
find it intriguing that uh that neither
player seems interested in playing F7 of
696 or just Knight takes E6 right away
uh for the moment this bishop is great I
love this bishop this Knight is less
great I mean this Knight really is
looking for a better Outpost than the
one on D7 I would say Advantage white
but just small I kind of prefer Bobby's
position and then it's really about the
same Shanklin versus Hans Neiman and
there uh I I think you you you were
Christian you were saying uh a very
Salient question that has to be asked
and answered is what if I take the poem
yes
two Bishops half open G file no question
we can talk about compensation can we
talk about an advantage less sure but
what Hans felt was that those positions
might not be fun it might not be fun and
let's let's go to Knight C6 now usually
the Knight is very badly placed on C6 as
it steps in front of the Pawn on uh C7
but he's doing it with a very concrete
goal of like
forcing you to play a move like E3 when
the queen is no longer enjoying this
ready
six right yes not only that but maybe
with the queen on C1 I can take
advantage of that and play after E3
maybe Knight day five right yes I'm
hoping to that's another hit because I
want to go Knight B3 you have to lose
another Tempe probably Queen C2 and then
I can go I think C5 now without the
Knight on B8 I am ready to go Rook to C8
and pin you down right if you do take on
C5 so it does seem like black is getting
some speed and some momentum in the
position I don't like the move E2 E3
somehow that doesn't gel uh with
everything I've kind of set myself up
for precisely may I ask I am not the
pawn I'm not a person to sacrifice upon
I want to assure you don't don't call my
Bluffs
can we have a look okay I'm obviously
your goal is to take
and I want to go E5 and please please do
something terrible like opening up your
king side with Bishop takes and Rook G1
no no you're not going to do that that's
clear but I'm sacrificing the house
after E5 you can take my knight with
your Bishop if you like I'm not going to
retake that by the way yes you can go
for my Rook
don't tell her don't tell her
um no I mean uh E2 E4 okay I
maybe agent no I will take your Pawn you
will take it yeah of course wow okay E5
I would take the Knight with a bishop
with the bishop okay now I have to pause
because no the problem is with queen of
fortnite
that's a big issue
your attacks with Queen D5 no I'm not
going to take back you're not going to
take Queen I want to get active I want
to check wow
and she's a big fire
uh uh this is really bad I'm feeling the
backfire it is it is which means I have
no alternative between F4 it's good to
check I I if if I don't like E3 because
then my queen on C1 why did I put my
queen on it's crying but I don't want to
lose the pawn tonight takes D4 so I have
to defend the pawn maybe reinforce the
attack what about Queen F4 Christian
Queen F4 is the best it's the best move
in the position yes and it does seem
like if
Samsung finds it and he stops right now
definitely he did not look at Knight to
C6
quite an interesting situation because
Knight to C6 after Queen to F4 it does
seem that white is building up some
pressure and actually gets an objective
Advantage exactly in the position yes
and again if white could ever put his
Rook on C1 in such a way that the pawn
on C7 is a backward Pawn the Knight on
C6 will Rue the day that it landed on
the Square
um
whenever you go H6 yeah you're not
actually threatening to take on G5 so I
can just go E3 or E4 and just continue
developing yes because this age file is
you get me yes yes
it's a patient's important in general
you don't immediately rush in with
checks yeah just six yeah
yeah and I like what you did there you
put the queen on H2 because with a queen
on H4 yeah
that was a nice Instinct yes yes did you
calculate all these or just your
greatest
I did see that H4 was available
the phone was on H4 it was in the way I
never had the square H4 I had the square
H2 in mind all the way yeah uh but it's
okay but that's an important point that
the move H6 doesn't immediately force my
hand I can leave it on pre and well in
that case by the way if I can leave it
on pre kind of makes I could play
something
hyper aggressive you know uh something
like this but okay but in any case I
even like the ending maybe it's not a
huge advantage or anything like that it
always strikes me that these endings
were again if the night were on D7 Pawn
were on C5 we're not talking Advantage
Knight on C6 is going to take you a
little while to solve what's going on
here so okay we'll keep our eye on it's
important that he plays Queen to F4
though Queen to F4 is a key move in the
position but it's nice after it's just
to have this chance to play E3 you know
what okay yes you're threatening me it's
okay I just play E3 and also I just want
to take a moment to shout out to our
audience once again thank you so much
for joining us but also you have an
opportunity to quiz our panel of experts
I like the way I got that in uh quiz
ourselves ask any question and like that
Anastasia Christian River I about the
tournament uh openings uh what have you
and we'll be happy to take your
questions and they should write to us
that yes everybody can write in Twitter
account yes our Twitter St Louis chess
club okay also follow our social media
and Instagram and in our YouTube channel
as well if you missed any interviews
from yesterday from the previous days
you can always find them there I saw you
posting a picture a video I want to say
of Christian dancing to the Romanian
Samba not yet but it's coming it's
coming yes and we do have some questions
let's have a look at them ask the
commentators so we have a tweet from
ratnesh
um and it says like what makes USGS
Championship different from other
countries national championships what
changes would you like to see in this
event if it's a national championship
wouldn't be better if it was an open
event with a minimum rating cap and the
first one I like the most
well thank you very much for the
question first of all I'll take it from
top the U.S national championship is by
far the most prestigious uh domestic
tournament that you can play in because
it gathers the best of the best the
creme de La Creme of the Chess World
really comes and that's why I don't like
the open events so much as these round
robins and in fact I really like the
concentrated round Robins this is a 14
player event that's a real Marathon
event wouldn't it be cool to have like
four players playing each other three
times so I really like these double
round Robins
events for the national championships I
think that's the most prestigious type
of play and especially if you can play
one time black and one time White
against your arrival that's why I like
the double round Roberts I think they're
the fairest second thing what would I
change for the event oh that's easy
double the price one
the players would be really really
really really happy it's not enough
already
it sells and yes sir no no minimum
rating cap one of the things that I love
about the these national championships
and the 14 player is yes you get a lot
more Juniors yes you get the US Open uh
qualifier so um
yeah I wouldn't change anything yeah but
I remember the word different for
CES right that's the title I mean you
went through all these different types
of types so which which one I mean you
played uh well I always played in these
uh round Roberts we did have some kind
of
semi-open where it was like a Swiss that
was mixed feels and things like this
round Robins but for me I never got a
real chance to play in them were match
play I would have loved for example you
know say today the top two players
Wesley versus Fabi I'd love to see
examples
two great uh players and uh again the
same same thing for the ladies
everything is going great I just think
the biggest problem for American women
players they need more opportunities yes
the Karen's cup is great it's wonderful
it would be really really nice if there
was a grand Chester for the ladies as
well
and Christian over to you uh to the
question from uh our Twitter what would
you change about today so many questions
in that tweet
they love you yes sir
so I'm not even sure if I want to
respond but I will try I will try okay
so what I would like to see um something
similar I really like the American Cup
format uh the matches uh including Rapid
and Bliss chest as well the armageddon's
that was quite a lot of fun but also
it's testing the might of these players
not only in classical chess but also in
Rapid and blisters which I tend to
believe that they are also part of Chess
and part of assessing who is the best
player in the United States so maybe
that's what I would do I would not make
it an open definitely not I do like as
you specified as well all these
qualification methods uh you can go
through the US Open you can win the
Juniors as well you get to be a wild
card potentially so there's a lot of
ways to qualify to this tournament and
that incentivizes the players to work
and participate in these events
disqualifier events as well so I
wouldn't change that but maybe I would
try to find a way to include uh both
rapid and Blitz into the mix as well
your two cents there what do you think
about these national champions I think
they're great I think it's a trade to
mark of St Louis also chess club how
many years already you have this year
yeah it's like everybody I don't think
it's only
um famous Championship inside of us
everybody is following because you have
really top players participating I mean
also that the fact that you have such a
great price fund here
um I mean all two players are
participating right I mean they're not
only us two players they're World
performers so I know many people they're
watching from all over the world even
though it's National Championship
exactly one of the things that uh the
question also what's a little bit
different from the other national
championships first of all the strengths
of the fields absolutely yes and then
when I think about for example the
Russian national championship it's
absolutely wonderful like seriously
amazing when all the top Russian players
play but those Russian national
championships of late they don't get all
the top players it's like the the price
funds for those tournaments doesn't
necessarily draw out the very best The
Prestige of winning the national
championship yeah that's important but
the players are also saying you know
like the prize funds have got to be
better also for women's shoes
yes I mean for women us Championship I
mean everyone the women actually every
woman in the world who just play well
she wants to be become American because
everybody wants to go to American
Confederation after that I understand
what you mean so very well and again you
have these countries where they have a
really uh great great uh players a large
number of great players but the national
championships are underfunded frankly
and it doesn't draw out all of the very
very best players so if you think for
example about tournament country like
India phenomenal country with great
great numbers of players national
championships They Don't Really feature
this one I found a non if you if you
feel where I'm going on this one so okay
maybe it will actually develop us soon
with so many youngsters in India it's
really impressive I mean we have of it's
also important that we have Champions
who won this title so many times like
Irina Crush for example participated
here on my place there was a Peter
sweetler not long time ago eight times
I mean it's really impressive results as
well exactly yes so and I I think about
the the days when Kasparov and carpath
would play in the Soviet championships
and then oh my gosh then they started
around wanting to play against one
another in the Soviet championships they
saved their clashes for the West yes I
was wondering when you played the
championship I was I was thinking like
what was your first price you won at
that time now that we were talking about
oh well this was the real problem for me
was because it was an asymmetric risk
playing in the national championships
I'm trying to get into these European uh
round robins and get very nice
honorarium and the national
championships when I was playing in
America were like sixty thousand dollars
for 16 players okay uh first applies
maybe six thousand maybe and now we have
the last one yes
gaming on some of my national channel so
I ended up declining quite a number of
national championships not the least of
which by the way there was often times a
clash between a tournament and the
national championship so I I didn't play
in as many and it's really nice for
example to see somebody like Fabi who
you know was fighting for the
championship of the world the number two
rated player also playing in the
national championship oh that's cool
every time actually
who won five time times this
championship and uh okay we don't have
him this year but he used to participate
even at the times when he was number two
in the world I think right so it's
really impressive that you have this
field and I mean they're famous all
around the world not only here exactly
exactly thank you for the question uh
indeed uh we just want to say once again
our gracious thanks to the organizers
here in the St Louis chess club for
putting on such a fantastic tournament
and also to doing their best to ensure
fair play we kind of make a little bit
of a joke about the screening but yeah
it's very very serious uh turning to the
game first back to the game did sang
Shanklin find Queen F4 is it just might
he did yes and actually Hans responded
with Queen D6 Queen David six right okay
aha yeah it's time to change those
schools
do you write uh
okay I mean my first instinct would be
like I I really take everything I love
messing up my opponent's Pawn structure
but the problem is is I don't think that
uh my opponent would oblige Me by
capturing the pawn would play something
like Knight E5 instead so my first
instinct would be like okay uh maybe I
should just play for the two Bishops uh
you know drawing my horns a little bit
play E2 E3 invite a queen trade and just
uh meet Knight D5 let's say with Bishop
back
um
I wouldn't say I have any you know great
advantage or anything like that I'm just
Pleasant yes
and is there something Anastasia is
there something sharper for white in the
position that I could spice things up is
90 95 595 the only thing I see but I
don't know what happens after Queen it
takes deep or Knight takes deep I takes
before with 92.
I think I I think I'm making life
difficult for myself uh any
um a Christian any chance for Sam the
spice things up after the solid Queen D6
maybe not spice things up but definitely
change the Queens on his own terms uh
the way to do that is actually to
continue with your initial plan after
you played this move H4 to continue with
H5 try to destabilize the position uh
around the black king now for example
and this is very very important if you
do go H6 right the queen no longer
protects the Knight on F6 so what I can
do is take on six right you take on F4 I
take back Pawn up you take on H6 I take
your knight that spawn up as well as a
Checkmate coming against your king so
you don't want to see any of that on the
board you cannot play the move H6 you
have to take take Knight to D5
potentially but now we see uh the idea
behind this move H5 I improved my
position I gave my Rook more space but
also I kept the pawn on E2 so I can play
the move E4 and destabilize the the
Knight on D5 in one move without losing
any tempies so I think after Bishop to
G3 it does seem like white has quite a
dominant position so H5 I think right
now is critical and could potentially
give Sam Shanklin quite a significant
Advantage lovely a nice little subtle
touch like H5 a lot very obvious when
you just realize that Bishop takes H6 is
now it's always in the air but as we
prepare for our first break tell us tell
our viewers what a q Boutique and five
percent discounts for friends and family
available what do you have for us what's
the specials actually it's a Champions
jacket yes the one which actually hunts
was wearing and today the blue and the
red yes there's some blue and red that
literally actually Rena Arena Crush was
she has it today so these jackets are
really great for the season for fall
season it's really perfect time and we
have them in red and blue for men and
for women I have the red one for example
the jacket actually features a screen
printed Champs logo on the front and the
screen printed St Louis chess club logo
on back and it's available right now in
our Cube dick shop online I mean really
great stuff yeah so I liked it very much
yeah it looks nice I got a swag bag
myself I'm sure my wife Yvette is gonna
be so happy when I return around we'll
see you on the the other side of the
break
you may have heard about St Louis's
world-class Museums Art History Science
even magic
but you may not know we have an entire
Museum dedicated to play with a 10 story
slide and a ferris wheel on top
don't let all this family fun Slide by
you
[Music]
whose kids it is Saint Lou is always
exploring anybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
.com
[Music]
foreign
can you hear it
it's the sound of Hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
Healthcare
[Music]
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
Ascension
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
championships round three and we have
current standings Jennifer you Ellis Lee
Megan Lee are still leading
coming in around with no results thus
far yes that's exactly right true and in
the open and in the open we have also no
results so in this case we still have
sam7 and Hansen even they type for the
first place with one and a half points
with all the gangsters chasing them
behind jumping into the game games as
Sam Shanklin did not essay that very
nice move H5 instead he played a move
that really looks to my eyes as
exceedingly natural he played the move
Rook on A1 to C1 bringing his Rook to
the half open C file looking in the
future to take advantage of the C7 Pawn
then came the move Knight D5 by Hans and
this is really a rod I find this move to
be rather provocative myself takes takes
and e2e4 uh let's get the party started
now if we go back a moment ago I was
looking at Bishop takes F6 and D5 well
I'm actually doing it an even more
favorable circumstances so I'm assuming
the Knight intends to drop back to E7 in
this case once again it's two Bishops a
very nice center right I mean even after
normal movement Bishop D3 I'd probably
in such a case be interested in keeping
my king in the center one difference is
that with the Knight not sitting on F6
you uh black
could play for the move F7 F5 but again
this this position
um with Knight D5 I wanted to say I I
find that move Knight D5 a little bit
provocative sorry no I agree I agree
with you and by the way they did play
the host ooh he went back to F6
that is surprising uh E2 E4 and uh it
feels like this whole interplay
Christian between The Rook coming to see
one is uh favorite Sam Shanklin oh
absolutely I mean you have a very nice
Center you have the two Bishops uh this
end game screams uh and it wants to be
better for white right I think it is I
think it is better for white after just
the normal move Bishop to D3 right sure
defend the pawn on e4
um develop your position as well
there's no reason why white wouldn't be
better at this point also white has The
Rook already on C1 taking full control
of the C file you don't have the
opportunity at least not up to this
point you have to lose a couple of moves
to play the move Knight to A5 because
I'm going to invade immediately via the
C7 Square you don't want to see that on
the board
probably Rook to C8 is going to be a
long defense for a black in this one but
I have to say
um this one is play on one goal and
white is not risking much in this end
game absolutely Queen C1 paid a very
handsome reward one of one of the
reasons why I really like Fisher random
is because you don't have games like the
game between Jeffrey Jean and Wesley so
no insult to either of these two players
but it's sort of like they went from the
opening went right to an end game uh
they bypassed the middle game as you can
see many many moves have been played
essentially all the position got hosed
white is a pawn up but only it's a
symbolic extra Pawn because of the
presence of the Bishops of opposite
colors makes Black's tasks so easy he's
going to put his Rook on B2 it's going
to play G6 and he's going to go Bishop
H4 and he's going to tie white down to
the defense of the F2 Pawn such in such
a way that the extra Pawn is not going
to have any weight I see a draw uh in
coming very very very soon
and uh let's see where would you like to
take us uh honestly I don't ask you that
enough what's up
I mean we have our uh what do I say our
predictions yes yes and uh let's go to
uh Jennifer uh for example yes exactly
because we have a bottle there yes and
it's important I don't know what the
answer what we will do if it's not a
draw today I'm not sure what is
happening it will be sad
uh okay uh when we left it it was the
Italian game with uh these nuances
rookie eight Bishop E6 so Tata said you
know what I want to keep my light
squared bishop and Jennifer said
let me play for D5 take advantage of the
center
it takes takes and with this move Knight
H7 I think we're caught up with the
players yep and all these are typical
Maneuvers right you might have one not
just three I mean this D5 move and the
fact that that we've decided uh not to
let her opponent to take on the four and
she took on D5 so I mean Knight H7 also
was a dn9g5 I mean all these ideas I
mean they're in the air the question is
always like how to put them in which
order right but the thing that that
I'm attracted to is this uh concept of
freedom of pieces like right like whose
pieces this bishop if you will shines
brighter than this bishop yes
that's what I mean like the Queen the
queen like we can imagine I don't say
that white should do this uh it's
probably in fact a very bad idea but we
can imagine Bishop B3 and I'm gonna just
make some silly moves for a moment and
once again we see that relax Queen is
shining more brightly than wise Queen so
if nothing happens after this Knight on
H7 and the next two three four moves
Black's going to say why aren't I better
why aren't I just playing Queen D7 Rook
d8 putting pressure on the backward Pawn
on D3 you got to do something to justify
this now from White's point of view
white might be thinking well like my nh2
yourself these kinds of maneuvering
ideas the idea behind this might be to
play for Queen H5 and Knight G4 a very
good day you've got the sacrifice sorry
but I'm not sure maybe Queen H4 is
coming and then just to check yes with
the very small like idea to take this
three for example right and if you
cannot play Knight F5 because of tool
that in this hand again
um I mean what what do you need to play
Queen G4 now or queen G4S if you really
want it yes
even Bishop E3 isn't even on my list of
happiness but okay maybe on a good day I
get to go Knight F5 in Queen G4 again
trying to justify whatever it is that
I've done by keeping the pieces on the
board going back to this moment I'm not
100 sure about the decision to play
Bishop C2
if you want to trade Bishops go ahead
and do it yes it's also yes typical
ideas just to keep the bishop right
there and yeah until your opponent takes
it if you don't want to take it on the
six yes exactly so we'll keep an eye on
this one let's go to uh I want to say
Maiden Lee and Arena Crush when we left
it we kind of felt that Arena had
already bypassed equality maybe had even
a small Edge
I don't know where's that King going
it's not so so obvious to me that uh
arenas for choice in this one look at
this mortgage for you I mean it's you
ask questions yes by playing it before
like what are you going to do now you
don't really want to take on H4 because
then H6 is going to be quite weak
but now it's possible right right and uh
just this basically means that this Rook
is going to be Tethered to the defense
of H6 Pawn all right kind of warming up
to Megan Lee's position and again
reminding everyone she started to oh as
did Alice Lee uh against Talia she's
playing against Talia this was the two
Bishops yes and let's just catch up
with the players and here we are
okay Alice is dreaming of a queen side
attack based on C4 but for the moment
her Queen is under pressure and by the
way
Italian gets to play Stills before night
still see no I'm thinking there's a
knight D6 here I was thinking if you
play C4 in this position I would rather
go for the two Bishops if I can yes I'm
96 okay I take Bishop Texans we could
pause because you do have a you I mean
you can take on A2 but you could start
well if you're gonna go on you might as
well you should take yes and uh two
Bishops yes two Bishops you cannot do
castling this Rook is a little bit stuck
on h8 right now
this is double-edged uh White needs one
or two moves to get her grip on the
position Rook C1 and E4 would do that so
for example Rook C2 actually is not a
very good move just to remind you of a
background Checkmate and position hmm
but we have a special guest in studio
Christian back over to you thank you
Yasser yes we are indeed with Emily from
The World Chess Hall of Fame you are one
of the curators at the world just Hall
of Fame tell us Emily what do you guys
do there yeah so we do all kinds of
things related to the history of Chess
just earlier this week we had Hall of
Fame induction so we have Eugene Torre
in town as he's been on the commentary
earlier this week and we also had Jim
Tarzan um here and they were both here
for the opening ceremony and were
inducted into the world in U.S chess
Halls of Fame oh sorry we also we also
have a big exhibition up right now for
the 50th anniversary of the 1972 World
Chess Championship match and that is a
great one actually uh the 1972 match
between Bobby Fisher and spaski tell us
a bit about that
yeah so 50 years ago the most famous
World Chess Championship ever happened
and it has a big impact both for us here
in the U.S on American chess but also at
the hall of fame because it inspired the
chess campus co-founder Rex sinkfield to
really take up the game so we have
artifacts from Bobby and boris's
childhoods all the way up through their
later years and I know you guys have
some uh artifacts that you recently got
can you tell us a bit about that as well
yeah so we have some special artifacts
on loan to us that have to do with Boris
basket's career but we also have some
really fantastic new donations that are
drawings and watercolors of the match
that were done by the artists LeRoy
Neiman for the match he was on the
television show Wide World of Sports and
he showed off what was going on and so
those are really special additions to
our collection I have to say that just
an incredible exhibit and if you are
here in St Louis and if you have time to
go visit Chess Hall of Fame you should
definitely do that Yasser Anastasia you
guys want to join the conversation I
absolutely Emily you said that this was
the most celebrated match in world
championship history I want to take you
to task on that one uh 1886 St Louis
hosted the first world championship and
it got International press
that's true that's true we have a deep
rich history of Chess right here in St
Louis that's continuing today Emily
thank you very much for everything that
you guys are doing there at the World
Chess Hall of Fame thank you for having
me thank you Emily absolutely and indeed
uh World Chess Hall of Fame just across
the street really is amazing very
impressive I know that the World Chess
Hall of Fame sent several people
including our varusian to Paris to talk
to Boris baskey Jr yes about his
father's collection and we got we have a
number of Boris his paper on loan yes
very very nice yes very interesting
letters and I think that also this match
had a big impact on Iceland as well USA
was was mentioned but I think also
Iceland really so many great Masters
appeared to so many people love chess in
in this country right after this match
people still remember I mean of course
not so many but some people remember yes
the match and then of course the fact
that Bobby Fischer lived for a few years
in Iceland as well at the end of his
life I think also influenced a lot the
fact that it's funny you should say that
because of the opening ceremony I was
talking with lotus the step bomb of
Wesley so and Wesley was being
interviewed and he's going to go in
November after the U.S championships to
Iceland to defend His World Championship
Bobby Fisher 960. exactly so he had been
asked were you why are you going to
Iceland and instead of saying I'm going
to go defend yes I'm going to go visit
Bobby Fisher's grave
sort of like really yes
you've been there yes I have not Gary
Kasparov has I've been I've been myself
yes there was a tournament I played in
the tournament 2008 or night I keep
forgetting but I but I played and I I
have done it yes I think like everybody
should do it well I will go and play
with my respects no question about it
but it's funny what you said that didn't
care that much about the defending his
style yes let's remind our viewers it's
gonna be a really important event the
world championship 960 will take place
in Iceland really really soon
yeah a lot of good players are going to
be there just checking in on the ladies
looking at the game of ruian versus
Sophia I this is a really a a very
important moment strategically and I
really want to emphasize uh the capture
that Rue Yang made right here right now
and it it made a very powerful
impression on me as a teen growing up to
understand that with the move C2 takes
D3 this is a hugely important recapture
you might be tempted to take with the
queen
No in fact this Pawn on D3 does a great
job at keeping this Knight out of any of
the crucial Square C4 and E4 furthermore
white is ready to play Knight on A2 to
C1 to B3 and take advantage of the open
C file so this
I want to call it a high class recapture
with a C2 takes D3 by Rue Yang just a
very good instructional moment going on
there in that game a shritha versus
Nashi oh boy there are two Bishops and
two Bishops the bishop on E1
terrible put it on E3 and I'm all I'm
all in favor of White's position this
doesn't look
um
no it's not uh going to be Advantage
whatsoever actually it's a threat even
yes the one is the threat no yes
the bishop is actually yeah you might
even be tempted to play a move like King
F1 or even Queen E2 just to cover that
threat oops sorry Milo I think that was
my mouse click I apologize for that uh
Vega versus Rochelle this was the
remember F5 yeah let's just check in I
mean again Rex is probably somewhere
saying how come you guys aren't talking
about the Grand Prix attack uh how could
we forget takes takes castles
Queen D6 or shells getting ready to exit
the stage right and have we caught up to
players no we have another moves uh
Knight to G5 yes with the idea if you
make this castling then Knight F7
surprise yes right Knight F6 we have a
fork then yes and now comes Knight E2
okay so pretty clear idea by begum she
just wants to capture this Pawn on E6 by
taking and if we have takes the
desirable D5 runs into a problem
yeah
that is a real real problem uh looks for
the moment that it's big Advantage here
for uh vegan because one move you really
don't want to play
looks like Rochelle's in a fair bit of
trouble in this fund uh Christian
absolutely yes you are completely right
about that Knight to E2 uh is a very
strong move because it immediately it
doesn't give black time right because if
black manages to launch castle and
defend that pawn on E6 black probably is
going to be fine unfortunately you're
not in time you cannot long Castle
because I take on D4 and then you no
longer have two Protectors of the Pawn
on E6 so big questions are being asked
right now of Rochelle how are you going
to deal with this position and I was
looking through the lines D5 seems to be
the best move but to be honest the
continuation of that line is just
inhuman uh very very difficult to find
it over the board with so many options
available for example maybe we can
yes sir I've got it I've got it on my
board
yes I thought about it now I take on D5
you take on D5 yeah I take on D5 first
okay you take back with a pawn I take on
D4
now of course if you take any of my
pieces I'm going to throw in a check
your king is going to be weak forever
right if you take on C4 or D4 I'm going
to throw in a check Queen to E2 and I
think you're going to be in trouble not
only that if you take my Bishop I also
have 96 coming right that's bad bad news
no
you don't have to take any of the pieces
what you have to do is long Castle right
now come on and this one might be the
only one that somehow survives really
the next few moves and I think it's very
much tied after Bishop to B3 you take on
D4 but Knight to F7 yeah even to the
naked eye it doesn't look like you're
escaping at this point it looks like a
decisive Advantage right it does so this
is what I'm seeing I'm seeing Rochelle
under tremendous pressure out of the
opening and it's going to be very
difficult from a practical perspective
to defend this position what I do see is
probably you have to play the move into
E7 you don't want to play that move no
but what else exactly what else King to
E7 seems like the only uh feasible move
unless you see this D5 and Castle long I
don't think
25 in this position when your king is in
the center still it's not natural it's
really difficult uh just checking in on
a clash between two former U.S Champions
um Sabina and Anna we had this was the
H3 Queen's Gambit decline looks again
like this Carl's dad Queen's Gambit
declined structure in this case however
I am favoring white because after the
move a2a4 this so-called minority attack
the classical yeah
it's it's it's it's it's yeah and then
and it can be very very annoying for the
second player especially as she's not
getting in the much desired night uh on
F6 to E4 often time so the queen is
actually on E7 supporting that night
getting to the E4 Square so I do uh
think that Sabina has outplayed uh Anna
to get to this position one more look at
Alice Lee again I'm sitting there you
know shaking my head 12 years old and
what she's doing done in this U.S
Championship so far is extraordinary 2-0
and here she's actually of course she's
just
suffering a little
um white after for example Italia is is
thinking uh several notes she wants to
take advantage of the fact that Black's
King is still in the center but it's not
so easy to do that you know moves like
Rook seat Rook D2 and Rook D1 kind of
slow just I'll just leave it at that for
a moment if I'm in Italia's shoes one of
the things I'm thinking of doing is
limiting my opponent's options if I
could play a move for example like E3 E4
I'm keeping this night uh
stuck and I'm thinking that I'll play
Rook C1 and double the Rooks and try
yeah and try to enjoy the two Bishops
with a little bit more activity
especially at certain moment you're
going to want to play the move A4 so
that this bishop on E2 really oh it
starts working in a nice way
no I will probably do that to what the
queen says yeah they're coming off the
board uh back over to you uh Christian
and tell us what uh caught your eye I'm
looking at this game between Sam
Shanklin and Hans Niemann because a lot
of things have happened since we last
saw it I think we left it somewhere
around this point
um Bishop to D3 was the last move we saw
H6 was hans's response Bishop takes F6
take on F6 now we see a damage structure
but more importantly we see more
activity infused into whites pieces now
King to E2 came Ruto C8 Rook to see The
Rook to C3 Knight to E7 and now we see
massive exchanges coming on the C file
Rook takes C8 is what I expect to come
on the board and the question is how is
this end game what I'm seeing is a few
weaknesses specifically I'm looking at
this point on H6 later on in the later
stages of the game so how can I take
advantage of that well I think you have
to couple this weakness on H6 with the
weakness on D6 as well so you can start
with the move Knight to D2 start looking
at ideas of potentially Knight to C4 and
invading the other Square D6 and for
example if you go something like into f8
king2f3 King to E8 Knight to C4 King to
D7 sure you got to the defense of the
Pawn on D6 with the King but you left
open the Avenue for my king to go
towards your other weakness the pawn on
H6 very critical weakness and once my
king lands on H6 your knight is going to
be forced to defend but unfortunately
for you I have a lot of ways to create a
pass Pawn not only that but I also see
avenues for my Bishop to get to H7 in
Target that night on G8 it's all about
how active white species are in
comparison to Black species which are
very very passive so I'm seeing the same
game once again it is Sam Shanklin who
must be quite happy with the outcome of
the opening because right now he's in
pole position to put a lot of pressure
if not get a decisive advantage against
Hansen even thank you for that question
and it does feel like a play on one goal
if you will I mean you got a weakness
there you got a weakness there let me
tickle you here let me tickle you there
well you know what I noticed that this
road which the King has to H5 if we had
this Pawn on H5
it would be closed right yeah I just
understood that maybe he kept the spot
on H4 I don't know just in case you
never know never very deep understanding
myself I don't know exactly going to the
game of Megan Lee versus Arena Crush for
uh just a moment uh I think this is a
very key moment the move Queen E2 so
when we left it we had just seen the
move H4 trying to take out on the king
side create some weakness upon
weaknesses that you might exploit Arena
played the move a G4 and Megan said well
I don't want you to be able to defend
the pawn on G4 with the move H5 so I'm
going to stop you I'm going to play H5
myself artificially isolate the pawn
maybe on a good day I'll play even Rook
to H4 pick it off
so Irina said I'm throwing down the
gauntlet I'm going to play this move
Knight B6 and because this Knight on C3
has only two Defenders I'm Gonna Knock
maybe I'm away I'm gonna play for Knight
C4 maybe Knight takes B2 or Knight C4
and queen B6 now what are you going to
do about that uh oh Megan said I'm going
to pursue
my idea that I started with which was to
isolate the pawn on G4 I want to attack
it and win it and if you play Knight C4
In This Moment threatening Knight takes
B2 I'm prepared to play the move Rook D3
defending against that threat of Knight
takes B2
how are you going to defend G4 now in
these positions as every good Sicilian
player will tell you we're always
looking to sacrifice in exchange right
oops yes Rook takes C3 so let's just see
if we can for a glimmer what would
happen now should I take or play even
before yes
well I'm a pond Grabber I have to be
true to my nature uh Queen takes uh is
it worth it uh
what I can see that if you take the
spawn on D4 then you immediately will
play Knight C4 right and then
that's a winning thread in fact Knight
T4 I have to uh in fact
now that I make a good move yes now that
I've blundered meet one I better show it
I was going to say I really need to
trade Queens Queen D3 and maybe I can
turn the tables actually if we if I
could get you to trade Queens then that
whole exchange sacrifice is uh it
doesn't work doesn't work
and if you do go Queen A1 check and kind
of grab the pawn well I'm no longer
afraid my king will will will Dart to
the king side and I've got uh Rook A1 so
maybe it just doesn't work and Megan is
throwing a gauntlet down to our
eight-time U.S Champion Christian and oh
it works just fine it does it does I'm
going to catch you right there yesterday
it works just fine does it
[Laughter]
no no what I want to do is King E7
followed by Rook to ca defendant okay
and then Queen to B6 or queen to A5 and
there's no way you can escape
King E7 Rook C8 and queen A5 you get
checkmated I can also go B5 and queen A5
as well in the Knight on C4 first and
then follow it up with landing on A5
that's going to come with devastating
consequences so you have to be extremely
fast as white to be able to escape the
best way to escape right now is
extremely difficult to find it is it
starts with Rook to D3 okay okay hinting
at the idea that you want to go Rook to
D1 followed by Rook to d8 or root D7
right right Queen to B6
yeah it's it's not easy to find not easy
to find this this is a very difficult
defense to find uh good luck with the
time ticking down finding this route to
D3 your king is completely yeah wow you
don't want to see this on the board so
Rook to C3 is an option right now for
explaining why Knight C4 is a good move
because I don't know what I did
it was intuition you felt it you felt it
I get that nice to see four okay but the
slow but B5 or King E7 or Rook C8 and
it's strange I can never get my king and
Rook to A1 in my broken anytime I even
attempt to play King B1 I just walk into
immediate mate yes so and you also don't
have time to take on G4 right because it
runs into the same problems the Knight
on C4 is no longer under attack so I go
Queen B6 Queen B2 Queen to B1 one and at
least at the very least I'm going to
pick up a rook but I think it's going to
be even worse yeah it's going to be even
worse than just a that's a rook that's
even worse yeah I find it I find it I'm
incredulous that even though I have one
maybe two
Tempe uh to deal with this very scary
thread of B5 and queen B6 that I don't
have anything better than Rook D3 and
rook d8 and you know why no because of
that pawn on E5
controlling the D4 Square very very
important that doesn't have Rook to D4
that is clear I am definitely missing uh
that uh Rook to D4 and Rook to D1
um it's a very concrete line Queen C5
also there is a threat right
that's a problem also yes the Knight is
not hanging uh you keep protecting the
night ah nicely spotted yeah Queen to C5
is a big one yes also yeah it's not that
easy to protect I don't know Irina is
thinking right she's definitely looking
at the wrong things secretly of course
yes the problem is you have to see
Knight C4 right right because Queen
takes C3 is also very tempting right you
get close to the king Knight C4 if you
have one more move you're going to check
me it's game over it's game over right
but this queen to D3 does seem to save
the day for a white not Queen D2 yeah
that was a mouse live that's a moment
I'm gonna blame the battery I mean it's
like the casing is yeah casing is wrong
Queen to D3 yeah and actually it is
white who is much better like you know
in fact it's kind of funny you're doing
me a great favor by taking that C3 Pawn
off the board not only is it costing you
a Tempo but that C3 Pawn you know I now
I can't go c2c3 and get out of my my
difficulties Knight C4 it's looking yes
completely and also it's kind of funny
because I'd really just like to just go
running to the king side you know Rook
D3 and Rook D1 but uh every time I play
this move Rook D3 I'm running into Queen
B6 and I'm not I feel like I'm running
in molasses it's really really slow wow
okay we'll see if Arena and what are the
clock Times by the way yes it's
important let's check how much time
because arena is definitely uh
calculating yes
lots of time 51 minutes still Yes again
42 years so she will she just will spend
maybe like 10-15 minutes checking all
the possible opportunities in this
position for sure yes exactly there is
this Golden Rule not to spend more than
15 minutes right
away yeah yes I I I've run into so many
players especially uh those who really
have gone to training schools I want to
say uh Olympic trainings where they say
guys 15 minutes make your mind yes or no
right yes no maybe yeah I mean those
people spend 40 minutes on Lanier
Dominguez never went to those uh Summer
Schools uh he didn't get the memo that's
for sure this will happen seriously when
you don't have this basic education you
only have this 2750 rating and then you
suffer all your life
too right you have to suffer with your
27 50. uh no response by Rochelle to
begum's Knight E2 this move really puts
a challenge uh to uh Rochelle as she's
staring down the barrel of this bishop
as well as this Knight on G5 I buy
eyeballing the E6 Pawn that was actually
wrong what yes I was actually wrong
that's a first is it possible how is it
how could you be occasionally so keep
going with that line that I showed D5
yes take on D5 take on D5 Knight D4
Castle Bishop to B3 yeah
and now you actually know you don't take
only four but you play rookie eight or
Rook f8 Rook d8 or Rook hf8 which is
just ridiculous I mean and now we're not
going to calculate this and realize that
oh no if the Knight moves you go C4 you
get some compensation nice this is crazy
it's crazy you cannot play this type of
moves
without being severely wanted on your
way out
maximum velocity in terms of wow rook f8
and that's very very nice and our social
media is working yes
so questions the last one was really
good it caused us to really think about
it and here it comes yes here we go how
are the players liking the new plane
space and what kind of snacks do they
have there okay uh first of all I think
that the players are not so happy about
their new space it's okay it's tolerable
the problem is they've been spoiled by
The Club at the top floor they had the
East Wing The West Wing they had this
huge board room they have all the nice
bathrooms and although it's not cramped
you can see uh there's no no place for
spectators so it's it's just enough okay
it's just yeah but the reason why we're
in this new space of course is because
they're expanding from six thousand
square feet as Tony Rich said to thirty
thousand not bad at all so uh the
remodel is uh causing this hiccup now
the snacks are really good I went over
there and they have these Strawberry yes
chocolate berries
and I mean that's pretty good stuff and
of course all the soft drinks and
coffees and teas actually this next
they're separated I think it's the
reason for that everything is the small
boxes you know and because the reason
for that I think it was from Corvette
period that they don't have it in a
common let's say plates but it's every
snack is in it has different packages
packages yes it makes sense interesting
I've been there today it felt a little
bit different than during the single cup
when we had only like five boards
something like this now it's like a
little bit tight I would put it this way
like you have to find your way right
there but still looks really beautiful
with many many nice pictures on the
walls from previous US championships it
it looks really beautiful on that
by the way on that I'll come back to the
question for a moment but first we have
one more uh question I wanted to ask you
about snacks but let's see them next
week okay let's see the next one and
we're looking for challenges uh so much
that's an interesting deal ipdx yes so
do the players ever talk to each other
during their game or is it prohibited it
is it is yes absolutely yes there is no
way don't do it sometimes it's just
accidental do you know where the sugar
is you know I mean where's the herbal
tease you know but yeah
I'm not going to say zero tolerance but
yeah don't do it I mean it's actively
discouraged on the exact same second
where you ask where the sugar is Chris
bird is going to come and when do you
them and you know that right now I
wanted to ask you guys about now we have
been here on these broadcasts we take
our breaks we get our nutrition
five and a half hour game six hour game
your tummy starts to question what's
going on
but you don't want all the sugar in your
body to get over the blood in your body
to go to your tummy and
so you don't want to eat during the game
but sometimes you have to what do you do
for snacks yeah I remember I used to
bring like bananas chocolate fruits and
chocolates I remember also that for
example Boris girlfriend has this kind
of habitat to have a coffee before that
the time travel I think always here
there's coffee at certain points of the
games like has a system and I remember
that in China we were suffering without
coffee together like we were sharing he
brought some coffee from Israel and he
told me if you want it also taste crazy
because I was also sleeping at certain
point even though I was not playing so
this kind of habits the players they
have I know that the demogram Nick he
used to bring the special boxes even
with some snacks okay so everybody has
his own approach I think for me it was
all and there you go what you said the
Packers vegetarians vegetarian rolls
look at that they get the spicy
shrinches oh I think we have to use it
oh that's a very important I think a
break as being called uh going on strike
for the next 15 minutes
I'm going to go get myself this is
player's only area but by the way yes
sir I have to confess that I broke the
rule and a few times I took some berries
from them because the previous events
they could go for sure
how about yourself Christian your coach
you're working with a lot of players
what do you recommend well it very much
actually depends on when they start
their games and right now we're starting
at 1pm central time here in uh at the
USGS championships and it's very
difficult to have both breakfast and
lunch yes before the game so you're
probably going to have a major breakfast
at around let's say 10 maybe 11 and then
you're going to try to survive for those
five and a half six hours and that's
exactly why you see all this uh extra
roast beef and swiss wrap things of this
nature that can actually fill in your
tummy and not only sugar based
ingredients right I generally don't
recommend coffee I recommend tea I think
that's much better than coffee coffee is
too much of an upper to my taste and I
don't actually follow that fruit
I do like my coffee
you can give him a yellow card the
example unfortunately but to my players
I usually recommend uh tea and a lot of
players do that a lot of players
actually don't drink that much coffee
they drink a little bit in the morning
and after that during the game they tend
to go to their tea and I think we've
seen Jane pomniashi here in saying yes
he always brings his flask with tea and
we've seen Hans Neiman during this round
he was drinking definitely some tea so
they're shying away from the coffee it
seems like and for good reason and
Victor korchnoy and the good old days he
liked a dark chocolate not to be
confused with no chocolate dark
chocolate it was bitter I didn't like it
is like 85 chocolate or something but he
liked the dark chocolate he swore that
cyclists used it for concentrated
impactful energy and also Yogurt by the
way what about yoga growth I mean this
kind of story was scarf
what kind of color the blueberry yogurt
man moving the night the strawberry and
moving the bishop yeah that was great
Baguio City uh Baguio is Philippines as
Eugenio Torre said they hosted the World
Championship it was quite something
special karpoffing coach night oh my
gosh uh what a rival the that was
talking about rivalries let's jump back
to Tata versus Jennifer for a moment
because this has been that Italian game
we left it after the move Knight H7 and
we were wondering what tatv had in mind
as she's well I mean it's E5 versus D3
and obviously the pawn on E5 is
controlling much more space than the
pawn on D3 what was tatv going to do
queen E2 Queen D7 a very useful move I
must say first of all it takes away the
the knight from jumping to the FI square
and I always had this rule I don't know
about you Anastasia
when is the opening completed
pieces or you removed your queen
connected your Rooks right
yes so the problem is we have these
three phases of the game opening middle
game and game a lot of players say Well
when is the end opening over I always
had it in my mind that the moment the
Rooks got connected
now we're in the middle game now we
start making our plans some people don't
have these uh it's not a real hard and
fast rule but this principle Knight H4
can I ask you something for example
Richard Robert who never makes a
castling when he's opening the end
normally I I was trying to to check some
of his games that he in one tournament I
think he didn't do castling at all for
like a few rounds so all about the
opening success so everything I just
said comes with an asterisk the asterisk
says uh except where Richard reports
concerned these rules did not work for
Richard they didn't work for Alexander
morozevich either it seemed to be like
those two guys in in particular uh had
the right to violate all of our cherish
but this is the next level right that's
understanding that's what always say
first of all you have to follow girls
and then you don't follow them but you
know why you do this exactly you have
the re you have your reasons I I would
make a move for Victor I would recommend
a move for of course not even said to me
yes sir
before you violate the rules of Chess
understanding you should first know them
I was like oh thank you
Victor was tough Victor was tough Bishop
E6 okay that covers the F5 Square once
again and again from Jennifer's point of
view she she's intimating that she would
like to play Knight G5 and remind white
there is a part on H3 and is that it we
caught up to the players nothing the
players are playing very slowly what is
that what are the times yes let's check
the time because I was a little bit
blind yeah exactly do you see that that
font is like two I mean okay my girl has
more time This is
[Laughter]
40 44 minutes against 34.
premature blindness I'm blaming the
producers on this one uh Bishop E6 uh
Jump Right In on this one Christian this
is a very uh even though the it's early
days this is only round three uh this is
a big fight between Tata and Jennifer
how do how are the computers assessing
the position a huge fight and still were
in the early middle game so right now
they're just trying to maneuver their
pieces try to get them to their ideal
squares right that's why we see this
move Bishop to E6 because what the white
is intimating at this point is that she
wants to get her Knight to F5 one of the
knights to F5 and get closer the king
sacrifice on G7 or H6 that's why this
move Bishop to E6 makes a lot of sense
the computers are just saying that white
is slightly better but nothing major
with normal moves Bishop to E3 maybe at
some point you want to include this
queen into the attack as well maybe
Queen to F3 or queen to H5 it's still
very early on but guys check this out
Megan Lee vs Irina Crush
does this remind you of something she
found it Rook takes C3 B takes C3 and
did not take uh the pawn on C3 did not
go for the material but understood that
slow play right now is King and in this
case Queen Knight to C4 is the movie in
the board and I have to say Rook to D3
is such a difficult concept to see I
understand you see Rook to D1 but you
have to be ready for Queen to B6 right
if you don't see Rook to d8 you're
completely lost at this point you get
checkmated Rook to d8 Queen takes d8 E1
King to E7 check this move out I'm not
gonna take on the aid with the King I'm
not going to take uh with the queen on
the eight I want to include this Rook
into the attack as well you don't have
time to take on h8 because you get check
made it boom boom and the game is over
so what you have to do is actually
follow it up with the D7
get it on the D file and find really I
have to take you take on C4 and now we
play this position but to my eyes at
least after King to E7 it just feels
like the black king actually is quite
safe because you don't have the dark
squares to attack it from you don't have
you cannot fly your queen to A3 and even
if you do I'm going to go to F6 I'm
ready also for the end game this Pawn on
H5 after King to a E7 imagine all major
pieces off the board I'm going to go
King F6 King G5 I'm two moves away from
capturing your weakness on a tribe and
that's going to be a winning end game
for black so definitely it does seem
like this uh middle game situation
favors Irina who is putting a lot of
pressure on one of the co-leaders going
into this round Megan leave we're going
to have to wait and see even if she
manages to find this Rook to D3 to
continue the game if she doesn't she's
going to be in deep Waters and I really
not to be honest in both games against
abrahamian in round one and and as uh
Sabina foyer in round two she did have
favorable positions maybe even
objectively winning positions so right
now she's fine-tuning her game and it
does seem like finally she found the
right solution in this one and she's
putting a lot of pressure on her
opponent now let's take a look at what
happened in the beg him Tokyo Nova yes
versus Rochelle that one after Knight to
E2 well Jan Rochelle thought for a very
long time and came up with this idea
Knight takes E2 Queen takes it to an E5
you're not losing anything major
immediately there's no Knight to F7
because I can go Rook to f8 I even have
ideas of D5 but right now the problem is
after Knight to E6
Bishop takes e66 Bishop takes E6 where
are you going to Castle where are you
hiding the king do you want to go to E7
I don't think so if you do go to E7 the
problem is this bishop is going to land
on G5 set up this pin and you're going
to have huge problems with the Knight on
F6 right at the same time you probably
have to go for this but everything is
working in White's favor at this point I
have the two Bishops I have this pin
landing on a G5 with a bispawn G5 and we
actually have the move A4 which is also
a great move uh by white just taking
more and more space on this side
accommodate black species once again if
you want to go there nope you cannot go
there you're going to lose an exchange
Knight to F7 if you're worse
strategically and you're also down in
exchange on the board not good you
probably can resign at that point so you
have to stay with the king in the center
this is not good news for Rochelle Wu
and also she spent a lot of time on this
last couple of moves right now down to
her last 25 minutes against 45 minutes
for a beg him Tokyo Nova with a lot of
moves to go 6 16 26 excuse me more moves
to go we're only at move 14 right now
and Rochelle's body posture is not
looking good exuding great confidence by
the way before the move a2a4 I flashed
on this position as well and I wanted to
say oh my gosh there's a winning
combination with Knight F7 and somehow
like I just saw that Knight F7 Rook f8
Bishop H6 Bishop takes H6 Rook takes F6
is absolutely devastating for white
because if Knight takes to E6 Chad group
takes D6 ideas so I thought oh it's over
until I started calculating D5 and it's
sort of like Knight takes Pawn takes and
it's not over over no because was the
90s trap right exactly the night is
trapped and it's that move D5 that hurts
my feelings so I really uh light this
move very much by begum a a2a4 uh there
are these ideas that that the bishop
like for example uh even though it
doesn't work it's just worth noting that
there's always this discovered check and
fortunately in this case you do have
Bishop E3 to deal with it but kicking
the queen with the move A2 A4 kicking
the queen away from uh the defense of
the Pawn on D6 by playing A4 A5 very
useful and I I like this move a lot and
by the way King E7 sometimes you've got
to do what you really really really
don't play the disc he did play King E7
social advises to play A5 move which
would make it completely crazy you know
look at this white squares after
possible A5 for Blake if let's say black
would who played
A5 uh herself stopping this idea yeah
just look at this white squares I mean
you cannot do this no more yes
not uh what Rochelle wanted to see uh
came to this day's game and in the open
section uh
you're still Christian right
I was about to say Alejandro but I
caught myself
no change no change no changes yes
Crystal changing the garden what has
caught your attention well actually I
was looking at every uh game and I was
trying to see where we are Sam seems to
have uh went for this end game thinking
that he probably is better due to the
fact that he has so much more space than
his opponents facing the centers space
on the side and at some point you're
going to have to find the break uh he
did play this move B5 taking away even
more a space and squares from his
opponent yeah it doesn't come to C6
doesn't have that Landing Square anymore
now what I would be worried about wise
position after this move B5 is that you
close it too much right and maybe
perhaps you're not going to be able to
find Alternatives later on in the game
to break through and make that final
push King to G7 keep King stays close to
the H6 Pawn so definitely anticipating a
potential land of the white King on H5
you don't want to move the king away
from that keep the King on G7 and the
question is how is white going to break
Sam is going to have to find a solution
for uh Del Fabiano versus Darius still a
very tense middle game and the players
are shuffling a little bit with the
Queens right now Queen to G5 Queen to E7
Queen to C1
not Queen takes C7 don't go into the end
game the end game seems to be too dry
and I think black can safely say that he
equalized so Queen to C5 Queen to C1
excuse me was the choice for Fabiano
still keeping this idea on tap King to
H1 followed by F4 this is the key idea
you have the bishop already on B2 you
want to open up the long diagonal and do
some damage there so this one very very
tense as well Jeffrey versus Wesley yeah
not that much has happened
at some point this Rook uh is going to
get exchanged Rook to D1 Bishop to C2
and the opposite color uh bishop and
game is just simply going to be a draw
we don't expect any other result in this
one this one was very intriguing the
game between Christopher and elshon and
it went through a lot of transitions
let's take a look I think we left it
somewhere around here after this move B4
actually long time ago this move B4 and
the move before was not aimed at
necessarily uh defending the pawn on C5
but after B takes C5 what he wanted was
just to pass pass by go B5 follow it up
with A4 A5 and try to later on in an end
game create a pass Pawn very close to
promotion at the same time I have a nice
blockade on your Pawn C5 at this point
black had the opportunity to play the
move Knight to B6 he did not spot it if
you go Queen to B3 try to keep contact
with the pawn on B5 well that's not good
because you're giving me too many
tempies I'm going to be at C4 and you
have to drop back to B2 then I'm going
to follow it up with Knight wave at some
point you're going to lose the B5 pawn
and you're going to be very nice in
trouble so he did not play that move
Knight to B6 he played the normal very
natural Bishop to B7 Rook to D1 A4
Castle A5 this was a cool move Knight B6
very nice
offering the uh transition into an end
game which probably was the right choice
for white so in fact Rook takes d8 seems
to have given white a tremendous
Advantage Rook they C8 Rook takes C8 and
now the move Knight to E5 or Knight to
D2 Bishop takes G2 has to come on the
board if you accept the fact that you're
going to leave me with two Bishops and
the potential of a pass Pawn on the a
file that's not good no bueno you cannot
do that so after Knight to E5 you have
to take on G2 take on C4 Bishop to D5
Knight to D2 you do have the two Bishops
I have an incredibly well placed
blockade piece on C4 the Knight on C4
not only that is blockading your uh C
Pawn but also supporting my past Palms
I'm going to go B6 next move this a pawn
is going to be extremely powerful and
this seems to be giving white a
tremendous Advantage he did not do that
he played the move after Knight to B6
Queen to C1 Queen to C2 excuse me Knight
to D5 attacking the bishop Bishop to D2
and this is what we have right now very
complicated battle but it does seem like
uh the worst is behind uh black right
now c4 supported by The Rook on C8 C3 is
coming this Pawn on C4 despite the fact
that it could potentially become a
liability later on in the end game for
the moment is such a dangerous thorn in
White's position I really like what
elshon is doing I also like time
management that Christopher you is
engaged in 44 minutes against 27 minutes
nevertheless the position remains
difficult to play with both sides to be
honest pretty chaotic but I do like
elshon's uh the fluidity the bishop to
coming to C5 with the queen on E8 E6 E5
a potential opportunity therefore
um uh Alshon uh turning our attention to
a Wonder Liang versus uh Alexander
Lenderman we were talking about
majorities you know like I like the
majority in the center I love them the
essential majority put the pawn back on
B6 put the pawn back on A5 and we'll
probably have a discussion doubled a
pawns no way Jose I would be uh I'd be
rushing embracing this type of an ending
where I'm ready to go E5 E6 and the four
versus two with the doubled a pawns I I
mean to my mind that's simply winning so
I really like a wondrous position
exactly at this moment in fact I was so
uh confused like why why did Alex
Lenderman allow this well he got himself
into a a pickle right here after the
move Rook C1
he's looking at Rook C7 Queen takes uh B
Queen takes A5 and he decided that he
had to play the move E6 E5 and I'm I'm
for sure that that move did not come uh
easily no let us put it that way uh for
Lenderman and he is uh if Queen C6 isn't
the only move I mean you can double
Rooks on the seed file for example but
uh it does feel to me like
a wonder is in charge of this game quick
check on the game of Sam versus Hans
Neiman I absolutely absolutely love the
space that Sam has created for himself
as a Christian was saying you have to be
worried that you don't shut it so far
down that you don't have a break but
always in my mind's eye I see that it's
white F3 G4 is
white can always break open the position
on his option if there's one thing I
hate it's the night on D2
put transfer magically transfer the
Knight to the F4 Square so that we could
talk about uh Knight H5 check and Knight
F6 I'm soaring so I start with ideas of
let's say Knight F3 G3 Knight E1 Knight
G2 Knight F4 and I make my little try
because it's not easy for black to
create any Counterpoint
what about someone who's like F6 I don't
know maybe F6 exactly
to do something in this position maybe
that's the only way because actually
your plan was not moving the night
before it's very recovery yes it
suggests itself right doesn't it so
let's say the problem whenever you're uh
how do you say you're just defending yes
defending defending move like F7 F6 is
very desirable because you're saying to
yourself I'm doing something but
oftentimes you're doing something may
actually be helpful to your opponent in
other words you've traded off your
double pawns and you pat yourself on the
back just right until that moment you
see a knight landing on the D4 square
and you said well trading the D4 upon
for the F7 Pawn ended up being something
I may not want to do so you always have
to be very careful as the defender of
altering the pawn structure now having
said that
if you don't play a move like F7 and F6
you're not human because you're you want
to get rid of this I mean this is
horrible or something yes exactly you
want to do something I was thinking also
maybe black has sometimes the ideas like
to push D4 F4 a certain point and to
have give some space to his Knight on G5
or F5 after f6s I'm not sure at which
moment but maybe sometimes you can do it
in order to try to defend a little bit
more actively instead of just waiting
sitting and waiting until you bring all
your pieces to the positions you want
yes sir Grandmaster Michael Marin had
this great comment in his uh Opus One
side is doing the other side is watching
yes exactly and in this case Sam is
doing all the doing and uh well Hans is
doing a lot of the watching what do you
have for us uh about this game Christian
yes uh I was trying to understand the
ways to break in uh the position and
actually as you guys already pointed out
F6 is the right way to break but for
white because indeed I will play the
move H5 and this is a key move because
now you're controlling both of the
squares of the Knight that potentially
he could jump to and could attack the
pawn on E5 via G6 or C6 that's why he
played this move B5 follow it up with H5
and as you guys were mentioning King to
F4 is coming and at some point I'm going
to take on F6 I'm going to kick the king
away from F6 and I'm going to start
invading with my king to E5 so that's
problematic for black that's why he
played the move a knight to G6 but just
a simple defense of despawn on H4 with
the move G3 why not add this point are
you going to follow it up with F6 well
if you do I'm going to go H5 or I can
just simply go Knight to F3 once again
whenever you take I'm going to take back
with the d-pawn and there's this uh D4
Square opens up this is a really
beautiful position for white it's going
to be a very tedious defense for Hans
Neiman nevertheless material is limited
position is very closed so if you make
one slight inaccuracy as white you
probably will lose your advantage
nevertheless it's going to be a long
maneuvering game we're going to be here
for a while because you know that Sam
Shanklin is going to try to convert this
one he has a golden opportunity to take
down one of the co-leaders in the event
thank you for that Christian I would
like to before we go on a break just to
say that uh our producers have put
together a very nice special feature the
players returning to St Louis they were
asked how do you like St Louis and
returning to St Louis for the 2020 U.S
championships have a look we'll see on
the other side of the break
what's your favorite part about the U.S
championships being held here in St
Louis well it's my first CS championship
and my favorite part is that it's so
long I really love playing this old
match
what's your favorite part about the U.S
championships being held here in St
Louis well it's my first CS championship
and my favorite part is that it's so
long I really love playing this
old-fashioned long tournaments
and the fact that is in San Luis it's
extremely convenient for me because I
live here well I've only played one US
Championship that wasn't here I played
in 2008 that was my first one in 2009 I
moved to St Louis and it's obviously by
comparison I could tell it was much
nicer and it's very professionally run
the price one's very good and uh you
know hey one of my us Championship here
once uh felt amazing I love it it's
cultural it's a lot of strong players
playing and his chest and it's all
together it's a fantastic experience I'm
just glad that for the first time part
of it
um well first of all I mean St Louis is
one of the nicest places I've been to in
the US and
it's kind of like been a routine for me
the last 10 years I've been coming every
year playing it's pretty much a second
home to me now yeah in a way it's um
there's very little pressure in an event
like that because you know I'm just
happy to to be here playing and uh you
know it's an enjoyable experience pretty
much no matter the result it's an
especially important tournament and this
year it's even longer than usual more
players so it feels like it'll be more
challenging but also more rewarding well
it's my first U.S Championship but uh
I really like St Louis I've spent a lot
of time here in the past few months and
my next results in St Louis
so it feels like not home but there's a
level of normalcy to playing Gear that I
don't get you know traveling around
Europe This is the closest thing I have
to home because I'm living in hotels so
the Chase Park Plaza is like my my
second home so it's nice to have
familiarity and of course just planned
or good conditions you know it's just
great to be in the atmosphere of St
Louis and you know the conditions here
are wonderful for the players and just
to be able to play all the top players
in the world is really unique for me and
it's something I'm really looking
forward to I generally just like the
atmosphere it feels since I've been here
so many times it feels like really
familiar I'm just ecstatic to be playing
at the U.S Championship like I didn't
really even expect to play this year but
I'm just really excited well I think in
general for me I've always enjoyed
um Forest Park a lot so anytime I come
to St Louis I make sure to to make as
many visits there as I can just explore
the nature and all it has to offer
especially now this time of year the
weather is great and yeah I look forward
to to venturing there again the
tournament just keeps getting stronger
every year which makes it harder for me
to try to win but
it's probably probably the best part is
actually that I was just kept getting
stronger all the time I mean back in
2015 there was like Hikaru and maybe
gotta monishook but back then like I had
a real chance of winning now I still
have a chance of winning but there's
there's lots of more competition so it's
forced me to try to improve myself as
well so I think that's that's really
great that tournament just keeps getting
better every year it's the capital of
Chess I would save them for the world so
it's amazing to play here every single
year well a couple of things first of
all I like the fact that uh
um I live here so when I'm when I'm
playing here I get the support from from
my people from my family which is kind
of unusual in the Chess World because
you're always traveling and I also like
the fact that uh the atmosphere that
it's created here it's usually great and
uh that's that's also I think helpful
for chess like for example you are in
the middle of a tournament which is
normally very serious and you know it's
super competitive obviously and all that
but then you get to hang out with great
people like you know the organizers like
Joey and Tony and and Yasser and Rex
himself and and just for a few hours you
forget about the the tournament and you
have a good time and it's very friendly
and very nice and and that's I think one
of my favorite Parts well it really
feels like my home uh or basically my
second home so we're only an hour flight
away from Minnesota and I've been coming
here in and out for the last seven eight
eight years Years also I went to college
here 10 years ago also St Louis has been
hosting world-class tournaments the
singfield cup Etc
so when you come here you know you will
be challenged
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the studio at round
three of us championships
and we have also the game it's over the
first game of the US Championship first
results we have first results Wesley saw
is here with us with Christian
and I mean the game finish Network we
have to mention oh yes very very
important uh draw that was a long time
in coming by the way yes that was that
Bishops of opposite color and we're just
getting Wesley all uh miked up yes that
was the Bishops of opposite you could
almost see it from a very long way away
we're like right here even though from
this point onwards it took 10 20 30
moves but it's almost an iron-clad
certainty that this position is going to
end and draw the Bishops of opposite
color let's go to Christian and uh
Whoop I'm sorry
we're still not ready and I was just
going to just finish the point that this
extra Pawn I'm grateful to have it don't
get me wrong but uh The Rook is going to
cover to B2 the bishop is going to go to
H4 white is going to be tied down and
it's going to be
difficult slash impossible to realize
the advantage of the extra pawn and so
it's kind of symbolic
being told now we're ready let's go to
Christian you're getting ahead of
yourself I'm so sorry I'd like two three
moves ahead but we are in the way it
feels with uh Wesley Wesley uh you
played with the black pieces and smooth
draw for you I would say out of the uh
the opening you equal rights comfortably
how do you feel about the game
um yeah I mean I didn't really get any
chances just want to play I think
um just just play some good solid moves
and if chances come good if not don't
but I think there were only one moment I
think the funny part is that I played A6
and moved here just by accident
yeah right we know Knight F6 is probably
the main move right and then Jeffrey
told me after again after Knight F6 is
not like winning four checked Queen A4
check okay so now it like
uh linear has some games with Knight C6
but Magnus won a game here recently
against that one and if C6 Queen takes
C40 transpose to the slab which Jeffrey
played in the first game
they did not want to see this on the
board no I just played A6 by accident I
had no idea if you can play Queen A4 so
the funny part is now I think if white
plays uh E4 and B5 is okay for black
so maybe I fixed it slightly more
accurate move order
um of course the Africa played Knight
after and move to but then somehow it's
very difficult for me to believe you
that you played A6 by accident I'll give
it to you this time
I'll give it to you this time he played
E3 on Knight to F6 why not B5 now
I'll be fine it's also a line biting
wife slightly better after A4 Bishop B7
B3 B3 okay E6 take Stakes bcbc Bishop C4
and come up the it seems very dovish but
Bishop on B7 is slightly uh vulnerable
after Knight bd2 B2 rupee one attack
Bishop B7 but I made some dirt with
white and black before many years ago
like this but somehow other engines
sound like well and then the other
critical part I guess they're not so
many critical Parts like he played
bitter before against me the speed test
Championship so takes on move 13.
so you guys already played this position
before yeah in fact A4 he played Knight
to F3 okay I think he's played this a
few times yeah how did you respond in uh
in in that game played the bishop Bishop
D6 oh no actually it was a bit game and
I blundered with Rook d8 like I played
Rook d8 here 935 queen queen D6 uh Queen
to D6 oh so the game is not here huh it
doesn't seem like it oh I think he plays
Bishop F3 Knight D5 and then he played
Knight takes up seven
such a fun and game huh and things are
getting a bit wild it still seems like
you're more or less fine but it's pretty
difficult for sure but we played
differential.com yeah yeah so A4 I guess
and Jeffrey weapon well prepared but
okay play very solid at least he was
also spending a lot of time at this
point yeah it was a one-up I mean he's
trying to get some chances but I think
is if I managed to trade drugs then it's
fine like here I missed Rook B2 Rook C1
okay still at the king I said Rook V8
checking E7 and then Bishop C2 but still
hard to imagine how white can win this
yeah everything exactly space four try
to keep contact with the opponent F2 and
then the bishop cannot move the pawn
cannot jump forward so still very the
thing if I lost this position with black
recently online but the F Pawn is on G3
not on F3 got it got it so I love that
very similar end games I learned some
some important lessons yeah but with the
double F punch it's much easier to make
it through because you have the Avenue
for uh this [ __ ] page four to attack
the pawn on F2 or what is the reason
behind it oh yeah I mean white can't
Advance with King side one so got it
also he's always got the yeah you're
right weakness and F2 but white can't
make progress on making five the double
punch Wesley yesterday a very difficult
game against a very promising uh player
Christopher you how did you handle uh
that defeat
uh well it's my 80th Championship I'm
used to kind of expected the result
because I always lose to teenagers
championships in 2015 I think I lost to
two teenagers to Serbian and I know if
Conrad Holt was a teenager
2000 uh
eight eighteen or two I was also losing
at some point in 2019 lost the Wonder so
it happens I mean I always lose rate in
the U.S Championship so it's kind of
expected also this year has 13 games so
the more the merrier but what is it
about teenagers that you necessarily
don't like playing against them it's
their style what do you feel gives you
problems yeah there's more pressure you
know they have nothing to lose they just
go all out for a win like I was very
fortunate a bit thin the Rob in the
Olympiad but uh you know they're very
Carefree their focus is just 100 on
chess they have no like girlfriends or
family
or college you know they probably
homeschooled uh and then they have like
two to three years to figure out if they
want to pursue a chess career or go
outside the university like a Wonder
eventually did but it was he's still
very strong but how are those days for
you how do you remember them worry free
were you worried about which career to
choose you got your rent paid they got
everything yeah for you and don't have
to worry about your clothes you have
your parents keeping an eye on you you
have the Stanford Fellowship so there's
where uh
both are good old days you know if
you're a teenager figuring out what to
do with your life uh for for me I guess
that decision has long been decided I've
been a professional chess player for
eight years now uh I remember back in
those days when I was 18 19 I I was
number 80 in the world and I wasn't sure
if I could make a career playing chess
uh so I went to Webster University for
two and a half years I was I didn't even
know what to study I finally ended up
citing studying Finance but then I
figured out that uh
uh whether I graduate or not I'm gonna
try my luck playing chess professionally
and then the Samford scholarship helped
a lot uh obviously but but when as you
get older there's certain pressure
uh playing against uh teenagers like
also like three of you right now it's
very strong also last time a few weeks
ago and uh and I guess Christopher you
was played very aggressively yesterday
like uh well speaking about I was
winning at some point yeah he actually
came to the studio and uh he said that
he felt disrespected on every level by
hans's previous interview not mentioning
maybe his name or saying that the game
spoke for itself because it was so
beautiful yeah how do you see that whole
interaction between this uh two young
men well I guess that can be expected of
hands I mean he's disrespected like
pretty much everybody in the Chess World
yeah at this stage calling other players
idiots and stuff and also beating the
great Magnus but uh and how about
Christopher's response
um what did he say exactly he said that
he felt disrespected by hans's interview
and we didn't know how to approach that
or how exactly he felt disrespected or
why he felt disrespected
well it felt disrespected because Hans
uh just won a game I mean wasn't a
perfect game it was a good game but and
then he called it brilliant and you know
anybody can lose a game uh
I think pretty much
everyone knows that Hans is probably the
most disrespectful teenager in chess
there are many other good players like
gokesh Arjun Prague and they're they're
very polite even Fearless gets like a
little angel but okay I mean it doesn't
doesn't really matter that can be
expected
but the thing is like I noticed
Christopher you was also throwing out
new openings here like he never played
second midnight filter before
and uh you know he's just playing for a
win every game just trying to improve
and
I guess if you lose the game and if you
get trashed out then that's the most
difficult feeling that you can feel as a
chess player but I mean it's a it's a
it's not a big deal there always be
other games and uh
yeah I know it's also Christopher you
won the U.S junior very considering yes
yes so he's definitely seems to be
surging through the rankings right now
he's definitely adding a lot another
layer to his game yeah certainly to end
the yeah it kind of reminds me of
a young a Wonderland or Leroy Fang so
we'll see how how it goes I'm just very
grateful that Mishra is not here please
more teenagers more uh pressure yeah
yeah unfortunately not played every
teenager in the tournament
still 10 rounds to go uh
right then this tournament 10 for you
still were in the yes 11 rounds yeah I
think also one of the problems for me
Levon Fabi I think uh the different time
controls every tournament uh also the
online tournaments I think it's very
difficult to
to change your mindset from playing
Blitz rapid to to classical and back
um if you notice pretty much all the top
players in the world that lost a bunch
of rating for no reason like I have no
idea why maximorsak for example was
elaborating but I think it's because
they don't really know what to focus on
we focus on online or focus on Rapid or
blitz so before this tournament I really
didn't have
much time to prepare because practicing
a lot on on chess.com and we have the
Fisher random tournament coming up
um
well I'm not making excuses but it is
what it is but I'm just saying that
compared to six years ago in 2016 where
everyone was pretty much playing Just
classical chess month after month uh
things have certainly changed absolutely
more opportunities but also a lot of
changes in the Chess World thank you
very much Wesley and we'll see you in
the rest of your games thank you thank
you indeed Wesley good luck to the rest
I'm sorry but I was really laughing
about it you don't have girlfriends you
don't have anything uh one result in the
books uh Anastasia yes only one actually
six games are still on the way and what
an interview it was everything I really
enjoyed it yes I could imagine that's
going to go viral uh on its own uh on it
it speaks for itself
I think Western should start making
draws with teenagers and try to do all
the others I'm fascinated by the current
position of Arena crash and Megan Lee at
first I thought it's game over just like
arena is going to win this very easily
these double pawns means that the queen
Side Pawn majority is not
um meaningful whereas Black's King on
the other hand is going to scoot up the
board go to H6 play F5 and this mass of
Pawns on the king side is Just Gonna
Roll and easily win the game
and then I thought to myself well well
Megan's problem is her King it's just
it's cut off along the D file and uh if
the king were on E3 she could put up
some serious resistance and maybe The
Rook could come to B1 Etc et cetera I
can't move the king and the law Rook D2
I'm just lost so then yeah so then I
started thinking well how clear is this
Rook ending uh King and pawn end game
pardon me my intention is to sacrifice
two pawns two Pawns in a king upon a
game Mike that's ridiculous how could
you lose two Pawns in the king and
pawning game well imagine the following
we get here and you play F5 and I'm not
going to capture the pawn on F5 yes and
undouble your pawns I'm going to leave
that alone I'm saying I'm not worried
about F4 and I'm just going to ignore
everything probably you shouldn't
capture no probably you should go back
and I was wondering okay I'm two pawns
down but
can you find the window yeah am I losing
this and actually white has this active
plan with C6 right I mean I was going to
play King to C4 King uh nc6 that's just
as you you mentioned Anastasia and I
didn't count it out but
it's so unusual to be two pawns down in
the king of Pawn in game and not like
dead loss usually you're just lost with
being a pawn down absolutely don't even
consider moving to a pound ending
correct
exactly it's so it's a it's a very
unusual
configuration and Christian Jump Right
In on that uh did you play this uh no I
I think she did play rookies
and maybe going into a can Pawn in game
two pawns down that would be really
remarkable
um absolutely I don't know who's better
in this one how do you see it Christian
how does that so Rook to D1 seems to be
a pretty decent move I don't think Rook
takes D1 actually uh works as in it
doesn't give you a winning advantage
that was my question because after King
to G7 it does seem like I'm actually the
first one came to E2 if you go King H6
G3 you take on H5 right now I go King to
D3 okay and on this side you cannot
break right yes there is no way to break
I mean you can go F5 but it's going to
take a very long time F5 take E3 and
then King G6 key and five King E4 right
in the meantime I'm going to go to your
B Pawn so right now you actually have to
pull the brakes and try to go King G6
King here F5 King C5 it's a yes E3 and
maybe you're I didn't count it out
either right in time it seems like you
are after King to uh F3 not King takes
E3 King takes E3 actually loses but King
to F3 and then pick up the G Pawn C5
since we're here we're going to go
through the whole variation King to F2
G3 C8 Queen and after or G2 you cannot
actually stop my Pawn right you can give
a check on a fade but after King to E2
you're not going to be able to stop my
Pawn you probably have to start picking
up some pawns take I get a queen you
take and most likely this is going to be
a drought maybe even black has some
chances due to the fact that the G Pawn
is more advanced right it's not not
about the quantity of the pawns but the
quality of the Pawns in this type of
Queen and games nevertheless it does
seem like the position might actually be
just a draw Rook takes D1 doesn't seem
to be the best move you want to keep the
Rooks on the board not an easy decision
to go a rook to C8 right nevertheless
the more you look at it it's all about
the connection of The Rook with the pawn
on e4 this is where you're going to be
able to increase your pressure later on
so just imagine a rook coming to C4 then
uh White is going to try to defend with
a rook passive on E1 and at the right
moment I'm going to go F5 and increase
the pressure that's going to require
some trades and maybe I'm going to be
able to build up a majority on the king
side as black so Rook to C8 is a key
move
at the same time Megan Lee I have to say
she's fighting and she's fighting really
well because her position was much worse
uh previously but she found the Right
Moves oh Rook tasty one
okay
okay let's see if Arena has calculated
this King and pawning maybe she saw
something that we didn't see this is not
going to be easy guys right yeah
good move yes not to give you a chance
to your opponents
and G4 probably then after you take it
if you take G4 yes because otherwise
white will play G4 so yeah G4 here yes
so that's why you don't take you need to
be able uh to attack that pawn on G4
with the move F3 because after uh G4 I
go F5 and I will create a pass Pawn at
any time right now I have to play F3 if
I
understood
because after a series G4 what what
after F3 I will uh slowly uh grab your
Pawn on H5 and then at the right moment
I will play G4
ke2 it's it's pretty crazy okay so
King G7 it's not easy guys King G7 yes
King F3 and forces
you to take on F2 this is not easy to
see if she sees that kudos to her I mean
by the way he takes G3
yeah
wow
three G4 uh it actually has to be played
and then F5 but still even this it's not
clear right no you go here here and now
you have to calculate who has more
tempies right right uh C4 look you have
this three pawns only five and it's not
working yeah
forget about it let's wait and see
whether she finds this kingy 2 King F3
variation at this point my guess is that
she's going to go into a deep tank and
try to understand and calculate the
variations that's the thing that's one
of the big factors of assessment that
differentiates uh Pawn end games from
any other uh piece and games they're
very much calculation based you have to
go why move that he well she moves that
I move that she moves that and so on for
like 20 moves and if you miss a little
detail then you lose the position
um this one is just an incredible
opponent you might have to say this is
fantastic what we just witnessed uh with
Christian there so in a book authorship
oftentimes we wrote ourselves into a
corner here here here here here and we
didn't understand the position so how
did we end our analysis
unclear's unclear now as a commentator
what does Christian say let's see what
the players
that's it that's our go-to line from now
on let's see what the players will
discover that's what back when the
engines were not around right and you
were seeing this crazy position and you
were yeah it's complicated
this is an amazing ending I definitely
am eager to keep our eye and see how
that
unravels uh that again is the ending
between Megan Lee our one of our
tournament co-leaders uh and Arena Crush
I wanted to jump into the Italia versus
uh Alice League game unfortunately
Bishops of opposite color seems to be a
theme in this round three as we're
seeing uh Wesley made it yeah exactly
and so I'm seeing a draw here Sabina has
made a great progress with this whole
minority attack she has managed to
really press her her opponent Anna India
having this weak Pawn on C6 in the
meantime this move F7 F5 might look to
All Eyes like it's some great aggression
but there is a long long way to get go
before you even make any threats Sabina
for choice in this matchup of clash of
former Champions if you will and let's
see about begum Rochelle when we left it
oh we had to avert our eyes because we
thought that we thought that Rochelle
was in deep trouble oh look at this
shades of Bobby Fischer b2b4 this was a
very nice
I think it was the brilliancy of game 11
from the 1992 rematch the rematch
between aspasky and uh Fisher where
Bobby played this flank sacrifice B4 bit
in that case he had A3 and Bishop takes
A3 B4 by vegan borrowing a page G4 yeah
baby look at this go for it we want to
play I know with the king in the center
puzzle Rush puzzle Rush H6 but let's
check what would happen I mean just for
people like why you cannot take this
phone it's very I like very much those
moves when you put the pawn on the
Square which normally you cannot even
think of right this T4 two times
protected like how can you come out with
this idea but really it happens
sometimes and it's very beautiful so
black cannot take CD flower because
Bishop A3 or obviously that's clear yes
before then E5 E5 yes so both times it's
really unpleasant for black
well that King is sitting on his open uh
Highway here in the center of the board
uh ideas of let's just let's just play
badly uh just for a few moves just so we
can just show exactly how terrifying
only bad this is appearing to be at
Knight to F7 hits The Rook Bishop G5
check which is why Rochelle actually
tossed an H6 only took it now that the
oh but the night
danced right back into the game this
move oh that's because maybe a
possibility to take only five instead of
moving Hornet I'm not sure but there was
a moment after each six could she take a
d takes C5 just for a second sure please
but I think Queen takes yes right and
unfortunately there is this a one I just
thought maybe there is some tactics here
but it feels like yeah it feels like
they're easily good something like
Bishop F4 yes first of all that protects
the Rook so you don't have time to take
the Rook yes
Bishop E3 so I don't know I would have
pursued this line of analysis because my
favorite is developing with gain of
tempo Bishop therefore that would have
been uh so yes takes on E5 but maybe
then she takes on G5 uh D takes E5 uh
hd5
in these cases
so we do have an issue yes and also Rook
on A1 is hanging and that's the issue
yeah
I'm still checking lucky five
yeah
no no it's okay the king and the center
of the board I believe one of the things
that always happens in these tournaments
is whenever there's a good King hunt
going on it's like everybody in the
tournament Hall gets up comes over us
that we call it the vultures they all
come over to take a look uh Knight H4
Bishop E8 Bishop F4 oh before you go uh
yeah crazy the line actually after
Knight to H4 Rochelle uh she actually
clawed her way all the way back into
this game and she had a golden
opportunity instead of Bishop to E8
Knight to G4 yes it was a key move but
it's so difficult to see all other
variations after that all so it's not
easy to allow yes with a check fork and
Bishop to F4 right right you have to
defend against the Checkmate on H2 Rook
takes F4 now you probably have to take
back with the Knight
you can also take with the Rook but D3
it's pretty obvious that the Oracle A1
is unprotected so you don't want to see
that on the board and the Knight is
actually better replaced on F4 because
it's also looking at the E6 Square in a
lot of variations this is what she uh
should have calculated in order to be
able to assess this position as okay for
black D3 which is extremely difficult
Queen takes D3 and now you're like yeah
sure Bishop takes A1 96 and I resign but
you give a check first to D4 King to H1
and now Knight E5
and now we see the geometry in the
position there is no way for the queen
to stay on the D file and maintain that
pin uh against the bishopone D7 so
Bishop takes A1 is not not possible and
at the same time defend the bishop on C4
wow really beautiful variation very very
difficult variations it's really
difficult to find yes she did not also
keep an eye on her clock right she's
down to her last seven minutes with 20
moves to go so she needs to speed things
up right now Rochelle but after Bishop
E8 Bishop F4 Queen to D7 it does seem uh
that white is back in the driver's seat
yes look at this Bishops and all the
pieces are really really happy there and
you don't have G5 that's the problem you
no longer have that counter play that
you were getting after Knight to G4
because Knight F5 is always coming so
what white should probably do at this
point is just improve her position what
is the only piece that's not playing in
the game The Rook on A1 precisely get it
to B1 tie the queen to the defense of
the B7 pawn and take it from there
there's no way for a black to uh improve
her position and she's kind of in
trouble at this point absolutely
nice uh by the way that movie G4 uh you
know sometimes you you just know you're
busted and you don't want you know to be
on the receiving end of a brilliancy and
you can see that with your king in the
center you know if if you lose the game
everybody's going to commiserate and say
yeah yeah we understand you lost the
game but a move like Knight G4 is very
unnerving because uh it says to your
opponent hey I I'm still in the game I'm
still fighting you know like I've got my
own counter attack so move like Knight
G4 I'd find very very attractive for
completely different reasons of
psychology just putting my opponent you
know like it's not all all fun and games
for you either buddy you know like we
also have to watch out remember this
game from the first round when Ellis Lee
managed to win this game at the
beginning she was defending and then
Saturday yes
this right moment exactly so okay uh but
at the moment it sure looks like uh
begum is for Choice Tata versus uh uh
Jennifer again a marquee match-up we're
kind of losing uh the the players here
uh as we left it around here Bishop E6
Tata played Queen H5 reinforcing the
into the fact that she's looking to drop
her Knight into F5 maybe on a good day
even play Bishop takes H6 Jennifer said
get lost I don't like you get out get
out uh Queen dropped back to F uh three
and by the way gift Meet The Pawn on H6
and okay there's some twoing and
throwing here because the bishop went
back to D5 94 Knight H7 Queen why do I
feel like
the players are either let's move
somewhere making a reversal it's it's
not a progress
it's like almost a Wily coyote or you're
going backwards with the legs the only
problem Knight F6 was not possible
anymore you cannot go Knight F6 back
because now I will eat your night yes
it's true that true that so Knight E7
big fight going on over the F5 squares
but there I asked the question is the E5
is that a peshki
just a second help me Anastasia just
tell me what I'm missing and I'll what
if I go uh Knight G6 96 again use this
pin only one I take on H1 I own H4 and I
go F5 F5 yes so there is a definitely a
pin on the E file but now I'm going to
get two pawns right you are yes
wow what the move what about my previous
heroic
I think Yasser just didn't see this
whole idea
[Laughter]
I caught you you got lucky
yeah
my reputation is going straight down I
mean I can feel it it's not working
anymore
um
do you know it the um at the closing
ceremony of the U.S Juniors and U.S
girls Rochelle and Jennifer came up to
me and said you guys are terrible you
guys are terrible broadcasters uh
Jennifer and I we would be so much
better than you guys and I was like come
on the show come on come on come on take
take our places and I told them that
this year's uh opening ceremony that as
soon as their games are finished the
producers have asked that they come on
and replace us we take a nice break and
they can and they were like uh
of course of course but I said it in a
very professional way yes sir you
achieved them
very hold on uh did we refute Queen
takes E5 is it refutable uh is it upon
him uh in the in the Tata Jennifer I
guess so at the end of the day can we
take the poem or we cannot yes or no yes
that's it yes yes or no Christian tell
us yes you can take it yes sir thank you
thank you you can take it yes you can
take it but what it leads to uh
a draw after another F5 immediately
immediately a five now if you move the
Knight away then I just move my knight
away and you Rook only one that's clear
to be unprotected so what you have to do
is actually take on H6 now right right
of course you could see it I take and
now it's some sort of a Perpetual okay
h8 Queen E5 King G8 Queen G3 and this is
the Perpetual clock wow so Queen takes
E5 leads indeed to a drop by the way
guys yes please she found kinky too
Megan Lee wow
wow will she find that right now Irina
is really deep in uh thought will she
find after King H7 but this is the first
step right is the a great first step
will she find King F3 after King each uh
H7 or G7 this is the key question right
now that we will let the ladies think
and Ponder but I think we should move to
the opening section because there are
some interesting let's do it let's there
let's do it when we left at Sam uh
Shanklin was enjoying a huge space
advantage over uh Hans Neiman but but
enjoying a space advantages was one
thing but when we left it the problem
for Hans is his minor pieces had no
great squares we're about to see that
this Knight on f8 in fact discovered a
great Outpost for herself and it's not
obvious yes I didn't see it he found the
C5 Outpost let's see how he got there so
A4 a useful move so we see Sam again
gaining some space and now thanks to
Knight D7 attacking the pawn we don't
have time to pick up the F5 upon we have
to play King D4 takes takes Knight C5
Bishop C2
Knight B1 and
we're almost all caught up if you had
told me this comes from a French defense
I said absolutely obviously it it what
else could it have come from now this
move
A5
convinces me that we're playing for A6
Knight C3 Knight A2 night before and if
you ever lose the a pawn well you just
resigned or B6 if we can catch B6 but
now it's impossible yes right so I think
uh Sam is ready to reroute his night and
that was what and that was why I mean at
first blush you're thinking I was
thinking that
um Hans was playing for Bishop H7 let's
trade light squared Bishops and that's
but this last uh move Bishop
F7 says well I want to control the C6
square but this doesn't look good for
Hans uh no let's say I go but once again
it's still the same question did you
close the position too much right maybe
there are some ideas with 95 sometimes
especially if you exchange Bishops right
maybe 95 and then King goes
all the way
I'm beginning to realize that when the
bishop sits sitting there eyeballing the
the pawn on B4 let's say I play A6 and
let's say white black is just waiting
it's not so easy to Route the Knight to
C6 because I have to keep B5 defended
which means we're going to do something
like this and once I do this I've got to
check to throw you back you don't want
to go King to E3 I've got a D4 check so
you have to put your king in front of
the pawn yes and I wait some more so
it's not easy and what's the evaluation
Christian of this intriguing ending it
does seem to be very close to equality
well obviously it is white who is
pressing but at least the engines don't
see a clear way in which uh White can
create any problems for a black right
now it does seem like with the spawn
potentially going to A6 which I think
was just the last move played I'm going
to keep the bishpony eight keep contact
with the pawn on B5 that's going to more
or less force you to defend it with your
knight right
three I think Knight C3 is going to come
pretty much automatically and right now
I'm just going to wait wait sit and wait
yeah so how are you going to make any
progress whenever you try to get the
king to F4 and push a G5 I'll let you
push G5 that's fine but you also have to
deal with the H5 weakness so I don't see
a good way to make any progress right
now if you go King E3 and you try to
reroute the Knight to D4 there's not
that much time because the pawn on B5 is
unprotected it's hanging right now so 92
94 doesn't work I guess what you have to
do but you don't actually have a square
to do it from because if you put the
bishop on D3 I'm going to take that
if you put a [ __ ] Pony too then you
don't have the E2 squares to reroute the
Knight so I don't see a clear way for
you uh to improve your position as white
and we come down to the same question
since the beginning of the end game did
you close the position too much and I
think the answer to that question right
now it's a clear yes
wow
and 30 minutes for Sam shacklin who
played very quickly came out of the
opening with this terrific novelty of
Queen C1 to two and a half minutes it
looks like and how many moves how many
moves I think
two Moves In fact yeah not a lot to go
uh one player that has uh more moves to
go in less time is actually Darius
vierge against Fabiano okay Darius down
to his last minute maybe we can move to
that one absolutely oh uh what a usually
in Balance position Bishop versus knight
but this is a massive massive Pawn
Center for darus on a good day if he
ever could play Rook E8 uh
44 is like yes but uh it's not just
about uh nice Central pawns it's also
about a potential week pawn on F5 this
move Knight H uh four is a key
indication that Fabi is thinking hey if
I can if I can play Queen G5 check F4
I'm actually really nicely poised to
take advantage of uh things going on on
the king side that this is double edged
and what did you say about the clock 35
seconds and counting for Darius
so he needs to make a move and he needs
to do it fast this is quite typical by
the way for Darius Darius is what we
call a Time trouble junkie and he really
enjoys being in uh time travel he always
is in time trouble but surprisingly he
also makes really good moves when he's
in time travel and he did one just now
look at Faith is the best move yeah so
protecting the five bone exactly okay
well let's pursue what looks like a
rather forcing series Queen Check Yes
can get trade okay King h8 good yes that
was my my question can i s a F4 or not
F4 E4 maybe F4 E4 and
it's scary it's scary I I'll grant you
that
[Music]
um
I was thinking of okay E3 wow who's uh
who's doing what yeah yeah okay
exactly what five rookie five
makes perfect sense of course
and I have to drop back yeah
uh maybe this is just a bridge too far
Queen E4 Queen D5 sorry Queen D5
where do you go yeah it's not but then
Queen G7 is yeah
um
you want to give checkmate with the King
yes
a good a good General always leads his
army in to battle
um
crazy position right did they teach you
that of your summer or School classes uh
uh it's it's it's a nasty uh position
for time before was played what cc4
really
defending as Queen D5 idea I guess so
yes C4
that's that's a movie yeah
it's a good idea though I kind of like
having that now whenever I get to play
E4 I feel like I'm going to have a
passer on You jc3 Queen takes C3 is on
the board oh it's on the board already
on the board okay Queen to D5 check is
also on the board of course this is what
happens when you have time trouble moves
are coming quickly right yes
thanking I'm assuming King to G1 ideas
of Queen C4
um
I want to say I like Black's position
but I'm just I'm not sure
it's anything what does the evaluations
black is doing great black is just doing
great black is doing great actually the
evaluation is giving black a one point
Advantage no kidding I was thinking it
was just better black but not a big not
that big well
0.5 if you played the very unnatural
King to H3
is the best movie
you have to be here
no no way no King age three he'll play
either F3 or King G1 yeah I think King
G1 would probably be maybe F3 because
you don't want to see E4 why don't you
believe on father I don't understand
what's going on King H3 is just a very
difficult move to make
but he's the best player so I'll give
you a couple of reasons
um one of them is I think he realizes
that he's slightly worse yes he also
looks at the clock he sees that Darius
has less than one minute on his clock so
there are still eight moves to go into
the time control he needs to take full
advantage of his time Advantage uh and
uh the situation that Darius is in so he
needs to move fast he cannot allow his
opponent yes to uh understand the
position and understand his next
responses he needs to make a move and a
decision fast that's why King H3
requires some time like you're going to
spend five seven minutes and understand
that the king is actually safe on H3 and
then you're going to play it but in the
meantime also your opponent thought
about the position
um I think this is one of those
situations it's not as complicated I
disagree a little bit because actually I
mean I can give my arguments yes because
I believe that you have to find some
moves which will surprise your opponent
so move a king H3 definitely will be a
bit shocking you know like you don't
really look at the is the right
direction at all so maybe at this moment
his opponent will be shocked and will do
something with which he he doesn't want
to do yeah no question about it those uh
very uh um I want to say unpleasant
moves though but not unpleasant um what
is the word I'm looking for a surprise
surprise surprise definitely the
surprising moves can really be
off-putting you're you're down on the
clock and your opponent makes a move
that's a bad surprise a nasty surprise
and it's sort of like you want to punish
them for taking such an outlandish risk
like King H3 so you start to immediately
think to yourself F4 I should go F5 and
I should go F4 so that the king will
have no Escape I'll go Queen H5 and then
suddenly a move like Rook G4 check and
it's sort of like oh my gosh you know
like I now I'm worse or something so
yeah these uh
surprising moves can be very powerful
when your opponent's in time travel
whether we see Fabi over push also yes
of course but definitely don't want to
end up in worse position also with time
control exactly back over to you to
counter at that point for just a second
yeah we usually do that when the
position is very complicated though
right right so how much of a difference
is between King to H3 and King to G1
not so much it's not like you're
creating any huge threats with a multi
to H3 it's just a better placement for
the king so black can still play B6 B5
C6 they can play a neutral move right
yeah no matter where you put the king so
that's why I don't think it makes such a
huge difference and that's why I think
Fabiano will realize that and will make
a move fast because speed right now uh
depending on the positions
okay as Alejandra would say I know my
boy yes
that's true king G1 and I like this move
that you said suggested
um Christian just simply C7 C6 why well
I just protect my queen and in case of
Queen C4 go ahead and trade it and put
my Pawn on D5 and in the meantime I'm
asking why well uh
um you better do something I've got some
space and maybe one day I'll re-route
this bishop to this diagonal and it will
be rather threatening so we'll keep an
eye on that one let's just jump to Sam
Savion one of our tournament co-leaders
and see how he's doing against well dare
I say it when I uh pick to win the event
uh Lavon aronian and we have
Sam sabiana's nursing an extra Pawn if I
guess exactly yes yeah even though he
spawns are a bit broken after move F4 I
think 11 actually a game they spawn
sacrifices
well he can certainly win it back yes
and probably he should take it back and
should he take a bit whoa whoa whoa what
am I saying just a second there is a a
fork a massive Fork on D6 in the
position right ah and you cannot you
don't have Bishop seven to protect so
your Bishop is hanging and uh and Knight
decis so it's not easy to take this Pawn
back yes in that case if white could
ever play no same story in this case I
actually have F5 right yes also oops uh
but uh if Sam is lucky enough to get in
the move King G3 he could really enjoy
his extra Pawn uh Lavon a little in
trouble here uh Sammy's doing great yeah
yeah sami's doing great now the problem
with Sam's position is that he has two
minutes on the clock
I know that's the only problem issue but
he also has only one
so Row 2 A4 was move 39.
Lev will be thinking about his decision
right now but after that it's just one
more move you're going to make time
control and you're going to try to well
we're in this position because you are a
pawn of indeed absolutely uh going to
another big heavyweight matchup of
Olympians this was the Berlin and I must
say even though it's another one of
those Bishops of opposite color uh
Physicians you could also say it's
pretty much play on one goal uh White
has a majority uh blacks majority of
oops I was about to say blacks majority
is stuck and exactly at this moment
maybe C5 can be played
yes to give some space to the king you
mean oh just to uh just to employ like
if I could get the bishop to move back
well then hey maybe on a good day I get
to play C4 and I'll put my majority to
work uh I was about to say just here uh
it felt like well black is just a pawn
down these double pawns don't count
whereas maybe uh I can use my majority
so I thought it was a Advantage linear
until we got to the moment
that we're currently in I'm not saying
that C5 is great or anything like that
but suddenly Ray has an opportunity
maybe to use his Pawn
yeah and let's just jump to uh
Christopher you who yesterday again uh
made waves uh with that uh remarkable
victory over our defending Champion as
well as his interview exactly
more discussions his game or his
interview after
that game right I mean also Wesley we
discussed it with Wesley today yeah I
mean there was a big reaction and I
would say that in our Twitter account
like more than 50k views of this moment
when the Christian was making this
interview it was actually kind of funny
because over the years uh Christopher
like a lot of people you know like they
come on the camera they kind of get
nervous so Christopher was like the one
word answer you know like how was today
good no did you like it yeah right yeah
and then yesterday came out of animated
you're like I got disrespected this will
not stand
it's a new fashion you know you start
you are talking right so that's
important I think and actually I don't
know if we have the streets I mean there
were many many discussions in Twitter
about this interview and the way he said
he said what did he mean by saying this
disrespect and things like that I don't
know if our team can show it yeah
the game was more more important at the
moment every vote this for sure by the
way I really like Christopher's position
I mean big time this he may be on uh
track for his second victory in a row I
mean just I mean just compare this Pawn
on B6 versus The Pawn on A6 now the
question is could I win by fours by
doing something like Rook B1 obviously
my winning threat is to play B7 and if
you did something like group B8 again
I'm I'm playing for night to A5 and
obviously if I can play B7 you know we
could shake hands uh
or should I keep the Queens on the board
anticipating that The Rook goes to B8
and the queen will go to D6 and again a
huge Advantage for uh Christopher I
gotta say I think this is winning I
understand we have a result in the
ladies oh yes I think so I think it's
Naji
um
yeah it's just a draw so sorry let me
turn back to Christopher's game yeah
Queen B4 on the board by the way that
was indeed played the threat is B7
elshon cannot play Queen E7 can't play
Rook B8 because of um Queen to D6 if
I've got that right for the second oh
I've got it back because it's Checkmate
yes
and uh if you know your back Rank
checkmates by the way I think it's good
for about six points in the puzzle run
yeah
yeah rank Checkmate uh
A5
oops Queen B4 A5 on the board
okay makes sense but so what did they do
if you think okay he took the pound yes
what's the idea ah Queen H6 Queen H6
that looks like that one is hanging a
desperate and you cannot move yes you
can just go H4 H4 just H4 exactly you
don't even have G5 no the queen is
actually monitoring that's and you
probably don't even want to play G5
either Knight to G4 might uh hurt your
feelings as uh White would take over the
attack but this is a Domination by uh
Christopher no question I think he's got
this one in the bag
uh Wesley was right saying that it's not
easy to play with teenagers in the
Italian the Millennials are coming wow
well they're here never mind they're
coming I uh whoa the night was on C5 I
don't know what's going on in this game
I was gonna say uh uh I I was very
impressed that Hans with his Knight on
f8 uh ages ago discovered a way of
actually giving his Knight
a great Square
and it looks like they're no they
haven't been repeating
um still Advantage white
looks like but as
well wait a minute hold on okay so as
white I guess I want to force the trade
of knights do I
so let's let's wake right let's Zoom
here
Bishop E8 Knight F3
I mean we forget that that this is still
a protected past Pawn which means any
King and pawn end game is not
necessarily very good for white but okay
if I'm playing for a win do I
do I trade I I'm a little bit confused I
want to play for G5 but
yeah I mean even if you do so I just
probably stand I'll take it no okay but
then be careful because I want to go H6
and
then
by the way another result uh Alice Lee
is not going for the Bible I'm not
surprised anymore she did draw Italia
that was the queen and Bishop of
opposite color we expected to draw in
that game two and a half points
nonetheless for Alice really good great
results so far wow impressive uh Sam
Shanklin versus uh Hans Neiman uh jump
in Christian well that one actually
seems to be going towards the repetition
a repetition yes they've been shuffling
the pieces back and forth but let's go
back to the latest section for just one
second because another uh player that
was perfect up to this point Jennifer
you I think she's going to go down uh to
a tative abrahamian because Queenie ate
Queen f8 thought I've managed to break
through
the position and now after Queen to G6 I
think this might actually be just it
why do you play after Queen to G6 well
first of all I'm just uh catching up to
the players yes as uh I guess Jennifer
uh what do I play after Queen G6
you have to go back to uh with the
Knight but then I just go D4
D4 uh opening up
and this one finished in a victory for
Christopher you dominant victory for
Christopher you two in a row for the
young man yes TMC is really this was
disrespected
don't do this never again not in my
house uh
oh that moved d3d well the problem is
The Rook on A7 like uh that's like yeah
that's like a pathetically placed rook
and in the meanwhile I believe that this
is like a kind of I'm walking into some
kind of a mating uh net here well I
don't know about that move maybe I can
just drop back with exhibition wait wait
a minute hold on am I am I being too
flippant here
maybe Queen takes H6 just simple
something simple yes well it doesn't get
approached if you can take the bone you
take the point but but you are
threatening made in two yeah exactly
exactly
I like it very much right
um
yeah uh
whoa d3d is it um no Queen G6 check is
on the board
D4 immediately played yeah wow and it
feels like it feels like my Peak is
going to win
I'm sorry did it tonight's on you
everybody's invited on this stuff
Anastasia is picking up the check yeah
is time travel a factor because those
last moves by both ladies they have both
it was an indication that that they're
under pressure of the clock but two and
a half two no not terrible but this is
just a losing position as uh it doesn't
look good for Rook A7 Queen takes and
the desirable rookie eight is simply
walking into a check this is a pattern
that we should all have hardwired into
our brain we put the bishop
yes H7 we we get to we get to reposition
the Bishop from C2 where it's currently
to G6 with a gain of tempo
this is such a beautiful little sequence
for the Checkmate there you should know
that
um yeah Jennifer uh
she overlooks something
before right we didn't we didn't fully
get a chance to witness what you missed
but it sure looks like tatv has this
game uh in her pocket D3 D4 one player
that had her game in her pocket and she
doesn't right now is
no at one point it was completely
winning beautiful game but I don't know
what happened now it's a completely
different situation
nice nice I I that that's whatever
where's the beef where's the queen you
you're close to uh to giving the
Checkmate but it's not there right
there's no Checkmate that Bishop on D7
coupled with the action of the queen on
D6 defense against all of these
unpleasant tracks right and I have my
own unpleasant checks right then the D4
is coming thank you uh Anastasia that's
what I always ask myself if I've
overdone things do I have uh a way of
saving uh the game at least okay so okay
seven rupees seven is one way I think
it's it's a draw you mean yes just
Perpetual check like there is no way to
escape that's a good point okay so she
has it yeah right like like usually uh
my disasters are you know Titanic you
know like there is no way normally the
ship is going down
uh rookies wow where did it go wrong was
it a Time trouble no where did the queen
go 10 minutes actually yeah yeah keep
going I think that was more than fine
everything everybody's happy birthday
everybody
a very bad move very badly timed move
because everything comes with Chuck you
you have to be looking at Bishop takesh
too right all the time yes it's the only
threat that's up in the position right
so why wouldn't you start with something
like Rook to C7 first and only why not
Queen B1 exactly yes sir beautiful yeah
with that deal bring the queen into play
right wow I mean that finishes the game
sometime in your eagerness to just get
your opponent to resign you play a
movement like Bishop A6 and Bishop H2
just tasered and now he's starting to
become a game for two results because
she played the move C3 if you don't pull
the brakes I mean queen F4 Queen G3 is
coming in the position
yeah she still has this like Rook A7
right
she still has Rook A7 yes yes who has
that Saving Grace but it won't be there
she just played Knight to G3 Knight to
G3 setting up some unpleasant checks on
E2
now it's time for Belgium to kind of
accept the fact that it's yeah she kind
of blew uh blew it uh so to speak Knight
G3 ideas of 92 Knight takes C3 uh at a
certain moment I start to get worried
that a moves like a bishop to B5
um
are going to be available or a bishop to
C6 and I won't have the Perpetual check
we'll keep that in mind and I just want
to go back for a second
and we have Knight F3 and it looks like
uh uh I I wanted to see if the two
players uh Sam Shanklin Hans Neiman
continued with that repetition and they
did a draw between those two and
Christian I do believe we have a special
guest in studio you are a very correct
Yasser we are with a very happy Victor
of today's round Christopher you
back-to-back victories for you
Christopher uh big victory it wasn't
easy tell us a bit about this game
I really didn't know what was going on
like most of the game I felt like I
would just
playing off like intuition but
in fact at some point like after Knight
C5 I really panicked
um Knight to C5 uh I think on move
all the way here 22 was yes Knight to C5
at this point looking at your P3 squares
it's not looking pretty yeah
but then I had this extremely lucky
trick where I sacked my work
when Knight E takes C4
and I think Knight to B3 was the move uh
recommended at this point did you see
this move and what was your uh response
the following response for you I think
my point was Queen B2 then Knight D6 and
if I take this Knight takes C4 and now I
take back 96 now I take it Bishop D6 oh
Knight to C2
B6 B6 and just play it like this yeah
and you have enough compensation and I
do believe that this was actually the
correct response as well you did have
enough compensation here
um but after Bishop to G2 it does seem
like you're starting to take over the
initiative where was the The Rook
exchange that you mentioned
Knight to B3 Rook sacrifice
um yeah this was kind of the work
sacrifice but I I found it amusing how
all these pieces were somehow like
hanging it's almost it's almost like
some it's almost like somebody decided
to just randomly put the pieces on all
the all the most hanging Square it's
like so unfortunate for him yes yes you
play Queen B2 Knight day one everything
is hanging the Knight on B4 is hanging
the bishop is attacking that Knight on
B3 Bishop on G2 and you're only a piece
down
that's not bad but like here if you if
you count the material I'm officially
like a like a rook and a piece down yes
but somehow my position somehow it's
still a good position just because how
unfortunately his pieces are placed and
you're actually going to be upon up at
the end of all this melee because still
one Rook under attack as well as his uh
two pieces Knight on A1 and Bishop on G2
very nicely calculated Christopher
Bishop takes a rook to C1 and it felt
after this that you just transitioned
very precisely into a winning position
two out of two in the last couple of
games after a rough start did that
feeling of disrespect fuel you into this
round as well
I think I I think I maybe could have
worded it better I felt like
the interview might have been a bit
disrespectful but I wouldn't say I
personally felt disrespected by it got
it got it now that clears the cobwebs
for us uh definitely Chris Christopher
congratulations still a huge victory for
you and plenty of games yes left in the
tournament guys
question from Anastasia yes I was just
wondering how much time Christopher
spent in social media yesterday after
that interview he got many many comments
even from top players like Anish giri
answered to his interview like did he is
he aware of those comments and uh what
what he thinks about it yeah I am a I am
aware of the comments I could tell that
there are a lot of people that were on
my side and not on my side and there was
a lot of like controversy behind it
but um
how did it feel to be in the center of
attention is that something that
distracts you at all or
yeah it was it was a little bit
distracting
maybe I maybe I could have been better
prepared if I was if I didn't keep
checking the whole the whole drama and
what other people were saying
and what did your parents uh tell you
because we know that your dad is always
with you always supporting you in every
tournament what did he tell you about my
dad was fine with it but my mom was like
concerned he was like why why is
everybody saying all these bad things
about me and but I I I sort of felt like
I sort of expected it after I realized
what I said well there's good things and
bad things you have to take it
everything with a grain of salt yeah
thank you Christopher congratulations
big victory for you a nice result and
still plenty of games to go thank you
absolutely congratulations Christopher
and the results are coming in hot and
heavy uh suddenly as uh hey well here we
see it in the open uh Anastasia yeah so
we have one decisive game Christopher
just won the game against silchan and
then two two draws Jeffrey shrunk with
Wesley so and Sam shankland Wisconsin
even four games are still on the way and
a lot of results in the ladies also just
took place and
we're just including
including that we do have three draws
and I saw that tatv a did win yes and I
think Jennifer missed a chance just at
the end uh time travel makes a fool of
his all uh her move Bishop F7 allowed
Queen h8 checked probably she had
some kind of Moment Like This where she
can start to look for some kind of
Perpetual check ideas to to stay in the
game she missed it in fact she played
the move Bishop F7 but after check and
Bishop C4 she had to give up her queen
and the game was over
um Christian back over to you thank you
uh Yasser we are with Sam Shanklin the
author of very tense game against Hans
Neiman uh Sam in the opening it felt
like he dropped a theoretical bomb with
this move Queen to C1 tell us a bit
about that it certainly doesn't bust the
Nim so I prepared this and for like
several games including one with Chris
jerk and one with narian and I just
never got to use it but I think that
black is certainly fine but it's not
that easy to play his position like for
example
um probably the most accurate is to play
H6 First bishop H4 and only now Bishop
B7 so that I don't have H4 but like this
is tough and then that's it's sort of
and it's also a little scary to play H6
when you know that I could in theory
play H4 and response but it's um there's
probably other ways to equalize but here
like and we were looking at trying to
understand the differences with this
move C5 and E4 now you take it there's
no more G5 there okay Bishop F1 King F1
I believe E5 E5 is my move which is very
tough to find I think and even then we
can still play it but no I mean there's
a there's a variation with Queen C2
instead of Queen Z1 and this one black
is definitely supposed to play H6
Bishop H4 and then Knight speed D7 and
now E4 comes in Queen C8 and basically
the point is here black is fine because
after Bishop A6 Queen A6 uh Queen C6
already we're trying to screw this up
with White Queen D3 the big point is
that now after E5 because he's managed
to flick in H6 and Bishop H4 Knight D5
comes and I cannot take his Knight I'll
be mated and now I'm in trouble between
native four and I made it so
um so basically the whole point with
Queen C1 is to try to discourage H6 so
if black plays Knight bd7 I can just
play the same line honestly like yeah so
if it was like H6 now now after Knight
video seven this is the point is that
now the currency and Navigator G4 G4 and
now this gets very I mean even here I
think black is probably fine but good
luck
so uh yeah I mean the way he played it I
don't know I mean Bishop B7 is probably
basically fine the way he played uh H4
and now Knight C6 I mean I I didn't have
this move it looks really bad and it
doesn't seem like like it's a slight
mistake at least yeah I mean I I know
there was he can take the pawn with
Bishop of three and queen D4 but it's
very scary
um C5 I think sort of equalizes after DC
Knight D7 C6 Rook C8 Knight D4 95 but
still a queen F4 I go Rook do like
there's some line here Rook C8 Knight D4
95 Queen F4 and computer calls this
equal after Knight C6 this much I knew
but okay take take Rook D1 I swing Rook
H3 around some point the Bishops matter
I don't know
um but uh yeah yeah well I thought he
would take with the Rook but anyhow it
doesn't matter um but the way he played
with uh with Knight C6 looked very
suspicious to me and I thought I should
just be better but I was struggling a
little bit to find the way I was very
surprised by Knight D5 actually as well
and I think the computer was saying H5
yeah but
uh just because after age six you can't
think of it yeah but if you take Sun for
somehow didn't love my Pawn on H5 now
and
um yeah so H6 and it's not so easy for
me to coordinate I thought Black's
probably more a lot of time to take
probably too much that's that's way too
much work I see it at night F5 so yeah I
don't know I mean I thought Rook C1 felt
natural enough and the real question was
if I could do something better than what
I did I don't know I mean
thought this was coming and I wasn't so
sure yeah
um so uh yeah I thought I was better
here I wasn't sure how much but um uh
yeah so take take Knight D2 and I was
absolutely shocked by D5 I thought this
totally underestimated the danger of the
structure I mean I think he's worse if
he doesn't play this but probably not
that much worse than should holds but
here I actually thought I had very good
winning chances and I really came very
close to winning at the end I think
um if we go forward
yeah I didn't know about playing B4 B5 I
was worried that he will go Bishop A4
and then Knight C6 and
uh so any once he does that done enough
he's got A5 coming with actual counter
play which I didn't like so I thought I
should play B5 I understood this sort of
just on the queen side but the problem
was I just couldn't quite break through
there was a critical one I think was
right on move 40.
um yeah so here I thought he's just in
huge trouble
um okay so yeah if you find I don't know
maybe this is just a draw but so here
take take sure and I was expecting A6
after Bishop C2 actually
A6 or A5 yeah well I thought S6 just be
very forcing okay BS ba6 and then
apparently it's just fine I think one of
the lines was yeah bishop
xp57 and Knight B3 to try to go for the
E6 Pawn Yeah uh but it's not enough yeah
so yeah uh yeah but the way I thought it
came very close to winning so after I
got Knight B1 Bishop G8
A5 I think Bishop F7 was only move right
because if he plays Bishop H7 I believe
it's lost I gotta take take and then
Knight D2 or A6 yes yeah and this one
was winning I was really hoping for that
but he made the right decision to come
back to F7
and then A6
yeah and so here Knight A3 was good so
now I'm just curious if I can win this
position after Bishop D7 because my
understanding here is if I can put my
net on G4 I believe white wins okay then
like I'm the king I'm threatening Knight
C6 and I'm threatening King F4 and G5
and he cannot stop both of them and the
problem is that his Knight is terrible
on C5 but I was sort of thinking here I
don't actually see how I can get my
knight to E4 was the problem without
letting his Knight get free let's see
this
computer issue Bishop yeah but the
problem is I need to defend the B5 Pawn
to get my note to D4 and I didn't see
how to do this so say you try to put the
bishop on this diagram yeah I think if
he doesn't play Knight E4 he probably
loses actually like I mean well okay
let's say like I don't know if he goes
Bishop B8 if he just wastes time Bishop
E2 Bishop D7 I suspect I should win this
if my knight gets to E4 but yes like so
we go now King E3 I think waiting one I
mean I guess you can always just go 94
but if you just yeah that move just says
Knight C2
and then King wherever F7 Knight D4 and
then yeah once I got the Knight to D4
it's winning so I guess but he has 94 in
time so I also could have tried Knight
C3 on move 39.
instead of Knight A3
with the points that's now I can it's
easier to go Bishop D1 D2 but the
problem is here after something like
King f8 and then Bishop D1 I think you
can still play Knight E4 here what's the
issue I think this is still just to draw
and I don't believe I will win yep
which was very frustrating yeah um but
uh yeah I thought I came very close but
I guess with a couple
I just couldn't quite get the
coordination in time at the end he
played very accurately now one thing uh
that you always feel very proud about is
your physical prowess and the fact that
you're working out and the fact that you
can maintain energy levels throughout
the long event this is a very long event
do you feel that helps you well I guess
we'll see in rounds 11 12 13. I can't
remember ever losing the last round of a
US Championship I don't believe I've
ever lost the final round
um but no I mean you know Fitness is not
wildly relevant until you've you know
started to play seven eight nine games
but you know I certainly hope it'll help
guys any uh extra questions just on that
note uh Sam uh Fitness what do you do
tennis basketball
one two uncoordinated for sports all my
teammates would hate me
um no I do a lot of weights I do
calisthenics I have a Peloton I like to
ride
um do a lot of like weighted pull-ups
weighted push-ups and try to also just
like I live in a very walkable area and
so just walking to everything grocery
store restaurants you just like average
four miles a day just by choosing to
walk even if you're not trying to
explicitly exercise it burns a lot of
calories keeps you fit I mean I'm not uh
you know the biggest Health Nutrition
Fitness Guru there's ever been but you
know I do things that work for me and uh
well I think it's helped so far fair
enough uh good luck in the tournament uh
Sam
and our results so far are Anastasia as
let's start with the open let's check
them
so we have how many already just four
results yes and we're on our normal to
the trees per round
yes we may very very well may uh with
three games remaining yeah so we have uh
two decisions games two draws now just
Sam was here he made a draw against Hans
and
um
see that uh I Wonder has won that uh
that that was the double A pawns versus
the center and in the ladies in the
ladies section uh
defeated Jennifer yes then it will draw
between Sabina and Anna and two other
doors actually we have more doors in
women's sections
we usually have four victories around in
the ladies only one thus far with three
remaining yes
and back to Christian uh you have a also
another guess we do have a Wonder Liang
after his victory against Alex lenerono
Wanderer first of all congratulations uh
a difficult tournament after this point
especially the game yesterday against
elshon tell us a bit about how did you
approach this uh game with the white
pieces together
yeah I had two pieces to do after my
game with elshon so I just spent the
night working on homework
um didn't really have much time to look
at anything really and
um yeah I was like out of book after
move three so
um basically like I I I I didn't really
know what to do against the sloth
um and I guess that just kind of happens
when you're sub 2700 level you know I
mean you like to watch the guys like
Kawana but sometimes you have to look at
my games just to see the struggle for
the rest of us so yeah I saw Jeffrey
played Queen C2 against Darius so I was
like okay Jeffrey used to be 2700
probably it's a decent move
um and yeah we've got some normal
position I think so you were playing
from memory yeah from Eastern memories
of the past watching a game yeah I don't
think sure I'll pay Quincy too yeah I
was I was well out of books so I thought
like I would just play something random
um maybe lose this game quickly and then
get back to homework again
so you know I was really surprised when
actually I got a decent position because
I don't think Queen C2 is the main move
but it's it's a move yeah it looks like
a move at least five G3 yeah okay this
apparently is some kind of line and yeah
A4 looked interesting the idea is that
in some lines after Knight B6 and then
maybe my D4 Pawn is hanging so if I
provoke A4 A5 then like his nylon B6
would be very loose
um it's going to B3 yeah here I might
have like Knight H4 rookie one something
like that
um yeah I was just happy that he wasn't
blitzing anything out anymore so
um I didn't hang a piece and basically
you took him out of uh yes his
preparation for sure yeah so here I mean
probably he's equalizing after it takes
takes Bishop B4 but at least I have my
Pawn A5 so I have like some space
advantage and also the center is very
secure
um and yeah I think basically it was
equal until I'm not sure he played E5 um
if you keep going yep so yeah just trade
some pieces and I think this is totally
fine yeah and here he played E5 which I
wasn't I didn't really understand what
the point was
um I thought maybe if he just played
like Knight B6 instead or I mean
Queen takes A5 it's very normal position
I mean yeah yeah the a pawn is a little
weak but okay you should be able to hold
and and like a lot of cases like the
five on four is not even yeah yeah
especially if like let's say I have e45
then like that's definitely holdable so
absolutely yeah I think probably he was
he was just a little overconfident
um you know when I got the wild card
I sort of thought that the stainless
chess club like always needs a punching
bag so it looked like um yeah you
probably thought like I blended
something but I'm not too sure um and
after d takes E5 like he thought for
quite a while so
um yeah normally that's not a good sign
when you're like sacrificing pawns
pretty sure if you're 2600 you can never
call yourself a punching bag you're into
A2 Queen takes A2 and you felt quite
comfortable with the uh huge majority on
King side yeah yeah I mean it's probably
it might not be winning but I think
practically it's just very hard for him
to defend this like he has to generate
counter play in like very unexpected
ways and
I think probably like after Bishop e394
it looked maybe almost okay for him
um like yeah maybe here in Knight C3 or
something
and then Rook CA and try and trade a
pair of Rooks because yeah once he
trades the Rooks then um like Bay Pawn
yeah basically like I I would much
rather have two Rooks on the board so
that when Rook is active and here like
okay he has a lot of counter play
um but yeah I think yeah and especially
after Knight D6
um yeah he allowed Rook C7 and the
seventh Rank and like okay now it's
entire queen size is falling apart
absolutely so yeah I mean probably just
an off day for Alex because yeah his
play seemed a little strange in the
middle game but yeah still happy to get
the win very happy to get the winner
wonder you mentioned that you're doing
homework how do you balance your
academic career as well as your chess
career yeah I think at the moment I'm
much more of a student than a chess
player
um you know it's really funny because I
was going to come in here and talk about
how it's really hard to do everything
and like school is taking a lot of time
from my preparation but then I see
Jennifer in the other section also in
college wearing all her games and like
bad excuse does it hold up that much
water anymore
um probably got to ask her how it's done
from my end yeah I mean I would like to
play better chess going forward but I
guess we'll see like and what do you
study in college at the University of
Chicago
we're taking various classes right now
the major is still undecided so you know
plenty of directions to go still
figuring it out and you mentioned this
tournament uh that you're going to miss
school to your professors what was uh
their response
um most of them said like the first line
was like congratulations and then the
second line was like I still expect you
to turn everything in
so you know not much you can do on that
end but yeah still glad to be here
um it's a good it's a great event and
and yeah you know it's it's been an
enjoyable experience thus far I wonder
congratulations we'll see you in the
remainder of the games thank you uh
lovely interview there I can understand
that this very awkward situation of
trying to balance uh being a student a
full-time students
championships he plays I mean it's not
an excuse me of homework I mean it's
unbelievable right it's not like my dog
eat my homework please please cut me
some slacks
he has to do his homework I mean what's
what's going on here exactly I mean we
have to take to do something about it
take measures indeed write to my
congressman uh something like that and
we're getting prepared for another
interview before we go on break as start
to have won a very very nice uh
attacking game and she's going to be
hooked up with uh Christian and they're
ready we're ready yeah where do you
Christian thought of a big victory
against one of the co-leaders going into
uh this round Jennifer you take us
through this very tense game
um I mean it was a lot of back and forth
we both manage our time really poorly
and at some point something happened we
didn't have time and then they came
under the social version of this game
yeah so here's the critical moment so I
think at this point we were wondering
and you uh both were having close to 10
minutes with a lot of moves in this
position in an hour on our class because
there's nothing critical happen until
this point and queen 25 was an option as
well did you consider this movie yeah
but it doesn't work g65
so or according to F5 sorry
I used to have been the right move oh no
I didn't like taking only five I just
didn't feel comfortable doing that it's
too much happening on that files too
many pieces that is true and you are
perfectly right because after F5 you
have to force okay there is no way I can
calculate this absolutely and you played
Bishop to E3 yeah that is the safer
option how did you assess the position
Oh I thought that five was a mistake I
thought she has to take only three
that one
and I thought this position is okay like
my pawn shops just ruined but I have a
bishop I have that file
definitely some conversation yeah
foreign
a lot of pressure on F7 don't worry
about the computer
I've covered my net I can't make it at
some point go F5 take with the e-pawn I
don't know like I thought
this can be quite dangerous for her and
I think actually the engines are just
finding some sort of very uh concrete
lines Knight F6 if you go to F3 Knight
G6 and things of this nature change uh
the structure but
she played F5 and allowed you to get at
least momentarily heruk on H7 yeah even
here she has to take only four
yes and then I think Bishop C5
and then yeah take because there are
some lines where she can try to trap my
like E4 Knight F6 and then my knight on
H4 like she can go G5 my knight is trap
that's why I had Bishop C5 so I can take
only seven yeah so might not can get but
I thought even here I should be doing
fine because the position opened and I
have two Bishops and the pawn on e4
could become a liability in the future
yeah she has to have something concrete
because the long term like this has to
be really nice for me absolutely and it
does seem like that's the case as well
Rook takes A7 she played yeah this is
already losing for her because
everything is hanging down I probably
have many ways of playing here not so
much I think uh you did find the most
precise way Rook takes C8 and queen 2 uh
G6 after that I thought of a good
victory for you how does that feel how
does it feel to take uh Jennifer you out
in this game
uh yeah it feels good
I'm very unhappy with playing I just
don't trust myself can make any
decisions I think it stems from not
playing a lot of chats taking long
breaks
but yeah it's an important Victory she's
a very dangerous player the year she won
she had 10 out of 11 so when she goes on
the streak she becomes Unstoppable so
yeah I think this was crucial for me
guys
no our congratulations to us have a
wonderful game a nervy game because of
the time trouble but uh very
entertaining to call and I think it's
time to gain your confidence back I mean
you're really doing well in this
tournament don't say anymore not good I
said you're my inspiration every time I
come here I get such positive feedback
more often yeah I got more up and uh as
we prepare ourselves for a break over
here we just wanted to say yesterday's
interview with Christopher you uh did uh
light up the uh Twitter sphere yes
absolutely yes and YouTube of course
exactly so as we go on break and enjoy a
replay of the Christopher interview from
round two see on the other side biggest
win of your career how do you feel you
just took down the defending U.S
Champion with the black pieces
I feel like it's a great Redemption from
yesterday
especially after after seeing their
interview and everything I felt like I
was kind of disrespected and it was also
kind of a wake-up call that I really
needed to improve my openings and
everything how did you feel after that
game yesterday because you had your
chances as well right and there's some
rivalry between you and Hans it seals I
just I felt disrespected on every level
and why why is that did why did you take
it personally I guess because after
after the like after the interview and
everything
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to round three and we start
with women results we have three draws
so far and one decisive game between
taty obrahiman and Jenny for you a very
very big game that was and in the open
section what results have we so far
after
round three yes let's check them also
and we have two decisive game one game
more than women section so far and I
wonder uh one against Alex and
Christopher you against elshon so two
games finished in Bros they're a very
eventful draw took place in the Sam
Shanklin versus Hans Neiman we just had
an interview with Sam where he berated
the fact that he was so close to getting
the ideal setups that would have led to
a victory uh in the remaining games that
are going on currently I'm on the open
uh between the Lanier and Ray Robson
after this last move Rook h8 even though
the presence of the Bishops of opposite
colors
it's very clear that white is the one
pressing as Lanier always has this move
F5 and the majority on the queen side
is not as useful as uh White's majority
so for example linear might just putting
something on the board for just a moment
set up a situation such as the following
where these four pawns are literally
being harnessed by these two pawns pawns
on A5 and B4 you can imagine that the
bishop would sit on C5 and then Black's
King is out of the game now how White's
King gets to Journeys to G5 so you can
play that's a completely subtle a
separate question how that all happens
but I would say that uh Lanier is
fighting for two results in this game if
the game ends in a draw well Ray should
probably count as lucky stars as he's
definitely on the back foot now in the
other two remaining games Lavon is
definitely in trouble Sam Savion one of
our tournament co-leaders coming into
today's round is enjoying a very very
healthy extra Pawn against the
formidable of honoronian as we can see
White's structure is a little bit messed
up but yeah give white the chance to
play F5 F6 and you can imagine that he
could easily realize his material
advantage and then finally we have a
game that's kind of difficult to call
this game between uh darush and Fabi as
both sites have have some trumps but
first impressions are that Fabi has
managed to turn the tide a little in
this one Christian oh Bobby was doing
great up to this move yeah it was
completely winning if he would have
played Rook takes E5 instead of Queen
takes E7 so the wrong Pawn wrong he took
the wrong Pawn Rook takes E5 and this
gives him a plus 4 Advantage wow that's
pretty significant group to have faith
and follow that route on the eighth Rank
and try to get to the king this it's all
about getting to the King after Rook 28
in order to not get checkmated you have
to drop the Rook back to d8 but after I
take take now I pick up the pawn on C7
with a Tempe and I'm going to also pick
up the pawn on F4 you don't have time to
venture and take my Pawn on A2 because
you're going to get checkmated you have
to keep the queen on the long diagonal
and unfortunately uh this is going to
lead to some problems for you so this
was a big moment he took on C7 and now
another critical moment because if he
sees the next sequence of moves Darius
that is he has great chances of
potentially saving this game the big
sequence is take on G3 first you have to
probably take with the H Pawn and it's
the most natural to take with the h-pawn
not open up the second rank for a
potential root coming to D2 and now
Queen to C3
now the idea is that if you take on B7 I
can take on G3 not only that you're not
winning you're actually losing you're
getting checkmated with the white pieces
so this is key queen to G3 he must see
this after Queen takes E3 Rook takes E3
if you do take the pawn on E5 I just
simply take take then I go after your uh
A2 pawn and this is just a technical
draw I'm going to take the B7 I'm going
to take the A2 and then we're going to
uh to exchange the A3 for the B3 pawn
two versus one we know that this is a
draw still some work to do on the
defensive side but it's a technical draw
big moment right now if he says F takes
G3 followed by Queen to C3 but once
again he's down to his last one minute
so maybe we can pan out on the bird's
eye view and see his reaction as he's
facing this difficult decision
and Anastasia also had a question for
you uh Christian Queen C3 Rook takes E5
maybe just to check it I mean I have
some again oh absolutely yes yes so the
idea is Queen C3 by the way only move
for darsh but what if I
um no no first I take on G3 and that's
key uh yes I take on G3 this is key this
is key you have to start by taking on G3
first yes absolutely because otherwise
it would work this way which he did with
10 seconds on his clock ten seconds and
now if you take on E5 I think I can take
control that's a point because otherwise
if you take the queen on C7 Rook E8 and
then rookie seven yes
very nice I just wanted to show that
actually there is this idea very nicely
spotted but unfortunately Rook just
three wow yeah that just really uh
you give these guys one chance and they
will find it they're that good they
really are now the question though
obviously Queen C3 I liked what you were
saying about you know you trade on E5
you do end up liquidating the whole
Queen side so it's two versus one we'll
accept that that is going to be a draw
but do I have to be so compliant could I
just play a move like rookie two and
kind of slow play it maybe play for King
G3 and I don't know even on a good day
yeah for rookie before yes you can
definitely do that and this will
probably give you a better end game
right is it sufficient to win that's a
big question that the players will have
to answer definitely the chances to hold
all this one with the black pieces
increase compared to what you had before
after Rook takes C5 you would have
gotten checkmated pretty much so exactly
um yeah seven was a huge huge blunder
allowing Darius back into the game and
also right now Fabiano is facing a
pretty difficult decision because
Queen takes E3 is not the only move
maybe you can try to calculate Queen to
F7
and then try to run with a king right
the root takes G3 take on G3 Queen takes
G3 and King to F1
to cover the uh file right and also
threatening The Rook so take take
Windows three and then we run the F1 and
now do we have the Perpetual so King to
Queen to H3
let's keep going and now Queen to G2
right
yes but what if you go King ah if you go
King E3 now Queen to G3 and you never
have time to cover with the queen
because one of the Rooks is under attack
and if you go to the D file you allow my
route to get in uh involved into the
attack then it comes
whoa that's uh that's a nasty chat and
actually no you know
why did we put the pawn on A3 wow
you have to be a bit careful now we know
wow uh this is a big moment guys I mean
uh if you don't mind in the moment that
darish played the move Rook takes D3 was
it a Time trouble for for uh the Fabi
because he has 31 minutes so he could
have so Rook takes he didn't calculate
Rook takes E5 yeah he he could have
remarkable spend some time on it and and
calculate the 65 and try to play it like
that and that according to the engines
Anastasia was a a four plus four upon
Advantage for Fabi so this was a pretty
uh nasty uh Miss I'm not used to seeing
uh Fabi mishandle winning positions I
mean we can all we can all
mishandle them but uh not Fabby I feel
this was this is his biggest problem
right now in this stage of his career in
the past let's say a year I remember
even at the American Cup uh no actually
at the sinkfield cup he played against
linear Dominguez and he had twice a plus
five six on the engine advantage and he
did not manage to uh find the right
solution so it's a problem it's a
problem that he will have to address in
time of course because you cannot solve
everything in uh one day but he
definitely needs to be worried about
that you know this feeling when you come
back after the game and then you see the
computer and it say it shows plus four I
mean that's not the best moment yeah
seriously it's depressing it is
depressing I mean I you know I always
before the engines became so strong it
was like chess was a mystery right like
did I miss a win did I did I miss a draw
I would come back and I felt good yes
when I made the discovery of the truth
yes it's like okay I worked hard and I
found for myself that yes yes sir you're
an idiot you missed the win I felt good
now I come back and I'm instantly told
I'm an idiot I just read today this
phrase that all moves look good until
you open if you don't check them with
the engine if you don't analyze them yes
so that's exactly probably what you
described don't really check your games
you believe that you're genius right
then unfortunately you come home it's
depressing it's depressing all right
we'll keep our eye on that what's going
on in the ladies uh what do we have
first of all uh uh begum uh she's made
life difficult for herself but on the
other hand she's still got the winning
in her grasp it's difficult to say yes
they're really close to that but it's
difficult to say sure objectively maybe
she's still winning but how easy is it
to convert this Advantage because you
also have to look around for a potential
H4 H3 so you need to keep this bishop on
the d8h4 diagonal but how do you make
progress if you don't include your
Bishop into uh the attack so Bishop to G
5 I see this is what the computer is
recommending Knight to A5 King to D4
King to B2 but then my knight goes back
okay how do you make any progress if I
manage to exchange the knights at some
point and go into an opposite color
Bishop end game that's a problem that
might actually uh become a problem in
the position and allow black to make the
draw so it's not an easy conversion
definitely not an easy conversion she
will be having to look at her opponent's
time as well well her time as well 16
minutes and 55 seconds for beg him 14
minutes for Rochelle and as we get
closer to the second time control well
the final minutes of the second time
control that's when this game will be
decided all right wow I mean I I
remember getting a position where there
was a rook on C7 the double Bishops on
A6 and B6 I'm out we got this position I
want to say by the way a big shout out
to uh Megan uh
um uh lee uh she found in a very I mean
if I gave you this position as a study
as a you know like how can white save it
I mean it's going to be a challenge for
a lot of the top uh Grandmasters of the
world especially when you say okay King
E2 King G7 this move is not intuitive at
all my goodness what a move F5 King
takes G3 and the players eventually did
get to a position where neither side
could make progress uh Irina did her
best to try to
triangulate and trick uh Megan but uh
Megan was up to the task and it was a
draw uh unbelievable very very very hard
played by by players yes but especially
Megan who had to find this really hard
defense and again right here Arena that
come come up with this wonderful
exchange sacrifice Rick takes Pawn takes
followed up by Knight C4 again not in an
easy intuitive move you want to take the
pawn on C3 and then there's only one
possibility
to save the game Rook D3 Queen B6 Rook
d8 I'm in
she deserved to draw I mean and the
specialist yeah and by keeping that draw
the eight-time U.S Champion is at 50
percent and Megan is at uh plus two but
we do have one other game beside the
Rochelle game going on and that's
between Rue Yang and Sophie and this
looks like the Knight is just dominating
the bishop
white extra Pawn on the queen side means
that 96 and yes it just moves forward I
don't know if there's way to stop it I
don't think so I don't think so either I
think that uh Rue Yang
Ayan is going to win this game back over
to you Christian what do you have for us
I'm looking at this game between Sam
sevion and leveronian and I'm trying to
understand how big of an advantage does
somehow Sam has plus 1.6 by the engine
but how do you make progress right
that's the question
at some point my guess is that he's
going to try to go Knight to E3 and
Knight to F5 try to Target this bishop
on D6 that is blockading my expansion on
the D file so this is key how do you
gonna stop that let's say Rook to d8
Knight to E3 Bishop to C5 Rook to D3
Bishop to D6 and I finally get my knight
to F5 so what is Black's response right
now apparently you need to save this
bishop with the move Bishop to f8 and
now D6 with the Knight on F5 is not as
easy uh to be played so let's transition
this Knight back to E4 Bishop T6 Knight
to e for sure I think this is pretty
much the best position that I can get as
white I still go F5 and the question is
how
is this position winning no it's not
actually this is easy to tell because
you don't have the king coming to E5
there's no way you can approach this
Pawn once you land on D4 I'm going to
take on D5 you lose the pawn so how are
you going to approach uh this position
you can do this this and try to go
behind let's say I just stay around and
you try to go behind and uh go to the C
file nope you're not going on the C file
you if you try to get to D4 I'm going to
pick up the pawn on D5 so this is a
blockade from Black's perspective this
is an easy uh draw the material is too
limited so despite the fact that the
engine is saying this is an almost
winning position objectively I don't see
it that way I think Levon has good
chances to save this one
um okay one idea you were saying was to
get rid of the bishop on D6 Christian I
like that uh the the the line that I
thought was even more attractive for
white was simply
with the Knight on G4 going playing for
F5 and playing for F6 okay now hold on I
don't think I've uh let me just refresh
my board for just a second the bishop he
just played Bishop Bishops yeah so so
just a second go back uh
so Rook D4 I'm not sure why I play my
Rook on D4 if uh e just goes F5 and
plays for F6
yourself so let's go F6 well that was my
question and that's probably the ugliest
structure you could have for the bishop
but I mean
ugly is ugly but how am I still going I
still have to prove a victory yeah you
have to go like well maybe in this case
I can go Rook E3 I would like to I'd
like to drop my rook in on E6 now that
you've played F6 let's go d8 yeah
Bishop somewhere okay okay so let's just
say I sit I'm I'm gonna wait for you to
improve your position how do you do it
let's say Rook A5 yeah sure okay uh sure
now uh Rook A5
um well you just played the king oh King
H7 okay
my knight my knight I'm reaching for my
night
I'm hovering like Christopher I'm
hovering uh my knight needs to go to E4
and it's not intuitive obviously how I'm
intuitively obvious how I'm going to get
there come on maybe we'll go with the
net Logistics
C5 Rook C5 just wavy away from the C4
Square well now it's time to double up
on the seventh right oh no ah it will be
three okay
with my knight on E3 I'm really that's
feeling good I'll go C7 Rook the C7
you're very close I'll I'll give you
that
now if I go Bishop C5 you go Rook C6
correct
that looks uh and you if you go Rook
here I mean it just feels like you've
you've been backpedaling I know I know I
know I know but how do you make progress
are you still uh same question right
uh I guess it's just on Bishop E5 let's
say or maybe bishop B8 immediately
creates some sort of a threat yes so
let's say the Knight cannot move I'm not
100 sure what threat it should be seven
Bishop A7 was my thread but you go D6
and that doesn't feel like a threat no
no I'm helping you it feels like help
Okay so let's go Bishop E5 but uh the
point that I was trying to make is that
I I mean the move F6 is kind of ugly it
is I agree but on the other hand just if
you don't play six yourself then I was
thinking I will play F6 and disturb uh
the king side Fortress now what we have
in the game however is quite different
um we have Bishop C5 Rook C4 and Lavon
is thinking do I come back make keep the
blockade on a D6 with my Bishop because
for the moment the night ng4 looks a
little bit weird right Knight E5 now if
I was in there yeah that would be
something I would really aspire to to a
play if I could
um maybe even my idea was 96 will be
possible absolutely absolutely you
studied the rook and Rook at night uh
checkmating patterns yes well again this
would be huge for Sam sevillan he comes
in today's round uh tied for first with
one and a half points should he win he
would be our clear tournament leader
yeah he's one of the most talented
actually players in in America I guess I
mean he is considered talented long time
ago right Jeffrey Zhang uh
yeah wow really really uh great uh
talented players that we have in the
United States that's why this mixture of
that in players like Wesley slow and
Fabby mix them up with Christopher you
and Hans Neiman for that matter very
young 19 year old uh yeah simply the
World Cup I remember I was thinking
Billy see it's been a long time ago
already I mean discovered years I mean
also didn't help them much right because
they couldn't really participate in the
tournaments at that period of time but
so as I know that he started to chess a
lot yes and he constantly trying to
improve so it pays him back I mean last
time in the U.S Championship he tied for
the first place very very good result I
guess for him so he's very ambitious
also in this event I mean I like this
approach like they're not afraid to play
against the top players in the world
actually they're hungry they want to
beat them I mean then it's really
impressive to show that they belong by
the way turning to the game between Fabi
and darouche for just a moment we did
see that Queen trade by the way uh this
move Rook takes G3 easy to spy that that
move is actually a winning threat
provoke the trade of Queens rookie two
as expected darush is going for that two
versus one ending inviting Rook takes E5
I suppose if I were in fabi's shoes I'd
be more inclined to playing F4 so that
Rook B2 again I'm making it as difficult
as I can for my opponent to get into the
the rook and pawn end game that he's
trying to get into with King F3 still
Advantage Fabi is it enough for win on
doubtful Lanier versus Ray Robson again
this Bishops of opposite color oh dear
no no no no Rooks okay no Rooks but okay
I've got a very clear idea right King
King
[Music]
I'll put the bishop back but the king
will you should one time yes
um
I mean you need to spend time so then I
move my king maybe and I have this
bishop defiles it's funny I I I'd almost
like to use the pawn for a Tempo like
you know I would play the move B4 not
worrying about Bishop takes C2 but
regretting the fact that later in life
when we have our Kings and oppositions
I'm I'm not pawned down I just don't get
to play c2c3 right
so it's not about fun it's more about
this the tempo so for example King
Bishop I'm not sure you should take it
by the way King what give me the second
bonus oh sorry uh that one I didn't know
I'm not sure
the first one was okay okay
Bishop Bishop thanks yeah I wanted this
to just keep your structure
and I I'm I land on F6 yes and I suppose
you keep your Bishop but how can you
make any progress yes well just a second
I go here and we wait right that's okay
yeah now I go here I got your idea let's
exists after uh maybe you go King E8
though
and I'm kind of stuck you are because
there is a five yes whenever I go E6 I
take F6 E5 yes immediately otherwise yes
you can
you just uh and I don't think you can no
but of course we have to check it
because it's really I think okay in this
position so Bishop push push
takes push push
yeah even if I win this Pawn it's almost
like a redundancy uh you did play B4 by
the way I will give you the pawns right
now I will go C5 then go
c64. I'll give you the pawns so that
whenever you transfer even if you manage
to fly your king to B7 somehow I will
always have uh Bishop coming to B5
that's going to defend both pawns and I
will take care of your F Pawn with my
king
very good point uh this definitely now
does look like it's heading to a draw
but uh Ray probably is not going to be
that happy because
he was just defending defending I mean
chess should be you know about my
chances too right this is just Berlin
yeah
you need to have a special setup of mind
and special character probably to play
it with black if you don't deserve your
own chances when you play the Berlin
yeah take what you get which is a draw
exactly uh picking up the action between
Sam sevion and Lavon aronian check King
went back the blockade as you said uh
Christian the bishop brought back Knight
is coming again the square G4
well I'm not a big fan of the square G4
F5 looks more attractive and uh
well I don't think anybody's made
progress at this moment I think he just
also maybe they're playing this game
like looking for some opportunities
maybe he will come back to a different
uh plan later on like I really like your
plan with the 506 really because I don't
see anything else I mean this really
looks very very attractive but maybe he
wants to check what he will play in this
situation in that situation by the way
remember talking to Michael gervich
about a game that he played with Larry
Christensen and the point was he was
playing with two Pawns in the night
against a rook and what he did is he
just played and played and played not
trying to make any progress but what he
was trying to do was play for the clock
to get Larry in a situation that he was
only on his increment now I don't know
what the times are between uh Sam and uh
Lavon yes
[Laughter]
this is very uh a very experienced move
by Levon he just uh took off from the
board and let Sam think about it right
all the way to your last minute right
and Sam uh Sammy's like no no no I'm not
gonna fall for that oh the Knight went
back to G4 kind of indication that Sam's
spinning his wheels he doesn't quite
have you know in mind uh the winning
plan he just
trying to nurse his extra Pawn maybe he
wants to go to E5 yes I thought of 95
and then if you
probably six then I go on ig6 yes and
then maybe some checkmates on the eighth
rank if I manage to get with my route
there yes I'm Dreaming I'm Dreaming
we're dealing with the answer
I'm daytime dreaming daytime dreaming
Knight E5 uh more or less around these
parts uh didn't live on in a very
similar position play the move Rook E8
by the way just to try to discourage
Knight E5
or did he keep the blockade I think I
think it's still black to play the
player yes 94 so he
thinks lemon is very very experienced
player he will never ever give he will
always try to find some tricks right
until the end you cannot relax Ricky ate
in fact so he's kind of repeating his
experience of this position from the
past little while uh trying to
discourage 95 by just saying okay go
ahead tell me your best setup keeping in
mind that this Pawn is on pre
maybe Sam will come back to F5
F6 since
it's kind of running out of ideas as
well as clock time just I mean the 5
aware like it's a responsible move that
um
like you you don't have this 95 anymore
right I mean yes like probably he's
still not sure maybe it is a five pound
but as Bobby Fischer famously said what
to get squares you got to get gifts
you get something I get something huh
F5
we'll see again down to two minutes and
let's let's just jump uh we we want to
uh share Rue Yang Victory as she used
her past Pawn on the queen side as a
decoy to get the pawn on G7 as well as
the pawn on E6 with Knight takes E6
Knight F4 the g-pawn is going to run and
she will win this game
also how about begum how is begum doing
oh Bishop's about opposite color these
are notorious
uh
has Rochelle
fought her way back to a draw
um I don't think so I I think she made
some mistakes is King 2g5 on the board
right yes it is we're expecting Bishop
e84 right and then it's that kind of uh
might be able to put you in a Zeus one
right now so it's a favorite word yeah
our producer Tom Williams loves Zeus
the language of chess uh okay so my
Bishop is looking at the pawn on C6 is
defending the pawn on H5 you're actually
forcing me to move my king correct okay
so King drops back to E7 let's go King
F5 okay let's try to invade that I need
to get to that D6 square right
if I manage to get the king to D6 I
think I'm going to be able to push my
Pawns
the king okay so uh uh I'll uh so let's
go King E5 I'll keep you honest
King to D7
I remember when the bones are very close
to each other we have more chances after
that I'm not sure if it's not clear here
but it's very important when the where
the ponds are far apart then it's very
hard for the defender in that case let's
give you a check instead of King E5 I'm
going to Bishop C6 I'm going to give you
a check Oh you mean Kate D6 yes uh
Bishop D6 check immediately so let's say
where do you go you block your Bishop
right right on the other hand I will
take you four pound no no you don't
because I go E5 that's that's my idea
you go E5 now I'll go E5 now and at the
moment I play Bishop D5 or something
like that yeah
is this enough because even this is not
clear whether it's enough or not right
because like what I go King here
three or King F5 boy I I think a
database just should kind of came up
and
let's check at the moment you played
King F5 cool let's play H4 and get rid
of the last pawns and then keep this
position remember if you go back sorry
go back just I remember this moment King
is on F5 here instead of Bishop D5 they
seems to be winning guys H4 not working
like I'm trying
oh yes I don't think it's working
because I have E6 first oh yes that's
important maybe then I pick up the pawn
on H4
which is key yes and I don't have G3
anymore yes there's no G3 so I don't
have this temp no
no well she played Bishop F4 so we're in
the position
this is the way this is why you started
it right yes Bishop F4 is is the right
start because we know if you go Bishop
C6 and we exchange the E4 for both the
H5 and G4 the pawns are two separated
yes now it's too far three files away
and that's winning
I remember you you could use even
fingers or or your hands right and put
it on the board kind of measuring how
far the bones are for each other it's
really good about winning the person I
don't know you had this kind of tricks
yeah no I it was always like the rule of
five or how do you know how many fingers
yeah yeah right and it depends on the
board yeah
Bobby had huge hands I mean his hands
might go from the the B file to the G
file I mean
yeah too big okay uh what does it mean
you get five right now it's it's it's a
big move will she find this plan of
trying to include her King into the
attack on the other side
King F6 or King D6 King E7 on the board
and you like the move King I think yeah
yeah that's a that's a very important
can I start with a check sure
um let's go King E5 and then go back to
the idea of Bishop G5 and King seven and
what if I go Bishop to G5 now check King
Diddy's King F5 and let's say I'm
waiting where do you wait on which
diagonal let's go E5 now finally
now King G6 now King G6 okay
uh
uh that's okay Bishop F6 Bishop F6
so I can
I can have like even though perhaps
Bishop F6 allows H4 now okay I need to
be careful I need to put the bishop on
F4
uh be a little bit more clever yes but I
don't like that score for the bishop
well if it wins upon but you go Bishop 3
and King D5 and then how do I defend
both pawns ah got you thank you so much
for that but now aren't I in time to
Queen this guy
um and maybe this is it this is the way
to do it
yeah I think you might be in time no
there's no way to stop me wow
and they're following our variation by
the way Bishop to D7 is on the board
right wow let me just refresh my my
board for just a quick second king E5
Bishop C6 they're actually going
straight into our variation wow
um you know
for Rochelle should she lose this game I
have to say like these types of losses I
mean they really it's it's it's like
you're you're in this
um a competitive oven of fire where
you're just like your your scorched
because you played so hard to defend you
were so close to making the draw it's
like you lost the game not once but
twice right you get a double zero you
know you don't get any any uh recompense
for having fought so well you still get
your big zero uh and King F5 on the
board uh
still what is the evaluation Christian
it does feel like right now after King
F5 this position is winning winning yes
for her it would feel like uh still it's
those type of games I think when both of
both players are unhappy right are you
doing it not twice but twice yeah and
the begging will be unhappy because she
had so winning position like a couple of
moves and she made it so long for
example even if she'll manage to win
this one she will not feel great so
let's say after normally yeah okay so
another player that tricked his opponent
is Fabiano caruana
winning his game against our history
don't do it twice it looks like yeah
well when we left it we left it here and
he did play F4 Rook B2 takes so now
we're
and where did it go wrong for Darvish
keep going yeah
E6
Perhaps
Perhaps the best way actually
um go back a couple of moves
so here instead of Rook C8 after Rook to
F2 maybe you can go Rook f8 aha
immediately yes
with the idea that after Rook F4 Rook
before I go back
Rook E8 and hunting your Pawn all the
time
yeah I kind oh okay five King G6 right
and you said Rook on F5 with your
kingdom
and now I just wait aha now I just wait
I go rookie seven let's see Rook E7 yes
remarkable so I'm
now I see what you're trying to do I'm
not even sure what I'm trying to do if
you if you let me know I'll be very
grateful so now I keep on waiting H6
okay
wow how do we feel about this it's
difficult to make progress because the
King has to defend this Rook right and
the other Rook has to defend E5 exactly
so it's a bit difficult I feel like I've
kind of reached my zenith here just a
moment uh what could I possibly do then
rookie five not easy but so let's see
where it kind of went wrong for darush
because King rock rock and
the king first of all got cut off that's
not good Pawn got to E6 oops sorry is
this the game that is the problem when
he took on F4 yes and now we've got two
connected past Pawns
and that should be all she wrote
King F3 Rook E2 and you're moving slowly
towards the other hook and he made that
decision to take on F4 with seven
seconds on the clock and this is the
problem you cannot allow yourself to
play half of the game on increment
exactly it is just not a good practical
decision and you will get punished
against this game just in strong players
so now you start moving yeah because
it's not like you're playing a fair play
I mean you you
your darish is a is a really really fine
player no question about it but if
you're constantly under time trouble
you're always feeling the stress you've
got to make your decisions within 30
seconds or a minute or two Bobby's got
30 minutes uh you're just going to make
mistakes and why is uh he's a 27 plus
player Darius yes absolutely but he just
has this huge problem with his time
management yep which it is a huge
problem and if you don't solve it you're
going to stay stuck at 26 70 26 80
you're never going to be able to push
only if you are not yes
right B5 by the way on the board now the
idea is that we go rookie two yes and
now if you go for example B4 I'm just
going to go rookie one and my thread is
E7
okay now you don't have time to play
Rook takes A2 because I make a queen
king E7 F6 F6 it's really that simple so
this move uh B5 uh rookie two on the
board and again we're threatening to go
E7 if we trade then I have a very simple
uh line of Victory I just go after the H
Pawn Black's King cannot capture on F5
my e-pawn runs for a touchdown
so Rook E2 and I think that that's just
over uh King has to drop back to E7
and by the way as expected
won against uh Sophie
Suzuki so we'll have one more decisive
game in the ladies
good good decides again uh King E7 on
the board and I'm expect it's not that
rookie one is the only winning move I
The Rook could just move anywhere the
whole point is that we want to play F6
check King takes F6 and E7 we just don't
want to allow them that would be a
little awkward yes exactly thanks for
showing me yeah exactly one right yes
just to stop uh the The Rook captures on
E2
you can still lose your game like that
right I mean just it's horrifying to
think you worked five six and a half
hours and with one
slip
yes that's why nobody's so gross think
about it rookie one of course easy for
Fabi but still I mean he knows it yes he
he already knows it yeah these world
champions they're so quotable but I I
still absolutely adore this quote that
Magnus Carlson uh is doing a press
conference in Norway in a young
Norwegian boy he said you know when did
you learn to stop crying after a loss
Magnus said well what makes you think I
stopped crying
he felt a lot better about himself Rook
E1 on the board four seconds on the
clock Rook takes A2 please don't play F6
please don't play F6
yeah I think Christian is very hard the
first of five is you speak
second leads his good friend so it's
nice of course
[Applause]
right right objective and neutral at all
absolutely yes of course I mean I mean
we all actually are of course but just
even still we have emotions except where
our favorites are concerned we're very
objective uh by the way again uh big uh
hearty congratulations to you and Fabi
Christian for your c squared podcast
broadcast I see that they're doing
remarkably well uh so you know Kudos and
that's uh for that and now we have a
victory we have a victory we do have a
victory Fabiano yes take starius down in
a really topsy-turvy game because
Fabiano was worse at some point he was
worse but once again the big problem
that Darius had was his time management
he had 30 seconds playing on increment
every single move for the last 15 moves
and even if you're better and even if
you have great chances you're not going
to be able to assess the position
correctly on every single turn and this
is exactly what happened Fabiano slowly
slowly turned it around and then managed
to deliver the final blow well the open
section heard your criticism at the
start of the broadcast Christian where
you were saying that the open players
only had a 28 percentage of Victories
whereas the ladies had a 57 percent uh
victories we were averaging two per
round we already have three with Lavon
still suffering against Sam sevillana
potential I want to say of yet one more
win in the open section
more likely a draw but still I that I
would love to play White's position
especially he gets levonne aronia he
must suffer
I would prefer to have more time
because still one minute 42 seconds but
you can see that also Levon has already
like 10 10 minutes he's slowing it down
as well because he understands that the
position is actually really requires a
toughness and again we all we need to do
is make it as difficult as possible for
Sam sevillan but let's turn to Christian
who we have special guests in studio
thank you Yasser we are here with Ru
Yang Yang after her first Victory here
at her first U.S Chess Championship
rouyang welcome to the show
congratulations
how do you feel right now after your
first Victory I feel pretty good I
so it's always exciting let's take a
look at the game because it definitely
felt like it was quite a dominant
display by you yeah except like the
opening part
did she surprise you at any point
I was expecting her to go like Ace like
takes takes in the A6 or like Knight C6
um
yeah but she decided with this new idea
Knight f693 and D6 for her is this a new
idea
um
um usually I think people go like you
know you see six
um this there's like there's like a
whole other like system I guess and then
um D6 uh D6 I've like never like seen
this before but I guess it kind of went
into some nighter position
um except after like fish should be it's
like neither but they should be there in
the black plays E6 yeah
um I wasn't I usually don't play this
side so A6 F3 well this basically
transposed into some sort of I think
there's like some G4 idea somewhere yeah
it's a chef yeah right yeah B5 uh Queen
D2 eighth
A4 okay very interesting yeah I thought
for a long time here because I was
worried about some um A4 and like black
has some like D5 ideas except like B4
she did that in the game but I think
after Knight A2
um and then instead of D5 she could I
think I was calculating like her playing
E5 first but it might not be that good
E5 that'd be three and then D5 yes
baby I don't know I wasn't sure about
this I mean I it says like White's
better but I I wasn't sure it's not that
clear yeah right
um but she decided against that she
decided to start immediately in the D5
and then E5 Knight D7 F4 and he managed
to change the structure yeah were you
happy with this change yeah
um this is like kind of like a French
like structure
um and
and I've like her pawns on B4 upon B4 is
kind of like weak and if you have a
place A5 I could the B5 squares week so
it's this like it's kind of hard to do
something about that pawn
um Bishop D3 Bishop D3 Knight takes you
decide to take with a c Pawn open up the
C file it also controls the C4 and E4
Square that's very nice yeah yeah that's
a good point
um Bishop to C5 I think it's a it's a
bishop B7
um I was calculating Bishop E3
um D4 yeah I saw Queen I think I saw
Queen G4 and then takes takes Rook d8
Knight B3
um that that I save upon that is correct
if you take on day three Knight to C5
this is just simply yeah losing very
nice fine by you and she decided against
that probably because I think she also
saw that
I think I was just better here
um I think and I suffered like I feel
like I play Kind like unprecisely uh
like I like maybe like Bishop like
Bishop D4 Queen F2 I mean I think it was
fine but I feel like I she got some
things okay
yes Queen 57
but still you you have this strategical
grip long term strategical grip it seems
like
it wasn't that good I I mean I'm like up
a pond but she has to do something
because finally she gets the bishop she
can't like she can't allow me to play D4
because yeah then you get everything you
you want in the position and she did
allow you to play the move d4 and now
now this is good
Ryan congratulations
um how did you prepare for this event
this is your first U.S women's
championships you're going to be facing
so many champions of the past and
potentially of the present how did you
prepare
um I mean I I like really prepared too
much I just went through my openings and
just tactics and things
um yeah
we hear a lot of uh you know the
Jennifer use of the competition saying
that they have to balance the academic
career with trust you have to do that as
well you're in high school right now
yeah and how does that work yeah I'm
missing a lot of school so I have to do
like do like do like the homework and
essays like during the tournament so the
professors will not allow you to take
them later on in in the Academic Year no
probably not
guys they don't cut you any slack uh
you know you you've got an excuse not
every student has this has an excuse
that you have sorry teacher I couldn't
do my homework I went to the U.S
championships
and what is more important for you by
the way to study or let's say your chess
career
what is more important what is more
important your study or your chess
um I I it's like a bit of both right now
um I mean and I'm only like in sophomore
year so uh yeah probably like next year
I have to focus on like APS and stuff
so right yeah like I'm trying to keep it
balanced and trying to let schoolwork
consume me
brilliant congratulations big victory
for you yeah yeah thank you keep up the
good work indeed uh turning our
attention to uh begum's game versus
Rochelle uh the two pawns are actually
uh going to win the game uh last move
Bishop B7 just hinting that you can't
just go H5 H7 as there will be a bishop
check but these two bridesmaids you get
to play E5 e pardon me e67 and then you
get to play uh H is six so E7 threatens
the queen you gotta stop it and then
this and now there's no stopping H7 and
uh White will Queen her Pond for begum a
very important Victory but boy she made
it uh so hard and for Rochelle she was
so close ooh really really really does
hurt which is going to leave us with the
game in the open section uh between Sam
and Lavon yes
because the the game another game
between Lanier and Ray no no no no no
that's a that Bishop uh ending uh the
opposite color Bishop ending I we think
is uh yeah we discussed it some time ago
exactly
that it's really difficult to break
through here exactly
all right and Kristen back over to you
thank you Yasser we are ended with
Fabiano caruana Fabiano welcome to the
show congratulations uh very labored
victory for you take us through the game
yeah it was a bit of a
of a messy game and I didn't like my
position for a large part of it
uh but yeah he was a very long time I
actually thought that my main chance in
this game might be because he tends to
get into very serious high pressure
and you started off quite uh quickly in
the opening building up a very nice time
Advantage at this point after Knight to
H4 he thought for a very long time for
this move Rook to E8 yeah it's probably
a fine move I
I was a bit surprised by it I thought he
would play either F6 or G6 but rookie 8
he's preparing someday to get Knight of
fate
and as I I thought this queen D6 movie
played is was very annoying because he's
trying to trade Bishops
but you knew this phone no not this one
but later the later I mean this is 26.
this line he's played with white so I
wasn't too surprised that he played it
with black
because he wants to play either Bishop
D4 Bishop A3 and then Queen G4 he plays
Queen E6 back and I couldn't
I mean I really need to stop the bishop
trade but it's very difficult so I was
trying to find a square for my queen and
finally I found this very strange C1
Square
at first I just didn't want to go there
but then I forced myself to make it
because I didn't see how else like if
Queen D2
Bishop B4
and my queen has to move somewhere it's
every square is 83 ie3 A3 probably yeah
and you might have well there's problems
yeah maybe but also like he has Bishop
C5 again he has Bishop A3
I I don't see where my queen goes if
Queen E2 then Bishop A3
and once we trade vicious my queen side
becomes very weak and also my queen on
E2 is not great because my knight really
needs to go back to that square
so yeah Queen C1 was artificial but I
wasn't sure what else to do
then I I think he played well I think it
was actually the best move by the engine
yeah maybe just to keep the game going
yeah so I think this F5 plan he played
was was good it was interesting uh of
course I'm not better but anyway the
position remains tense yeah A3 was
probably a difficult decision but I
thought it's a very good move because if
you play C5 first
then I play his Knight C3 a B9 D5 Queen
d8 ab3 I get the a file and my knight
goes to a very nice e3c4 circuit and I
thought I have a very pleasant position
okay maybe it's still equal but but
definitely I'm I'm more comfortable
absolutely and then yeah at some point I
was getting much worse I was on instead
of King hate King AJ like really was a
real relief for me
were you thinking about uh
being worse at this point and maybe uh
not being happy with the fact that you
took unnecessary risks at all no I
thought my position is worse but he has
no time so I wasn't sure if my position
is worse with that in mind uh I I still
thought I was still ambitious in this
position so you're trying to play a
practical game at this point yeah I mean
he had like seconds and it's a very
complex position and he has a lot of
weaknesses so
what can I do I have to put my Rook on
E1 and yeah yeah I was thinking first
Knight F3
for that I was scared take take and F4 I
started a bit scared I was thinking if I
could run like King to B1 that would be
very nice but it's difficult to get
there Queen H5 yeah otherwise it might
work out and King G2 he plays like uh
Queen H5 or something
yeah that's because Queen two so yeah uh
Rook H6 first and the point is of Queen
E2 and F3 wins
and Rook H2 yeah so so yeah that's why I
took on D4 first
uh I didn't like it because his
structure his Bishop becomes suddenly
good
uh while here it's kind of limited and
after Bishop D4 cd4's Bishop is very
good yeah but okay I mean he still has a
weak King so rookie seven I definitely
misplayed it with this uh C3 move
uh sorry at the wrong moment
um and then yeah take Queen D5 I was
very unhappy King G1 and I thought B5 is
like so unpleasant because he stops
Queen C4 stuff and it was yeah that was
a the main move by the computer I didn't
know what I was going to do here I was
thinking maybe Knight G but the bishop
can come to c5e I might even win the a
pawn but my king is under a strong
attack and if you go on H2 maybe you
have time to go F4 yeah it gets
complicated but for sure he's better so
once you played King like he had another
chance here B5 but he allowed my knight
to E3 I was suddenly not worried anymore
after 93.
uh and then here I was already thinking
I might play for an advantage
and yeah after the time control I
thought he has a really difficult
position
uh okay his moves were natural Queen D4
I thought is
and then he found this brilliant
resource you know it's uh
like I had already kind of calculated
this from far away I thought okay
wait rookie five rookie five
and rookie five yeah
yeah why didn't I do this
that was you know I have a hard question
I thought he had like Queen C1 here on
King G2 F3 but I just have Rook rookie
one you prefaced it well though you said
he found this Brilliance wait but Quincy
one is on
okay one Rook D1 uh and Queenie Queen
[ __ ] G8 and I have Queen G4
26 King h8 Quincy
yeah I probably should have exerted
myself more here I was still trying to
Blitz him and I thought Queen C7 was
winning this queen C3 was amazing yeah I
mean it's his only chance yeah it's I
just missed it I thought I'm winning
after Queen C7 and the point is Queen F7
uh looks winning at the store but yeah
take take King F1 Queen H3 King E2 Queen
G2 King D3 oh Queen E3 King E3 Queen G3
is a repetition because I can't go to D2
so I have to go forward King Rook d8
King C4 Queen C2 King B4
Queen D2
I was trying to calculate uh King A3
here I thought that at the very least
he has Rook uh A8 like I just calculated
one draw for him and that was that was
not for okay for Queen D6 and if B4
there's a funny mate here Queen D3 and
if I play Queen B3
take King takes teenage sex so
um so yeah I saw that he has a draw here
and uh and then I was just forced to go
for The Rook ending which is very
unpleasant but yeah felt very drawish as
well
where did you feel he made the last
mistake
oh yeah those Rook F2 is tricky yeah
Rook C was probably Incorrect and here
well okay it's clear the last mistake is
where it takes up four yes he can play
rookie eight here I was gonna play like
Rook A4 take
uh Rook A3
take take I mean very good winning
chances but whether it's winning or not
I don't know
what taking I don't know what he was
thinking I mean my pawns are are
connected they can't be taken they just
run forward I think he probably panicked
in time trouble definitely panicking
time travel he was playing on increment
for the last 30 moves or so Fabiano this
is a big victory for you with the white
pieces to start successfully uh the
campaign for another championship how do
you feel your chances are looking at
right no I mean it's a decent start but
it's still so early it's such a long
tournament and 10 more games it's like a
full tournament ahead so I can't really
say much but yeah this is a pleasant
pleasant win to have an important one
for sure guys any questions our
congratulations Fabby uh keep up the
good work we enjoyed uh the game
immensely yes and I was wondering also
are we going to see new new chapters of
in podcasts during the tournament are
you going to do something new or you
will be focusing on there was one
yesterday guys uh yes for sure you have
this guy in the studio all day and
you're asking me
yes but Christian said that your
motivation that you have to play well
not only for yourself now but also for a
podcast so do you feel this extra
pressure on your shoulders no I don't I
tend to separate uh playing chess and
and other activities so this this
tournament would be important for me
regardless of whether or not we were
making a podcast
okay all right uh quickly fappy just
because you're in studio turning your
attention to the game between Lanier and
Rey uh you probably realize that they're
in this bishop savop is a color Berlin
ending for quite some time just your
knee-jerk reaction draw or win for white
but it uh has to be a drawn up it has to
be a drug and White's only ideas I guess
uh E6 and in F6 yeah because if you play
E6 takes up six then E5
uh I guess he's trying to go to
to uh C5 I don't know but there will be
Bishop attacking the pawn
that's that point yeah at some point
like yeah you just forwarded he could
just put his King on C6 and then once
like let's say
he waits Bishop A2 kingy
I mean again King E3 allows yeah Bishop
D6 Bishop B3
King E3 Bishop A2
King D4 just King C6
let's say Bishop C5 you just wait and uh
White's only idea is E6
take F6 but then E5 take Bishop F7
and we have a fortress
yeah King D7 King I mean the usual but I
thought he had very good winning chances
before I mean once he got F4 and it
looked like extremely unpleasant
uh but Rey is a ray is an excellent
Defender I mean much earlier with the
two Rooks on the board I thought ah
should be serious seriously unpleasant
for black this this position but
but uh maybe it's it's nothing
um all right thank you very much for
that Fabi as uh we're round three is
drawing to a close we have one uh very
very important game uh here where we're
we think there's uh it's a two result uh
situation and after three rounds all the
ladies are completed their games
Anastasia yeah on top yeah so we have
ellisley and Megan Lee both of them they
have two and a half points no Bobby
Fisher Price for anybody yes they lost
half a point today and that's it I mean
no 100 score anymore I beg you want her
game and she jumps on the third place I
mean she ties for third place together
with status and Jennifer you yeah Tata
by virtue or victory over Jennifer you
uh now is it too and Arena crash uh
still at fifty percent three draws in a
row yes Rue young also has one and a
half points the same as Thalia so month
is also one and a half points and Sabina
for sure joins them with one and a half
points and actually all ladies scored
points there is no one who has zero
everybody's on the board
and Christian is with our latest winner
well back in first of all as your coach
are you trying to give me a heart attack
for yesterday the wife or yesterday it
was your like mistake you know I lost
the game so your loss was mine okay I'll
take it I'll take it explained to us uh
today's game oh my God
at some point I I thought I was like
winning and I don't know what happened
so it was a successful opening it felt
look at you
I'm being attacked hero okay we have the
xc6 F6 C6 yes that's pretty decent
uh here okay uh Queen B6 I didn't like
this move Queen is not doing anything
like I felt like she had to play at
night somewhere like eight yeah night
night of six or night age six she needs
to develop an
um anyways and she has to somehow
protect these six Pawn so that's why I
thought after Queen B6 my position
should be winning because 95 and 92 is
coming
and it was indeed and I think her only
chance was something very unnatural to
go here here take a now long Castle
um
yeah yeah this one should be like this
one is definitely winning as well you
have to be a bit careful but it's still
winning
but then something happened yeah
something happened I wasn't sure about
A4 I I wanted to play immediately before
B4 okay yeah but I thought it would be
too much I don't know maybe I just had
to go for it ctxp Bishop E3 have you
have you learned about this thing called
development
[Laughter]
take your pieces out
if you take on before I developed with
the tempo you know I've talked I've been
told that if he can develop with the
temple it's always good yeah some people
will blame me that I'm not teaching you
development stuff all right and you
played this uh before Cafe take take
and I guess once again have you
[Laughter]
the original idea was just to play
Bishop E3 then we got the position
before we got position at some point I
just realized that I have a very
interesting mode D4 the idea is that if
she takes on D4 then I'm playing Bishop
F4 so I'm developing the Bishops
just giving away a pawn it's not a lot
I'll take that I'll take that okay it
was just a beautiful move I I did
understand like after age six it's not
that clear but I thought my knight on H4
would be better than uh on G5 and she
had time trouble that's why I thought
I'm putting some pressure on her did you
spot this uh extra option of Knight to
G4 for her but I thought I'm better
after 94. night takes G6 or then I'm
playing Bishop F4 and then Rook takes a
four
then D3
oh
whoa what's your idea so the idea was
that if you take you you're not going to
take you're going to give a Chuck and
then Knight to E5
but okay it's it's difficult it's very
difficult on the clock
and until her king is not that safe no
no I would be glad to have this position
I don't care about the engine
it makes us of course
um and she played Bishop E8 and it felt
like you're finally breaking through
right I wasn't sure if Bishop B8 was a
correct move like I didn't see I I had
the feeling that after Bishop B8 I'm
just winning because everything is
collapsing right and then I don't know
what I did wrong it just
I don't know well
I think you know what you did wrong
Bishop E5 Rook B7 right F3 Rook f8
oh see oh my goodness
development oh please what is your queen
doing
um no I had this idea I don't know why I
thought after Bishop B6 and Bishop A6
I'm just winning
so you calculated Bishop Texas yeah I
thought I'm just winning I didn't see
any moves and I didn't have much time
that's why I decided to go for it and
then after I got the position I was like
oh my God what I'm gonna do after Bishop
this album
that was
that was bad
yes uh but you kept going and when did
you feel like you're getting some extra
chances once again at what point uh I
after I saw that uh I can play Rook A7
and Bishop uh C7 I felt okay I'm going
for it but I I repeat it because I I had
like very low time
so basically this position I thought I'm
gonna win this position uh okay again
the engine can sure can hold it I do
believe it but like as a human how would
you play this position like your knight
a little bit stuck and I'm taking the
three Pawn anyways and you have uh like
weak pawns G6 and then H6 I I just
didn't see how she's gonna like uh play
I couldn't see the setup for her so I
was like probably I'm gonna win this
position so given that you did miss that
move Bishop to D7 you managed to
readjust psychologically and still play
for a win I was happy to have a play but
like uh I wasn't forced to just repeat
the moves that's uh that's why I was
like okay if I have a chance I'm just
gonna try absolutely and then you got
into this and Bishops of opposite color
position I'm not sure about 93 but it
felt like after 93 I have huge chances
to win the game okay like yeah I should
be very careful I shouldn't miss this H4
idea and I need to place my uh Bishop on
D6 which uh like which always holds
because of E6 that was my idea before I
played 96 93 I imagined that I I play C5
Bishop D6 G3 and King goes to F6 and
that's how I should be winning
I don't know like yeah and let's go
towards that moment because it did he
found some good uh like moves I guess
and here she played this move King too
yes that was a disaster like King needs
to stay on this King to C6 and how are
you planning on trying to make progress
at this point
um probably I'll put King on a F5 okay
now it seems like Bishop to E8 might be
the only move
which is not an amazing move through
to
make
your idea is to play Bishop D7 and King
D5 that's how you want to hold it yes I
also thought if I can like if she can
get that position she has like but what
if you push your Pawn all the way to E6
now
and this is the key now you have it
seems H4
now it works for some reason yeah
well she didn't find it she played them
of King to E6 and after that she didn't
have time to find anything she did not
yes yes it's a huge Factor that's why I
just went to this end game okay I'm not
like it's not easy for her uh to play
this and I'm not forcing anything
so she needs to find moves in like 30
seconds it's like insanely hard in the
in such positions I guess it's easy to
blunder
congratulations back him a big victory
bounce back victory for you after
yesterday's loss how would you assess
your performance so far oh yesterday was
a disaster I was marching my king on e4
which was which was a great idea I'm
happy about my idea even today about
like B4 and D4 moves I'm finding some
good uh like ideas beautiful moves to
play but I'm not like
uh finishing of my opponents
yeah yesterday it was adjustable under I
I meant to play G6 first but for some
reason I thought like king after is not
good I was looking for other moves and
it was just a blunder like I forgot
about Jesus idea so so far it's all
right a win is a win two out of three
still in third position right now thank
you patience beg him can I ask a
question uh I know that vegan she comes
from chess family her father plays chess
her sisters everybody glitches and even
though they're in Uzbekistan right now
do they follow the tournament I mean are
they checking your games online or they
do it next day I mean of course like my
family everyone like checks my games my
results but sometimes it's too late I
guess like now it's 2 or 3 A.M there so
probably
my sisters are not watching but my dad
might be watching so he's my huge fan he
always watched my games at life yes do
you feel their support when you play any
Tournament of course I I just know that
they're always by my side they they have
been like my whole life huge support for
me I know that they are for me all the
time yeah and the last question like
begging played on the first board for
the national team and I was wondering
like does it do you feel like extra
responsibility now that you kind of need
to prove something maybe even win in
this Championship no I never feel like
I'm responsible to prove some something
to someone else other than me so other
than myself I'm just playing here uh
I think I'm just like as others trying
to play my past chess that's all I don't
I never thought about like oh I had the
fourth sport I have to like show
something now okay thank you and
congratulations thank you so much guys
absolutely our congratulations indeed as
we see that Lanier and Ray robson's
going right into that Fortress by the
way uh kind of a knee-jerk reaction that
Fabby gave when we asked her and only
two games left and the Ray Robson linear
game is now very very easy Fortress for
Rey he just keeps his Bishop here
whenever the black king pardon me the
white king tries to make a a b line to
the C5 Square we just stop at you you we
go King D7 and King C6 and there's no
way that this white king can ever get
over to the A6 Pawn so draw
is coming up there and it feels like um
well Lavon just defended this very very
well
Sam put a lot of pressure on his
illustrious opponent but it wasn't
enough yeah he didn't play your planet
five which I really liked so maybe
we missed this opportunity yeah I bet
also he was playing uh we just uh
on the increments at a certain moment a
little bit of time in this mismanagement
there uh by Sam but nonetheless I mean
come on putting pressure on the Vaughn
throughout the entire game yes yes it
was not an easy draw let's say not at
all not at all so anticipating two draws
in this game we will see three uh
decisive games uh in the open section
which is again also a beating track of
our uh diet of two and it's almost a
white wash well actually it is whitewash
the only player to win held the white
pieces in the openness and also true of
the
um ladies yes it is another whitewash in
the ladies three decisive games in the
ladies uh White won all the games
it's good it's good to have the white
pieces and chest
it seems it seems even though you know
that mental players are complaining that
you cannot find an advantage with white
you cannot equalize with so black I mean
life is not it's difficult I'm telling
you it was the worst thing uh preparing
I had a a match here against Anatoly
karpoff and coming into that match and
prepping for Anatoly carpa it's like
whenever I'm preparing with the white
pieces some variation for Anatoly
there's no Advantage whenever I'm
preparing the black pieces I'm slightly
worse what's going on it was it was a
terrible uh yeah terrible feelings
and uh
with uh Lanier and Ray repeating that's
that's a draw on the book says we see uh
linear and with the remaining game also
looking like it's going to wrap up we're
probably going to call the broadcast but
final words uh Christian please for this
round three well once again it was an
incredible round and I have to say uh
seeing Fabiano scoring his uh first
Victory that's bad news for the field
because we know Fabiano whenever he gets
you know a Tip-Top shape and inform he
can rank up those victories quite nicely
we've seen that in previous USGS
championships as well and in the ladies
section I have to say the a-time
national champion Irina Crush she's
really trying she's getting winning
positions almost every single game but
she doesn't have that final spark to
finish those games she will need to find
that in the remainder of the game still
plenty of rounds to go and we have a lot
of games ahead of us and a lot of
remaining rounds and we're going to be
here to call all the action yes we will
that's the good news we're going to be
back tomorrow round four same time thank
you so much for sharing your day with uh
with us all absolutely Anastasia is a
great pleasure to call the action thank
you all have a great evening and we'll
see you all tomorrow see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited